This is the 99% Invisible Breakdown of The Power Broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliot Cailin. Today we'll be going through chapters 11 through 15. That's the first section of part four, The Use of Power. With us for this episode is David Sims, the movie critic for The Atlantic and also cohost of Blank Check with Griffin and David. Hey David.
这是《99%隐形》对《权力经纪人》的深度解析。我是罗曼·马斯。我是埃利奥特·凯林。今天我们将解读第11到第15章。也就是第四部分“权力的使用”的第一小节。本期做客节目的嘉宾是大卫·西姆斯，他是《大西洋月刊》的影评人，也是《与格里芬和大卫共开空头支票》节目的联合主持人。嗨，大卫。
Hello. Thank you for having me. Well, I'm so excited that you're here. It's so funny because I was like thinking about this show, like in the middle of the night, I wake up, it's like three o'clock in the morning and I was like, I bet David Sims has read The Power Broker and I wrote you and it like you wrote me about 20 minutes later because you're like an East Coast time and you said, I love this book. I have to assume that David Sims had woken up at the exact same moment, knowing
你好。谢谢邀请我。我太高兴你能来了。这真有意思，因为我三更半夜醒来时脑子里就在想这个节目，大概是凌晨三点吧，当时我就想，我敢打赌大卫·西姆斯一定读过《权力经纪人》，于是我给你写了封邮件。大约20分钟后你就回信了，因为你住东部时间区，你说我太喜欢这本书了。我只能猜测大卫·西姆斯醒来的那一刻，正好也是
you were about to ask him about the power broker. Yeah. Is that right, David? That's of course I, I have a power broker, a Spidey sense, I guess. We can all, we can all find each other on the astral plane. Um, I, I was trying to remember if we had ever discussed it. No, Roman, but I guess we hadn't. You just sort of figured my sort of Venn diagram of interests would overlap here.
你知道即将向他询问关于《权力经纪人》的问题。是的。是这样吗，大卫？当然啦，我猜我有个“权力经纪人”版的蜘蛛感应。我们大家，我们所有人都能在星光层上找到彼此。嗯，我一直在回想我们以前有没有讨论过。没有，罗曼，但我想我们之前确实没聊过。你大概只是觉得我的兴趣文氏图会在这里有重叠吧。
You often talk about on your show about movies, you reference reading very long books and being kind of a fan of the very long book, I think. And I don't know, I just had this, I just had this feeling and I just wondered how do you feel about being someone who, uh, somebody thinks about in the middle of the night and wonders if you've read the power broker is that it is identifying character. I feel, I feel great.
你在自己的电影播客里经常谈到，你会提到阅读很长的书，而且似乎算是那种超长书籍的狂热粉丝。我不知道，我当时就是有那种感觉，我只是好奇，作为一个会被人在半夜三更想起，并且纳闷你到底有没有读过《权力经纪人》的人，你觉得这种身份标签怎么样？我觉得，我觉得挺好的。
I do think that I mean, uh, in my sort of public persona, especially on my podcast, I do talk about my love of like, you know, city subways and urbanism and you know, things like, so maybe that's- That's true. That's put out. But I have a longer history with it. I mean, so, well, I don't know. Do you want my life story here?
我确实觉得——我的意思是，在我的公众形象中，特别是在我的播客里，我的确经常谈到我对那种，你知道的，城市地铁和城市规划的热爱，你知道，诸如此类的事情。所以也许就是因为这个——没错，这就是我表现出来的形象。但我跟它有着更深厚的渊源。我是说，好吧，我不知道。你想听我讲人生故事吗？
Yes, I do, I do. It's not gonna be that long, but so I'm the child of two New York City journalists, reporters. Well, one reporter, one more of that long, but so I'm the child of two New York City Journalists reporters. Well one reporter one more of an editor, but still so I grew up with like, you know, New York City Journalism and history Sort of steeped in that a little bit And then when I moved to New York from college in 2008 the first job I got was at a newspaper called the chief I have no idea if either of you would know The Chief, anyone? Nope.
对，我想听，我当然想听。其实不会太长。我是两个纽约市新闻工作者的孩子，记者。好吧，一个记者，另一个更偏向于——其实不会太长。我是两个纽约市新闻工作者的孩子，记者。好吧，一个记者，另一个更偏向于编辑，但不管怎样，我是在纽约市新闻业和历史的氛围中长大的，多少受了点耳濡目染。然后2008年我大学毕业来到纽约，找到的第一份工作是在一家名为《首席》的报纸。我不知道你们两个是否知道《首席》报，有人知道吗？没有。
Anyone? Uh, it's a, it's a venerable weekly newspaper, uh, print, obviously paper in New York that's existed since the 1890s that is like, uh, focused on like municipal news, like civil service, unions, unions, news for city workers, right? And it's this kind of, I mean, God love it, this creaky old buttress in the sort of New York City media world. Back in the day when city reporting was robust,
有人知道吗？嗯，这是一份历史悠久的周报，当然是纸质印刷的报纸，自19世纪90年代起就在纽约存在了。它主要关注市政新闻，比如公务员事务、工会、城市工人的新闻，对吧？它有点像，说真的，愿上帝保佑它，它是纽约市传媒界一个摇摇欲坠的老古董。在当年城市新闻报道还很蓬勃的年代，
you worked at the chief and then you would sort of jump up to a job at the post or the news or whatever, you know, you would, it was sort of part of the ladder. So I worked at the chief, I covered teachers and white collar workers and DC 37, a lot of unions and all that. And I covered the city budget. And so within weeks of the job, I had to call Robert Caro on the phone because my boss, Richie Steyer, who's this venerable municipal kind of expert genius, you know, I'm writing some story about the parks department and Richie is just like,
你曾在《首席》工作过，然后你会跳槽去《纽约邮报》或者《每日新闻》什么的，你知道的，这就好比是晋升阶梯的一部分。所以我曾在《首席》工作，我负责报道教师、白领工人和第37号地方委员会（DC 37）的大量工会新闻，以及诸如此类的事情。我还负责报道城市预算。所以入职几周后，我就不得不打电话给罗伯特·卡罗，因为我的老板里奇·斯泰尔——他是那种德高望重的市政专家兼天才，当时我正在写一篇关于公园局的报道，里奇直接就说：
Hey, call, call Robert Caro. This is his phone number, like for background on, you know, Henry Stern on, on whatever, whatever, on some piece of history. And so I have Robert Caro on the phone and he immediately is basically like, well, if you could turn to this page in the Power Broker, and I was like, oh, I don't have that in front of me. And it got couriered to the office within a day.
“嘿，去给罗伯特·卡罗打电话。这是他的电话号码，你可以向他了解背景信息，”比如关于亨利·斯特恩的资料，或者任何一段历史。于是我给罗伯特·卡罗打了电话，他接通后立刻就说：“如果你能翻到《权力经纪人》的这一页……”当时我就想：“哦，我手头没有这本书。”结果不到一天时间，书就用快递送到办公室了。
He should have hung up on you immediately at that point. It was like, and I was still this baby. I think I sort of knew who he was and I knew about the book, but I was, you know, I was still like a wet-eared nobody, 22 year old trying to figure out how like collective bargaining in the city worked and things like that. And so I quickly sort of realized like, okay, well, a great way for me to steep myself in the kind of thing I have to worry about on this job, which is like how this levers of government work
当时他应该立刻挂断你的电话才对。简直就像是……而我当时还是个乳臭未干的菜鸟。我想我大概知道他是谁，我也知道那本书，但我当时，你知道的，我依然是个涉世未深的22岁无名小卒，正试图弄清楚城市里的集体谈判是怎么一回事之类的事情。所以我很快就意识到：“好吧，要想深入了解我在工作中需要操心的那些事——比如政府权力如何运作，
and what goes on in these sort of agencies is to read The Power Broker. So I read it in my early 20s as this kind of, you know, Bible of New York history, which is what it is, among other things. And then later during COVID, I finally read all of the Lyndon Johnson books. So I'm a Robert Caro nerd, I would say, at this point. I've been very, very just adoringly listening
这些机构内部究竟在发生什么——一个绝佳的方法就是去读《权力经纪人》。”所以我二十出头的时候就读了这本书，把它当成纽约历史的某种“圣经”——在众多属性中，它确实就是这样一本书。后来在新冠疫情期间，我又把林登·约翰逊的所有传记都读了一遍。所以我想说，到了这个时候，我已经成了罗伯特·卡罗的书迷了。我一直非常非常由衷地倾听
to the stuff you guys have put out so far. Oh, thank you so much. I mean, the book really is profound in this way. Like if you wanna understand this, and in fact, this is a part of like Elliot's origin story of this is like, is there somebody handing it to you and just like saying, it's like if you wanna understand anything about the city,
你们至今已经发布的内容。哦，太感谢你了。我是说，这本书确实有着这种震撼人心的力量。如果你想理解这一切——事实上，这也是埃利奥特接触这本书的起源故事的一部分，就像是有人把它交到你手上并对你说：“如果你想理解关于这座城市的任何事情，
like this is the book. This is the way city, like this is, this is the book. This is the way to do it. Yeah. This is, this is the book and uh, it's the, when I was walking, walking around New York, I was handed two books, the power broker and Dianetics and I chose one and I never looked back. Still haven't read the other one. I think I made the right choice. We'll see. We'll see how life turns out. I mean, Dianetics has got a, got a big volcano on the cover. That's pretty exciting. I mean, the power broker has, it's a, it's a crumbling statue that towers over the ground around it.
这就是必读之书。这就是城市运作的方式——这就是这本书。这就是解锁的途径。”没错，这就是这本书，而且——当我在纽约四处闲逛时，有人交给我两本书：《权力经纪人》和《科学圣经》（Dianetics）。我选择了其中一本，从此再也没有回头。另一本至今还没读过。我想我做出了正确的选择。我们走着瞧。瞧瞧生活会变成什么样。《科学圣经》的封面上有个巨大的火山，那挺刺激的。而《权力经纪人》的封面是一个崩塌的雕像，它高高耸立在周围的地面之上。
It's, it's Ozymandias transposed to the, to the New York landscape, which is still a pretty great cover. But it was, it was very much a similar thing for me that I was a production assistant at the Daily Show at the time. And it was a similar sense of like, if you're gonna understand politics, then this is the book to read. And it served me in good stead for my years there, certainly. When you're handed it, you're like,
它是把奥齐曼迪亚斯（Ozymandias）的意象移植到了纽约的景观中，这依然是一个相当棒的封面。但对我来说，经历其实非常相似。当时我是《每日秀》的制作人，也有类似的感觉：如果你想理解政治，那么这本书就是必读之书。它确实在我那几年的工作中发挥了极好的作用。当你拿到这本书时，你会觉得：
where does this book get off? It's so big. It's not just that it's 1,300 pages, but the fact that it's this sort of like Atlas sized object, you know, you're just sort of like, how could this be? But the same time you are kind of like, well, this must be a masterpiece, right? Like for it to dare exist in this form.
这书怎么这么大？它实在是太厚了。不仅因为它有1300页，更在于它是一个犹如阿特拉斯（Atlas）擎天巨石般沉甸甸的对象，你知道的，你当时就会想：“这怎么可能？”但与此同时，你又会忍不住想：“好吧，这肯定是一部杰作吧？”毕竟它才敢以这种形态存在于世。
Yeah, exactly. And it's sort of, that's what it is. It truly is. So let's get to our recap. We're gonna sort of pick up where we left off at the end of chapter 10. It's 1924 and the New York State Legislature has just passed a bill written by Robert Moses,
对，完全如此。事实也的确如此。那么让我们进入回顾环节。我们将从第10章末尾中断的地方继续。那是1924年，纽约州议会刚刚通过了一项由罗伯特·摩西起草的法案，
giving him enormous like hidden power to appropriate and govern land to the new state council of parks that is run by Robert Moses. He wants to build a string of parks connected by parkways on Long Island with his biggest dream being Jones Beach, which he envisions as the greatest bathing beach in the world. And the part that we're going to be talking about today is the use of power where we find out where he gets things done.
赋予了他巨大的、近乎隐秘的权力，可以为由罗伯特·摩西运营的新州立公园委员会划拨和管理土地。他希望在长岛上修建一连串由林荫大道相连的公园，而他最大的梦想就是琼斯海滩，他将其设想为世界上最棒的海滩。我们主要探讨的这一部分聚焦于权力的使用，我们将从中发现他是如何把事情办成的。
So Elliot, tell me about the opening of this chapter. Oh, you got it. So as you said, this is the section where he's wanted power all this time. Now he finally has it and he's going to use it. And we start with chapter 11, the majesty of the law. This chapter opens with an epigram. I love a good epigram opening chapter. I didn't look up the original source of this one because after the Sophocles quote that starts the book, I was just like, I'm not going to find carol sources sometimes. But this is a quote from Cornelius Vanderbilt, credited here as Commodore Vanderbilt as he was known. He says, law, what do I care for law?
埃利奥特，跟我讲讲这一章的开篇吧。没问题，包在我身上。正如你所说，这是他梦寐以求权力的章节。现在他终于大权在握，准备将其付诸实践了。我们从第11章开始：《法律的威严》（The Majesty of the Law）。这一章开篇有一句警句。我太喜欢用精彩的警句来开篇了。我没有去查证这一句的出处，因为在读了开篇引用的索福克勒斯名言之后，我当时就想：我有时候可找不到卡罗引用的那些出处。但这句引言出自科尼利厄斯·范德比尔特，在这里他被称为摩根·范德比尔特（Commodore Vanderbilt），这是他当年的外号。他说：“法律？我怎么会在乎法律？
Haint, I got the power. And we're going to see this is going to increasingly become Robert Moses' way of seeing things. And I love the use of the word hate, which I'm sure is how it was said and written down. It's like, this is the way that people talk in the olden days, in the olden days. It doesn't say ain't I got the power. He says, hate, I got the power.
老子难道没有权力吗？”我们将看到，这逐渐成为罗伯特·摩西看待事物的方式。我特别喜欢“hate”（编者注：原文口误，应为ain't）这个词的使用，我敢肯定这就是当年的原话和书面记录。这就好比——这就是旧时代人们说话的方式。他说的不是“ain't I got the power”（我难道没有权力吗），他说的是“hate, I got the power”。
Uh, but we're going to see this, this transformation over the course of these chapters that we're talking about today, where Robert Moses really says goodbye to the idea of legality as a way of getting things done and embraces power over, over the law and kind of running roughshod over the law. So last time he wanted this $ million dollar bond to start building parks and parkways to make this Long Island dream a reality. It hasn't passed the legislature yet. Don't worry, Governor Al Smith, he always has Robert Moses back. He gives him $225,000 from the general state revenue to start work. Moses does the important things first, rents a big office a
不过，在我们今天讨论的这些章节中，我们将看到这种转变：罗伯特·摩西真正向“合法性”这种办事的观念道了别，转而拥抱凌驾于法律之上的权力，甚至开始粗暴地践踏法律。所以在上一回中，他需要这一百万美元的债券来开始修建公园和林荫大道，好把长岛之梦变成现实。该法案当时还没在议会通过。别担心，州长艾尔·史密斯总是坚定地支持罗伯特·摩西。他从州政府的常规财政收入中拨出了22.5万美元让他开工。摩西首先做起了重要的事情：他在自己以前工作过的地方往下几个街区、
couple blocks down from where he used to work and across the street from the tiny room we finished writing the government reorganization report he is in a very literal way showing his past how much power he now has by getting an office in the same area he gets himself a black Packard limousine the top-of-the-line car and a chauffeur he starts hiring people he's known for a long time he exempts them from the civil service exams the same civil service exams he was so crazy about when he was a younger person, that he just could not get enough of civil service regulation.
以及他刚刚完成政府重组报告的那间小屋的街对面，租下了一间大办公室。他用一种非常具象的方式向过去展示自己现在拥有多大的权力——他在同一片区域设立了办公室；他还为自己买了一辆黑色的帕卡德豪华轿车——那可是顶级豪车，还配了一名专属司机。他开始雇佣那些他认识很久的人，并豁免了他们的公务员考试。就是那些他年轻时曾经狂热追求、对公务员考试制度顶礼膜拜、怎么也看不够的公务员考试。
Now when he's hiring people, he's like, forget it. We're not gonna do that. And he buys them their own cars and their own fancy office furniture. He is ready to start spending money on his favorites. And almost immediately, he's using political favors to get things done. He's doing the kinds of things that I feel like conspiracy
而现在，当他在招募人手时，他的态度是：算了吧，我们不搞那一套了。他还给他们买专属汽车和高档办公室家具。他准备开始大手大脚地为自己中意的人花钱了。几乎立刻，他就开始利用政治人情来办事。他做的那些事，让我觉得阴谋论者
theorists are always talking about where there's a classmate from Yale who knew him back when he was a student who's an assistant to Herbert Hoover, who's then the secretary of commerce. And he helps Moses get 600 acres of Fire Island Beach, that 600 new acres that wasn't even mapped yet because nobody knew it was there until he went there to see it. They're like, yeah, yeah, we'll give you that.
总是在喋喋不休：比如他在耶鲁读书时的同班同学，现在是时任商务部长赫伯特·霍华德的助手。这个人帮摩西搞到了长岛火岛海滩（Fire Island Beach）的600英亩土地——那是600英亩新土地，甚至在此之前连地图上都没有标出，因为直到他亲自去看之前谁也不知道那里有这块地。他们说：“行啊行啊，那块地给你。”
We went to Yale together, sure, that's fine. He has this land now just through his connections as part of the state government, but that's not gonna be enough. He's gonna have to go take land from other people. Is he willing to take land from other people? Yes, he's willing to take land from other people. Yes, very much so.
“咱们是耶鲁校友嘛，没问题。”他现在仅仅通过自己作为州政府官员的人脉就得到了这块土地，但这还远远不够。他必须从其他人手中夺取土地。他愿意从别人手里抢地吗？是的，他愿意从别人手里抢地。是的，非常愿意。
In a myriad of ways. He enjoys it, it seems. The chase is part of the fun for him, I think. I think that's true. It's the chase is part of the fun for him. I think that's true. It's the chase and the conquest. So he starts going out to, Long Island at the time is still kind of split up between farmland and rich people's estates.
通过各种各样的手段。而且他似乎乐在其中。我想，追逐的过程本身就是乐趣的一部分。我认为确实如此。追逐和征服就是乐趣的一部分。于是他开始前往长岛——那时的长岛依然是一半农田、一半富人庄园的格局。
And there's a little bit of housing developments. And he goes out to Long Island farmers in the evenings, when they're done with their work, he charms them into selling him the pieces of the fields that he needs for his parkway route. If they don't want to sell, the charm goes into selling him the pieces of the fields that he needs for his parkway route. If they don't want to sell, the charm goes away and he plays hardball. He condemns property.
还有少量的住宅开发区。他会在傍晚农场主们劳作一天结束后去找他们，用个人魅力说服他们把修建林荫大道所需的田地卖给他。如果他们不愿意卖，那股魅力就会消失，
We'll see a longer example of that later on in this episode. Long Island barons, they don't like this. The whole reason they got these big estates on Long Island and then bought the land around the big estates and then bought the land next to the big estates was to keep the wrong kind of people away from them. And now, Robert Moses is saying, I'm going to build parks and roads that'll bring those wrong people straight to you. And there's a specific man who decides it's going to stand up to Robert Moses.
取而代之的是强硬手腕。他会强行征收财产。我们稍后会在本期节目中看到一个更长的例子。长岛的富豪地主们可不高兴了。他们当初在长岛买下这些大庄园，接着又买下大庄园周围的土地，然后又买下挨着大庄园的土地，其全部目的就是为了把“不三不四的人”挡在外面。而现在，罗伯特·摩西却说：我要修建公园和道路，把那些不三不四的人直接带到你们家门口。于是有一位特定的人物决定挺身而出，对抗罗伯特·摩西。
His name is W Kingsland Macy, which is the names of people in the past were so on the nose. I just love it. Like if you were a wealthy guy in Long Island, you were W Kingsland Macy. Uh, if you were, if you're're gonna donate money to the Yale swim team, you were Ogden Reed Mills, I think I said, or Ogden Mills Reed, I can't remember anymore. But W Kingsland Macy, he starts a consortium
他的名字叫W·金斯兰·梅西（W. Kingsland Macy）。过去的人名真是直白得恰到好处，我太喜欢了。如果你是长岛的富有老钱，你就会叫W·金斯兰·梅西。如果你要给耶鲁游泳队捐钱，你就会叫奥格登·里德·米尔斯（Ogden Reed Mills），我想我刚刚是这么说的，或者叫奥格登·米尔斯·里德，我记不清了。但W·金斯兰·梅西，他发起了一个财团，
with a couple other wealthy people. And he's not the wealthiest of the barons, but he's a man with money. And they preemptively buy this land called the Taylor Estate that Moses is supposed to go take. And Moses calls Macy into a meeting and he goes, don't finish buying that land. I have the power to seize that land. The law says so.
联合了其他几位有钱人。他虽然不是这群大亨中最富有的，但也是个有钱人。他们先发制人地买下了那块被称为泰勒庄园（Taylor Estate）的土地——原本这块地是摩西打算去征收的。摩西把梅西叫去开会，劈头盖脸就说：“别把那块地买完了。我有权征收那块土地。法律就是这么写的。
If I want, I could go into your house and I could seize your house. I could kick you out of it. If you tried to go back into your house, I could have you arrested for trespassing. And then I would have the newspapers in New York harass you for trying to get back into your house. So don't buy that land. And W. Kingsland Macy is like, well, this isn't really the spirit of the law. I have rights as an American. And he buys that land. Moses immediately sends state troopers to take possession of it and starts working with it. And Moses is doing this with
如果我愿意，我可以走进你的房子，把你的房子没收。我可以把你踢出去。如果你试图再走回你的房子里，我可以以擅闯私宅的罪名把你抓起来。然后我还会让纽约的报纸天天骚扰你，因为你试图重返自己的家。所以，别买那块地。”而W·金斯兰·梅西则反驳说：“这根本不符合法律精神。作为美国人，我有我的权利。”于是他还是把那块地买了下来。摩西立刻派遣州警前去强占该地，并在上面开始施工。摩西对其他富豪也采用这种手段。
other barons as well. And they have their expensive lawyers start researching what Moses' law means when it says appropriating land, which as we talked about last episode, it means something different than what most people think it means. And F. Truby Davison, the rookie state legislator who put the law through, he feels really bad about introducing that bill. Like, it just wasn't what he intended it to be. And Moses just appropriating land left and right. Is anyone going to stand up to him? Roman, David.
于是这些富豪开始让昂贵的律师团队去研究摩西制定的法律中“划拨土地”到底是什么意思。正如我们上一集所讨论的那样，这个词的含义和大多数人想象的并不一样。而当初把这项法案推上台的菜鸟州议员F·特鲁比·戴维森（F. Truby Davison），对引入这项法案感到非常内疚。这根本不是他的初衷，而摩西却在到处强征土地。难道就没有人能站出来对抗他吗？罗曼，大卫。
Is anyone going to stand up to Robert Moses at this point? If they are, they're only gonna supercharge him. That's true. There's one man who's gonna do it, W. Kingsland Macy. Yeah, well, it's Macy. But the thing is, what's so interesting here is like this type, you know, when he has this power and he sort of like, he begins to show his corrupt side.
现在有人能站出来对抗罗伯特·摩西吗？如果有的话，那也只会让他变得更加势不可挡。确实如此。有一个人准备这么干，那就是W·金斯兰·梅西。嗯，确实是梅西。但问题是，这里最有趣的地方在于，这种类型的争斗——当他拥有这种权力并开始展现出他腐败的一面时，
And it's not even that corrupt. and he sort of like, he begins to show his corrupt side. And it's not even that corrupt. Like he gets a fancy car, he has a nice office, but none of it is like a crazy amount of stuff. And then he starts going after these parcels of land. And I always find myself in this section really flip-flopping on how I feel about Robert Moses because, because sometimes he's taken it from people. I'm like, yeah, sure. Go ahead and take that land from those people.
而且这种腐败甚至还算不上多严重。比如他买了一辆豪车，有了间漂亮的办公室，但这些东西算不上什么疯狂的巨款。接着他开始追逐这些地块。我发现自己在阅读这一部分时，对于罗伯特·摩西的感觉总是左右摇摆。因为有时看他从别人手里强取豪夺，我心想：没错，尽管去把那些地从那些人手里抢过来吧。
Literal land barons, essentially like modern, like who, and he, he does seem to be one of a few people who's looking at Long Island and is like, we should do something with this, right? Like which, which you sort of understand. I think what you're getting at is a, there's a thread running through this section especially of the power of the political argument of the people versus the powerful and how there is a certain, it's the thing that the framers, the constitution were worried about in terms of a demagogue who could come in, how there are certain times when it is very attractive
他们本质上就是现代的土地资本家。而且他似乎确实是少数几个审视长岛并认为“我们应该对这片土地做点什么”的人之一，对吧？这一点确实让人有些理解。我想你指出的是：贯穿这一部分的一个核心线索是政治论点的力量——即“人民”对阵“权贵”，以及人们如何看待这种博弈。这正是宪法制定者们所担忧的：一个可能会乘虚而入的煽动者。在某些时刻，从权贵和富人手里夺取某些东西并分给穷人，
to take something from powerful people, rich people, and give it to poor people. And often that is a form of justice as well. There are times when that's the right thing to do, but it's easy to overstep that boundary. And the idea of one man standing up against the wealthy for the benefit of the poor, of the many, is a very powerful argument that gets used to support Moses in this section. And when Moses is using it to do something beautiful in a way, to create these parks and to make them available to regular people, it's easy to see that as a positive thing. But it's also easy, as Carol shows it, to see the seeds of what will
具有极大的吸引力。通常这也是一种形式的正义。在某些情况下，这确实是正确的事，但也很容易跨越边界。一个平民挺身而出、对抗富人以造福穷人（造福大众）的理念，是一个非常强大的论点，在本节中被用来为摩西提供支持。当摩西利用这一点来做一些从某种意义上说很美妙的事情——比如创建这些公园并让普通人能够享用——人们很容易将其视为一件积极的事情。但正如卡罗所展现的那样，这也极其容易让人看到日后那个“坏摩西”的萌芽。摩西在劫富，那如果穷人妨碍了他的计划，他为什么不也去盘剥穷人呢？
become the bad Moses later on. Moses is, he's taken from the rich, so why shouldn't he take from the poor as well if it's getting in the way of his schemes? And we'll see that later in the seeds that are being planted here. But it's easy to overlook it, because when you're reading this book for the first time, I know it's like, do it, Moses, do it. Take that land from those barons.
我们稍后会从这里埋下的伏笔中看到这一点。但这一切很容易被忽视，因为当你第一次读这本书时，你的反应往往是：“干得好，摩西，干得好！把那些地从这群地主老财手里夺过来吧！”
They don't need it. Give it to the people. And it's that kind of back and forth that is the devil of democratic government. And he's learning here that the fastest route to what he wants is not really going to be the most legal or the most compassionate route, right? It's going to be more brutal, sort of a mix of brutality and like, you know, charm, I guess, or, you know, something a little insidious. But look, what I love about this book and about the Johnson books is
“他们不需要那些地，把它们分给人民！”正是这种反复拉锯，构成了民主政府的魔鬼面。他在此时领悟到，通往他想要的目标的最快路径，其实既不是最合法的，也不是最有人情味的路径，对吧？它会更加残酷，是残酷与魅力（或者说某种略带阴险的东西）的混合体。但瞧，我喜欢这本书以及约翰逊传记的原因在于，
what powers Caro's fascination, I think it's like, right, how much good these people did, but often the means were terrible and motivations were bad, and the results were often so, like, you know, like, but how do I measure that against, like, the great good being done? Like, that's what's so gripping about him arguing with farmers over the price of an acre where you're just like, you should be, you know, putting this book at the bottom of a gigantic pile out of total boredom when, you know, he's describing the long Island zoning to you, but you're not
推动卡罗痴迷的动力，我认为正是：这些人成就了多大的伟业，但他们的手段往往极其恶劣，动机不够纯粹，结果也常常伴随着争议。可是，我该如何将这一切与他们所创造的巨大福祉相衡量呢？这正是他最引人入胜的地方——当他描写摩西与农场主们为了一英亩土地的价格争论不休时，你可能会觉得：当你看到他对长岛分区规划的描述时，简直无聊得想把这本书扔到巨大书堆的最底层，但偏偏
it's so dramatic. He makes it so dramatic and so exciting. And it reminds me of the section reminds me of when I visited Versailles in, uh, in France, the only one time I went there and they were like, the cost of building Versailles was half the gross national product of the country. And I'm like, that's crazy. People are dying in the streets and he's building this enormous house.
他写得如此跌宕起伏、扣人心弦。这让我想起我唯一一次去法国参观凡尔赛宫时的情景。当时导游说，修建凡尔赛宫的成本相当于该国国民生产总值的一半。我想：这太疯狂了！人们都在街头饿死，而他却在建这么大一座宫殿。
But then I was like, you know what? Those hundreds of years ago, those people are gonna be gone by now anyway, but the house is still here. So like, was it a better investment? There was no way of me, I could enjoy those 18th century, 17th century Frenchmen, but I can enjoy this house still.
但随后我想：你知道吗，几百年过去了，那些人无论如何都已经不在了，但这座房子依然矗立在这里。所以，这算是一笔更好的投资吗？虽然我无法与那些17、18世纪的法国人共情，但我依然能欣赏这座宫殿。
So it's a hard thing. History is a tough business. Anyway. Well, we should talk about, because this is a real key moment here that ends up being kind of the, we talk about Robert Moses' ability to draft bills as being one of his superpowers.
所以这是一个艰难的选择。历史就是一门艰难的生意。不管怎样。我们应该谈谈这个，因为这是一个真正的关键时刻，最终构成了——我们常说罗伯特·摩西起草法案的能力是他的超能力之一。
So he affords himself all this power through this law that he passed. He changes what the meaning of appropriating kind of means for most people. But it only really works when he begins to enact it that Al Smith agrees to it. Like, and this is a real key thing. He still is relying on Al Smith for that power.
因此，他通过自己通过的这项法案赋予了自己所有这些权力。他改变了大多数人对“征收土地”这一概念的理解。但这一切真正奏效的前提，是当他开始将其付诸实施时，艾尔·史密斯表示赞同。看，这才是真正的关键所在。他依然在依赖艾尔·史密斯赋予他那种权力。
Exactly, yeah. Because he could write that law and it doesn't matter. At the end of it, executing it requires the governor to buy into it. Yes. I mean, what's so fascinating about his partnership with Al Smith, who's such a fascinating figure, and I assume you guys talked about him a lot last time,
确实如此，没错。因为他可以起草那项法律，但如果最终无法执行，那就毫无意义。执行它需要州长的大力支持。是的。我是说，关于他和艾尔·史密斯的伙伴关系，最迷人的一点是——艾尔·史密斯是个如此迷 A 级的人物，我猜你们上期节目一定详细讨论过他——
is just that Al Smith is this genuine populist, and Robert Moses doesn't seem like a populist at all, but everything he is doing here is like, like Ellie, like you're saying, is a form of populism, right? Like, yeah, this land will be for the people. Like, you know, we're gonna make Jones Beach and like, yes, insidious things will happen later to sort of make it for specific people maybe, but, and like, it's just such a funny match. And I don't know, like, would Moses have considered himself like politically aligned with Al Smith? Like probably not, right? I don't think so at all. I mean, Moses never, Al Smith is a Democrat.
那就是艾尔·史密斯是一位真正的民粹主义者，而罗伯特·摩西看起来一点也不像民粹主义者。但他在这里所做的一切——埃利奥特，就像你刚才说的——都是某种形式的民粹主义，对吧？比如：“是的，这片土地将属于人民。”比如：“我们将建造琼斯海滩，是的，虽然以后可能会发生一些阴险的事情，也许最终会让它变成某些特定人群的专属。”但这两个人的组合实在是太搞笑了。我不知道，摩西会认为自己在政治上与艾尔·史密斯志同道合吗？大概不会吧？我一点也不这么觉得。我的意思是，摩西从来——艾尔·史密斯是个民主党人。
Moses never loses his Republican affiliation. Even when he's the closest man working for the democratic governor, he is still registered as a Republican. And it's almost like Al Smith has no ideology, but he wants to help people. And so he will do whatever it takes to do that, even if it means being a little slimy. Robert Moses wants to control things and he wants to make things. And so he is willing to do nice things for people
而摩西从未失去他的共和党身份。即使在身为民主党州长手下最核心的效力者时，他的党籍依然注册为共和党。这感觉就像是艾尔·史密斯没有什么宏大的意识形态，但他就是想帮助人们。因此，为了达成目标他愿意付出一切代价，哪怕这意味着手段稍微有点油滑。而罗伯特·摩西想要掌控一切，他想要创造事物。所以，只要能让他创造出自己想要的东西，他愿意为人们做点好事。
if it means he gets to create things. You know, he had that idealistic bent at the beginning, but it was the entitled idealist. You know, it was the guy from above who feels like he knows better. Yeah. Right. Rather than the populist.
你知道的，他一开始确实带有一种理想主义的倾向，但那是属于“有特权的理想主义”。你知道的，那是那种高高在上、觉得自己比别人懂得更多的人，对吧？而不是真正的民粹主义。
He doesn't, he wants to make things for people, but he does not want the people to have the power to have decisions over those things that he makes. And I feel like Al Smith is the opposite. He would rather have the people making decisions than powerful people, unless the powerful people are him and his best friend, Bob Moses, man, Al Smith rocks. Even though Al Smith is hugely flawed figure, then he eventually hated the new deal just anytime in this book when he's like, yeah, but I'm sticking up for the little guy.
他想为人民创造东西，但他绝对不希望人民拥有对这些他所创造的事物进行决策的权力。我觉得艾尔·史密斯恰恰相反。比起权贵，他更愿意让普通民众来做决定——除非这些权贵正是他自己和他的好朋友鲍勃·摩西。天哪，艾尔·史密斯太酷了！尽管艾尔·史密斯有着巨大的瑕疵，比如他后来极其痛恨新政。不过每当听到他在书中说：“话虽如此，我还是要为小人物撑腰”时——
I know he didn't sound like that. I just, I just kind of like, I love thinking about it. Probably did a little bit. Yeah. It did sound like that actually. I take it back. One of the other things that's kind of surprising about the power broker, considering it is so much about kind of the rules of power and how institutions
我知道他当时说话肯定不是这个腔调。我只是——我就是喜欢这么想。他大概确实带有一点这种腔调。确实听起来有点像。我收回刚才的话。关于《权力经纪人》，另一个令人惊讶的地方在于，考虑到它如此深刻地探讨了权力的规则和体制是如何
work is how much it is still in that world of the influence of personality on politics. Why does Al Smith hate the new deal? Because as we'll see, he hates FDR. He doesn't like FDR. And why does, uh, why is he doing these things for Bob Moses in a big sense? Because he likes Bob Moses, you know, and that the shape of a city can be so transformed by the personality of the person. And that's much of the Johnson books as well, is it's the effect of personality on history, which is not a popular way of looking at history right now, but it's undeniable that kind of
运作的，它却依然扎根于“个性对政治的影响”这一世界中。为什么艾尔·史密斯痛恨新政？因为正如我们后面将看到的，他痛恨小罗斯福（FDR）。他就是不喜欢小罗斯福。再比如，他为什么要这么大力度地帮鲍勃·摩西？很大程度上是因为他喜欢鲍勃·摩西，你知道的。一座城市的形态竟然可以因为某个人的个性而发生如此彻底的改变。约翰逊传记中也有很大一部分在探讨这一点，即个性对历史的影响。虽然这在当下的历史观中并不流行，但不可否认的是，
larger social forces and individual personalities mix to create, you know, the world we live in. It's all part of the beautiful tapestry of the power broker, but Al Smith is about to step into this Macy fight, as we'll see. W. Kingsland Macy's lawyers, he points out that the way Robert Moses took the Taylor estate wasn't even a fair according to the law that he wrote. He created a law to let him do whatever he wants, and he still oversteps that law. And he shouldn't have appropriated that land without attempting to buy it first, without having the money on hand to legally purchase it. And Moses needs Governor Smith to sign the documents
宏大的社会力量与个人个性交织在一起，共同创造了我们生活的世界。这都是《权力经纪人》宏大而美丽的织锦的一部分。不过，艾尔·史密斯即将介入这场针对梅西的斗争，正如我们所将看到的。W·金斯兰·梅西的律师指出，罗伯特·摩西夺取泰勒庄园的方式甚至连他自己写的法律都算不上公正。他为了随心所欲而炮制了一部法律，结果却依然越过了这条法律。他在没有试图购买这块土地、没有备好现金来进行合法收购之前，根本不该强行征收这块土地。而摩西需要史密斯州长签署
appropriating this land. And Smith is like, I don't know if this whole thing is legal. Let me meet with the barons so they can press their case. And the barons screw this up so badly, this meeting with Al Smith, because it's like a scene. It's so the way Carol presents it, and I have to believe that this is how it was told him,
征收这块土地的文件。史密斯则表示：“我不知道整件事是否完全合法。让我跟这些富豪见个面，听听他们的陈述。”结果这群富豪在与艾尔·史密斯的会面中把事情搞得一塌糊涂。因为正如卡罗所描绘的那样——我不得不相信当年的真实情况确实如此——
it's so on the nose that the rich people are like, well, we don't want Long Island to be overrun with rabble from the city. And Al Smith gets mad and goes, rabble, that's me you're talking about. And he signs the form right in front of them because he's so mad in that moment. And it's again, personality and history. Maybe he wouldn't have been so eager to do it if those guys hadn't pissed him off in that moment in that specific way that he's so sensitive to. Yeah, yeah, it's amazing how Moses uses the political valence of like who is elite
富豪们的傲慢简直太直白了：“我们不希望长岛被来自城市的下三滥乌合之众给踩烂。”结果艾尔·史密斯勃然大怒，反驳道：“下三滥？你们说的这群人里可包含我！”他当场就在他们面前签署了征收表格，因为他当时实在是太气愤了。这再次印证了性格与历史的关系。也许如果那些家伙当时没有以那种戳中他敏感神经的特定方式惹恼他的话，他未必会那么急于签字。是的，没错。太神奇了，摩西竟然能如此精准地利用政治上的“精英”与“非精英”对立的情绪，在每一种特定情况下都如愿以偿。而我觉得最搞笑的是，这与当今的现实是多么的契合。
and who isn't in these ways that really get what he wants in each of these situations. And what's funny to me is how much that resonates with today. When Trump talks about the elites in these weird situations is like gold toilet billionaire talks about elites. It really is just a matter of how you present that narrative and these lawyers really fucked up when it came to talking to Al Smith.
当特朗普在那些奇怪的场合谈论精英时，一个坐拥黄金马桶的亿万富翁却在口口声声痛斥精英。这真的只取决于你如何包装叙事。而这些律师在跟艾尔·史密斯对话时，真的是把事情彻底搞砸了。
They really screwed it all up. And this court fight for the Taylor state, this is another time where we're going to watch something for a little bit. And then later we're going to skip back, you know, cause Caro is not doing everything on the same timeline. The fight for the Taylor state goes on for two years in the courts and W. Kingsland's Macy's partners, they're like, this isn't worth it, but Macy, he doesn't care about the money. It's the principle of the thing. And he's got to fight for the private property rights of Americans. And he's so old fashioned. A reporter is like, Hey, why don't you come take me to the land and show me,
他们把一切都搞砸了。这场关于泰勒庄园的法庭之争，是另一个例子：我们先看了一部分剧情，然后稍后又要回过头去补充背景（因为卡罗并不是按单一时间线来讲述的）。这场针对泰勒庄园的诉讼在法庭上持续了两年之久。W·金斯兰·梅西的合伙人们觉得：“这不值得。”但梅西根本不在乎钱，这是一个原则问题。他必须为美国人的私有财产权抗争到底。他是如此的老派。当记者问他：“嘿，你为什么不带我去那块地上看看，向我展示一下？”时，
show it to me. And he goes, no, that would, I couldn't influence your thinking on it. That would be unfair. Whereas Moses is like, yeah, I'll, I'll take whatever help I can get. And the New York times is putting out front page headlines, like a few rich golfers accused of blocking plans for state park, which is the yellowest of yellow journalism you know there's no I wish I wish that it's I whereas nowadays the Times would be like in a fight over land to competing narratives and that would be their headline you know they
他却回答：“不，那可不行。那样会影响你对这件事的看法，太不公平了。”而摩西则完全不同：“行啊，我能争取到什么帮助我都照单全收。”当时《纽约时报》头版头条赫然写着：“少数富有的高尔夫球手被指控阻挠州立公园计划”。这绝对是最具煽动性的黄色新闻，你知道的。我真希望——如果是在今天，《时报》的头条大概会写成：“在土地争夺战中，两种竞争叙事激烈交锋”，
make no judgments whatsoever but back then they weren't afraid to and the press most is using them to really portray himself as I am fighting for the benefit of regular people and rich people are trying to stop you from getting a park and a beach. And later on we'll bury it in the article in paragraph 24 or 25, that the appropriation of land was probably illegal. And in the court of public opinion, things are going well in the actual legal court, they're not going so well. Yeah, they're going poorly because there's two big problems. He, he, he's not allowed to appropriate land that he hasn't offered for purchase.
他们绝不会做出任何主观评判。但在当年，他们可不怕这么做。摩西一直在利用媒体将自己塑造为“我正在为普通人的利益而战，而富人们正试图阻止你们拥有公园和海滩”的斗士。而至于“土地征收可能并不合法”这一事实，则被悄悄埋在文章第24或第25段里。在舆论法庭上，一切进展顺利；但在真正的法庭上，情况却不那么妙。是的，情况很糟，因为有两个重大问题：他无权征收那些尚未提出购买要约的土地，
And he doesn't have the money to purchase it. And so they're not going to buy it. They're going to buy it. They're going to buy it. They're going poorly because there's two big problems. He, he, he's not allowed to appropriate land that he hasn't offered for purchase. And he doesn't have the money to purchase it. And so they, they need to rectify these two situations, like too sweet before, before, before the court, you know, rolls over them. And, and so, uh, Robert Moses is like, I need a legislature to appropriate this money for me. But the Republicans in the legislature are like, this is a great way to embarrass Al Smith
而且他也没有足够的资金来购买。所以他们根本买不起，也无力支付。情况之所以糟糕是因为存在两个重大问题：他无权征收尚未提出购买要约的土地，且手头没有资金进行购买。因此，在法院的重拳砸下来之前，他们必须赶快纠正这两个漏洞，免得法院的重锤把他们碾碎。于是，罗伯特·摩西找到议会说：“我需要议会为我拨款。”但议会里的共和党人却认为：这可是通过他最好的死党摩西来狠狠羞辱艾尔·史密斯的绝佳机会。所幸在政治层面上，舆论法庭在很多时候比法律法庭更有力量。
through his best buddy, Moses. But luckily, in the end, in terms of politics, the court of public opinion is more powerful in many ways than the court of court, court, the court of law. People love parks, and he has Al Smith. And so Moses can just use his lawyers to stall the court proceedings until Smith can bully the legislature into getting the money through so that it will appear somewhat legal. And Moses is like, Smith, hurry up. Oh, he says governor because he always calls him governor. Hurry up. Hurry up. And Governor Smith, who's the master politician, he says, wait, it's spring right now. Wait till the summer. Wait till New York gets hot. Wait till the voters are so sweaty.
民众热爱公园，而且他有艾尔·史密斯。于是摩西只需利用他的律师团队拖延法庭诉讼，直到史密斯能够施压议会强行通过拨款，好让整个过程显得稍微合法一些。摩西不停催促：“史密斯，快点！”哦，他总是尊称他为“州长”。“快点！快点！”而身为政治大师的史密斯州长却说：“等等，现在才是春天。等到夏天吧。等到纽约变得酷热难耐，等到选民们热汗淋漓，
They feel the need for a place to swim, that they feel the need for fresh air because they're so hemmed in. And so on June 10th, right as the heat is starting to build up in New York City, in the first speech ever carried on a statewide New York radio hookup, Al Smith talks for two and a half hours demonizing the opposition, the rich, calling for a special session of legislature to give the people parks. And it's not a question of the state overreaching its power. It's a question of whether the rich can stop the special session of legislature to give the people parks. And it's not a question of the state overreaching its power. It's a question of whether the rich can stop the state from giving the people what they need. He barely mentions Moses in the speech. It's all about the rich versus you.
让他们觉得太憋闷而急需一个游泳的地方，觉得太窒息而渴望新鲜空气。”于是，在6月10日，正当纽约市的酷暑开始升温之际，艾尔·史密斯通过纽约州历史上首次联播的广播节目发表了两个半小时的演讲。他在演讲中猛烈抨击反对派和富人，呼吁召开议会特别会议，把公园还给人民。这根本不是什么州政府权力过界的问题，而是富人能否阻止州政府把人民需要的东西交给他们的问题。他在演讲中几乎没有提及摩西，整篇演讲的主题全都是“富人对阵你们”。
And you're hot in your tiny apartment. You're sweating. It's terrible. And the Republicans have their own speech the next day about like, well, sacred property rights. But when you're hot, you don't care about that stuff. Like when you're a New York don't care about that stuff. When you're a New Yorker and it's summer in the city, the back of your neck's getting dirty and gritty, you don't care about that. You want a place to go.
当时你正闷热地挤在狭小的公寓里，大汗淋漓，感觉糟透了。而共和党人在第二天发表了他们自己的演讲，大谈所谓的“神圣财产权”。但当你热得喘不过气时，谁还在乎这些破事？当你身为主妇或者一个普通纽约客，在夏日的城市里被烟尘熏得灰头土脸时，你才不在乎那些呢，你只想找个地方去避暑。
And the people are so overwhelming in support of Moses and the governor's side. They flood the legislature with letters. The New York papers keep carrying stories of this fight. And it's something that you have to wonder, Roman, this is a question that you brought up when we were talking about this episode. If you're there at the time, not knowing how things will turn out, whose side are you going to take?
民众对摩西和州长阵营的支持简直铺天盖地。他们向议会雪片般地寄去信件。纽约各大报纸不断追踪报道这场争端。罗曼，这正是你在讨论本集节目时抛出的那个问题，令人不禁浮想联翩：如果你当时就在现场，在不知道结局会如何的情况下，你会站在哪一边？
I'm all Al Smith on this one. I am like all Robert Moses, all Al Smith. Like he's making that speech and I'm like, hell yeah, let's storm the beaches. It's so rare that there's a fight over public parks. Like now that this fight is always over, we want to take your land to build an arena for a billionaire sports team that doesn't want to spend one red, one red cent building it. Like, you know, like it's always something like that where it's, it's
在这件事上我绝对百分之百站在艾尔·史密斯这边。我完全支持罗伯特·摩西和艾尔·史密斯。当他在发表那场演讲时，我的心声就是：太棒了，让我们去攻占海滩吧！像这样为了公共公园而展开的抗争实在太罕见了。现在的这种土地争端，往往都是：我们要夺走你的土地，来为某个一毛不拔的亿万富翁体育俱乐部建一座体育场，而他们自己却连一分钱都不想花。你知道的，总是诸如此类的事情，它本质上就是……
easy to understand why people get angry about the construction of, you know, whatever arena. Or it's we want to take this land and build low income housing in your neighborhood and people get angry about that because with, with parks, it's the thing where everyone can use them. Even if you're middle-class or if you're lower class, everyone can use them. And so there's less of a partisan fight except against the ultra wealthy who everyone hates already. I'm just amazed that this worked so well and it all has to do with the parks.
很容易理解为什么人们会对建造什么体育场之类的东西感到愤怒。或者说我们要征用这块地在你的社区建造低收入住房，人们对此会感到愤怒，因为对于公园来说，每个人都可以使用它们。即使你是中产阶级还是下层阶级，每个人都可以使用它们。因此，党派争斗较少，除了对每个人都已经恨之入骨的超级富豪之外。我只是惊讶于这招竟然如此管用，而且这一切都与公园有关。
You know, like it just is like, I just wonder, you know, like with Moses's acumen for like all things law and politics, if he didn't have the parks as his thing, would he have gotten anywhere? Because it allowed him so much latitude to do horrible things, because he could always cloak it in the park fight. Yes, it was very lucky for him that the issue that he was kind of naturally interested in anyway,
你知道，就像，我只是在想，你知道，就像摩西凭借对法律和政治方方面面的敏锐眼光，如果他没有把公园当成他的核心事业，他能取得任何成就吗？因为这赋予了他极大的自由去干那些可怕的事情，因为他总是可以用公园之争来掩盖它。是的，这对他来说非常幸运，他本来就自然而然感兴趣的那个议题，
but that he could stumble into, because it was not being exploited by anyone else at the moment was one that's so universally beloved and it's so hard to find a... It's hard to make an argument against a park. I can't really think of one. Oh, we should have a park here so that people can enjoy themselves and it can be natural and fun and relaxing. No, we need people. I mean, I guess you could have people saying like, any distraction from work hurts the ambition of the species.
而且他能够偶然介入，因为当时没有任何其他人去利用它，这个议题是如此受人普遍喜爱，而且很难找到一个……很难找到反对公园的理由。我实在想不出一个。哦，我们应该在这里建一个公园，让人们享受乐趣，让它变得自然、有趣且放松。不，我们需要人。我的意思是，我想你会听到有人说，任何对工作的分心都会损害人类物种的雄心。
We have to get into space or something like that. But that's a pretty out there argument. And it's not one they would have been making in the 20s. I think you're right that he had this powerful issue that gave him that latitude. I think he gets into it later in the book even more as well, just underlining how little public space there was available in the city especially.
我们必须进入太空或诸如此类的事情。但这是一个相当离谱的论点。而且这不是他们在20年代会提出的论点。我觉得你说得对，他拥有这个强有力的议题，赋予了他这种自由度。我想他在书的后面更深入地强调了这一点，特别是强调了城市中可用公共空间究竟有多么匮乏。
Yes. And just like that there was like, yeah, one playground for every 150,000 kids or stuff like that where it was like, the need was really, really desperate. I guess what happens later is the people start saying like, well, we don't want a public park because we don't like what that means, what, who that'll bring or whatever. But I, in the 1920s,
是的。而且就像那样，大约每15万个孩子才有一个游乐场之类的，就好像这种需求真的、真的很迫切。我想后来发生的事情是，人们开始说，嗯，我们不想要一个公共公园，因为我们不喜欢它意味着什么，会带来什么人或者诸如此类的事情。但我认为在20世纪20年代，
I feel like Long Island is, it's not like empty, but it's, it's, it's a very quiet part of the state, right? Like comparatively, pre motor car or whatever. It's the dawn of motor cars. You'll read like nostalgic things where like, yeah, we used to play stick ball in the street. And it's like, well, you were playing in the street because there was nowhere else for you to play. The street is not a good place to play.
我觉得长岛它并不是说空无一人，但它是一个非常安静的州的一部分，对吧？相比之下，在汽车出现之前或类似的时候。那是汽车的曙光。你会读到一些怀旧的事情，比如，是的，我们以前在街上玩棍球。这就好像，嗯，你在街上玩是因为没有别的地方可玩了。街道可不是一个玩耍的好地方。
Like that's a bad place to play. Like why can't kids throw balls against stoops anymore? It's like, well, cause that's not a great place to be playing. You know, when a car could hit you or a horse could stove your head in. Horse hooves always stove things. Anyway, Carol takes a moment here to talk about some of the people who are behind the New York Times specifically, who are helping in the press. New York Times, even at the time, was the most powerful paper in New York. Now it's the most powerful paper
这就好像那是一个糟糕的玩耍地方。就像为什么孩子们再也不能把球朝台阶上扔了？这就好像，嗯，因为那不是一个玩耍的好地方。你知道，当汽车可能撞到你或者马可能会把你的马头踢碎。马蹄总是把事情搞砸。不管怎样，卡罗在这里花了一点时间谈论一些幕后推手，特别是那些《纽约时报》背后的人，他们在媒体上提供帮助。当时的《纽约时报》已经是纽约最有权势的报纸。现在它是这个国家
in the country. And the publisher, Adolf Ochs, was very close to Al Smith. His daughter, Iphigen, was this already an idealistic Parks activist. And as we'll see, she'll come to idolize Robert Moses. She will really kind of adore him and in a way worship him. And that support is going to be unquestioned for decades and will become hugely valuable to Robert Moses as he embarks on his projects. And there's all this lobbying behind the scenes. There's all this kind of backroom politics stuff. They decide to hold a conference of regional parks commissioners on the day that the legislature session opens.
最有权势的报纸。出版商阿道夫·奥克斯与阿尔·史密斯非常亲近。他的女儿伊菲根当时就已经是一个理想主义的公园活动家。正如我们所看到的，她后来会开始崇拜罗伯特·摩西。她会真的有点爱慕他，甚至在某种程度上崇拜他。这种支持在几十年里将是毫无疑问的，并将对罗伯特·摩西展开他的项目变得极为宝贵。幕后有各种游说活动。有各种各样的密室政治把戏。他们决定在立法机关开会的那天召开一个区域公园专员会议。
They can all be there cheering when parks are brought up. Just kind of classic old fashioned political theater that works. And it doesn't work. The republics hold firm. They defeat Moses Park money bill. He doesn't have it. The purchase aren't there. He's losing land they could be buying worse now the taylor state appropriation
这样当提到公园时，他们就可以都在那里欢呼。这简直是一种经典的老式政治把戏，而且确实管用。但它又不管用。共和党人坚守阵地。他们击败了摩西的公园资金法案。他没有资金。买地的钱没有到位。他正在失去那些本可以买下的土地，更糟糕的是，现在的泰勒州拨款
really is not legal they've got to get this money from somewhere so that they can make it look kind of legal that's when they turn to mrs muskowitz and she just says the name that i'm sure we've all been thinking up to this point august heckscher. And he is a millionaire, he's a famous millionaire. He agrees to give them the money in exchange for naming the park after him. And it still is, it's called Heckscher State Park. It's still there. He was zinc.
确实不合法，他们必须从某个地方弄到这笔钱，好让它看起来有点合法。就在这时，他们求助于莫斯科维茨太太，而她脱口而出的名字，我敢肯定我们所有人在这一刻都在想，那就是奥古斯特·赫克斯舍。他是一个百万富翁，一个著名的百万富翁。他同意把钱给他们，条件是以他的名字给公园命名。现在依然如此，它叫赫克斯舍州立公园。它还在那里。他做的是锌生意。
I always like looking up those guys where you're like, where'd they get the money? He's like, I don't know, zinc. The guy just had a ton of zinc. That was his thing. That was his racket. Robert Carrow describes him as a wee man who has little tufts of white hair
我总是喜欢去查那些家伙，你会想，他们的钱是哪儿来的？他就像，我不知道，锌。这家伙就是有一吨的锌。那是他的营生。那是他的门道。罗伯特·卡罗把他描述为一个瘦小的男人，有一撮撮白头发，
and when he sits in a chair, his feet don't touch the ground. Which is, which, the image that conjured in my mind was Mr. Mixleplick from the Superman comics, you know? Sure. It just sounds like that to me. You have to imagine when Moskowitz said his name, he just appeared in the air floating around them was like money for a parking need.
当他坐在椅子上时，他的脚都够不到地面。这，这让我的脑海中浮现出的形象是超人漫画中的米克尔里克先生，你知道吗？当然。听起来就是那样。你必须想象，当莫斯科维茨说出他的名字时，他就凭空出现在他们头顶上方飘来飘去，就像是在为公园的需求送钱。
Oh, well, let me move 1000 tons of zinc. Powered by zinc. Yeah. Because they, they, they, they make this calculation that they can't go like what you'd normally do when you're fundraising for a thing is talk to a lot of people and try to get support and maybe collect it. They know that if people find out that they're asking for the money because they don't have the money, they're going to be in big trouble. So they have to ask one person who Belmosk with says, we'll say yes.
哦，好吧，让我搬动1000吨锌。靠锌驱动。Yeah。因为他们，他们，他们，他们做出了这样的计算，他们不能像你平时为某件事筹款时那样去做——和很多人谈谈，试图获得支持并筹集资金。他们知道，如果人们发现他们筹钱是因为他们根本没钱，他们就会陷入大麻烦。所以他们必须问一个人，而莫斯科维茨说这个人会答应。
And that's August Hckscher, which is, uh, which is crazy. Yeah. And it's, it is the exact opposite of the theory of democratic politics and governance that it's like, Oh yeah, well, we couldn't get this money through the democratic process. So we'll go to one rich man in the, in this fight between the powerful and the poor. We're going to go to this one rich man to make it happen, but it's a, it's a complicated business politics court battles going badly. The judge rules against Moses. Meanwhile, these towns in Long Island that Moses needs the approval of to build
那就是奥古斯特·赫克斯舍，这真是，这真是太疯狂了。是的，这完全违背了民主政治和治理的理论，就像是，噢，是的，好吧，我们无法通过民主程序弄到这笔钱。所以我们要去找这个斗争中的某个富豪，在权贵与穷人的这场斗争中。我们要去找这个唯一的富豪来促成此事，但这是一场复杂的政治博弈，法庭诉讼进展不顺。法官对摩西作出了不利判决。与此同时，摩西需要其批准才能建设
his Jones beach dream and his roads are turning against him. There's a public referendum to allow park development in Hempstead on Long Island. It gets voted down and Moses is like, I'm this is all slipping away. I'm not going to be able to build any of this. My, my land options are lapsing. The parkway land negotiations are halted. Developers are starting to buy up the land I need and they're building little houses on it, which is not what I wanted. And this is when the chapter ends with one of Caro's most beautiful kind of teased transitions.
他的琼斯海滩梦想和道路的长岛城镇正在与他作对。长岛亨普斯特德举行了一场允许公园开发的公开公投。结果被投票否决了，摩西觉得，这一切都在从我指缝中溜走。我将无法建造任何这些设施。我的土地选择权正在失效。公园大道土地谈判陷入停滞。开发商开始买下我需要的土地，并在上面盖小房子，这根本不是我想要的。这一章就在卡罗最具美感的一个悬念转折中结束了。
He says, this is on page 206. It had been a year since Robert Moses had announced his revised and broadened park and parkway plan. Now, more than a year later, parks and parkways were still located nowhere but in the map of Moses' imagination. After all the talking, all the planning, all the fighting, they simply didn't exist. And at the end of 1925, there seemed little possibility that they would come into existence at any time in the foreseeable future. If one looked ahead a decade, even a generation, it seemed unlikely that any substantial part of the dream would be a reality. New paragraph indent.
他说，这在第206页。距离罗伯特·摩西宣布他修改和扩大后的公园与公园大道计划已经过去了一年。现在，一年多过去了，公园和公园大道依然只存在于摩西想象的地图上。在所有的谈话、所有的规划、所有的斗争之后，它们根本就不存在。而在1925年底，在可预见的未来里的任何时候，它们似乎都几乎没有成为现实的可能性。如果展望未来十年，甚至一代人，梦想中的任何实质部分都不太可能成为现实。新段落缩进。
Within three years, almost all of it would be reality. What? How did that happen? We gotta find out in the next chapter. It's because you counted him out, you fools. You thought he was dead. No one puts Moses in a corner. Nobody. Exactly. Him standing with his hands on his hips
但在三年内，几乎所有这一切都将变成现实。什么？怎么会这样？我们必须在下一章中找出答案。那是因为你们这群傻瓜把他排除在外了。你们以为他死定了。没有人能把摩西逼入绝境。没有人。没错。他双手叉腰站在
on a beach or something. Oh, God. We could do a whole, like, at the end of this whole project, we could just do a whole episode on the last sentences of each of Robert Caro's chapters. They're so good. They're so good. He has incredible flair. He's really good at finding the dramatic core
沙滩上或类似的地方。哦，天哪。我们可以做一整期，就像在这个宏大项目的最后，我们只需做一整期关于罗伯特·卡罗每一章最后一句话的节目。它们太棒了。太棒了。他有着令人难以置信的才华。他非常擅长找出戏剧核心
of a moment, cutting through to what is the dramatic question that has to be answered. And guess what? In the next chapter, I'm gonna tell you how we answer it. And you're like, I gotta find out. But we'll get to that chapter after this break. Okay. This is the new chapter. It's chapter 12, Robert Moses and the creature of the machine.
的时刻，直击必须回答的戏剧性问题。你猜怎么着？在下一章里，我会告诉你我们是如何解答的。而你会想，我必须去一串究竟。但我们会在这次中场休息后进入那一章。好的。这是新章节。这是第12章，罗伯特·摩西与机器的造物。
Where are we now? So this is a one where at right, you've just said one of the coolest titles, I think in any chapter in any book that, uh, uh, the creature of the machine. Don't get your hopes up. We haven't gotten to the curator of cauliflower yet. So that's true. That's true. Last chapter in this section, this episode was the curator of cauliflower and the first chapter of next episode is going to be the feather duster, which, which shouldn't sound cool, but it does. So Robert Moses and the creature
我们现在在哪里？所以这是一个，对吧，你刚才说了一个最酷的书名，我认为这是任何一本书中任何一章里最酷的书名之一，呃，机器的造物。别抱太大希望。我们还没到花椰菜馆长那里呢。所以那是真的。那是真的。本节的最后一章，这一集的最后一章是花椰菜馆长，而下一集的第1章将是鸡毛掸子，听起来不怎么酷，但确实很酷。所以罗伯特·摩西与机器
of the machine, which again, it sounds like he used a machine to build a creature, which is fantastic, but that's not what he does. This is, it's 1925 going into 1926. And at this point, Caro takes a moment to stop us and to say, let's talk about the political power of parkways, of roads that open up new areas. They're a potential source of enormous wealth for politicians. Parkways mean that the government has to buy a lot of real estate. It means the government has to hire a lot of workers and contractors. It means that a lot of businesses that were isolated before are now reachable by road. Land that was not valuable because it was too distant is now valuable because it's within close distance.
的造物，这再次听起来像是他用一台机器制造了一个生物，这太棒了，但这不是他做的事。这是1925年过渡到1926年。在这个时候，卡罗花时间停下来对我们说，让我们谈谈公园大道的政治权力，即开辟新区域的道路。它们是政客们巨大的财富潜在来源。公园大道意味着政府必须购买大量房地产。这意味着政府必须雇用大量的工人和承包商。这意味着许多以前孤立的企业现在可以通过公路到达。那些因为地处偏远而没有价值的土地现在因为距离较近而变得有价值。
And if politicians are aware of where these roads are going, they can buy land along those routes. They can get contracts to the people that are connected to them. They can give tip offs to people in exchange for money. They can make a lot of money. If they own businesses in those areas, those businesses will now be worth more. There's a lot of ways to make money off of a new road. If you know where the road is going and in previously Robert Moses, the idealist, the democratic purist, is he going to play that game of getting votes by telling them where they should buy land ahead of time?
如果政客们知道这些道路将通往何处，他们就可以沿途买地。他们可以把合同给那些与他们有联系的人。他们可以向人们泄露内幕以换取金钱。他们可以赚很多钱。如果他们在这些地区拥有企业，这些企业现在就会更值钱。从一条新路上赚钱的方法有很多。如果你知道路通往何处，而在此之前罗伯特·摩西这位理想主义者、民主纯粹主义者，他会通过提前告诉人们应该在哪里买地来玩这种通过选票谋取利益的游戏吗？
Roman. No, sir. No, sir. That is against the spirit of democracy or whatever. He refuses. In 1924, he announces park plan. They say, where's the roads going to go? We want to make some money. And he says, no, I refuse. And in 1925, there was that Hempstead referendum. He still is refusing to give inside knowledge to the guy who can sway that.
罗曼。不，先生。不，先生。这违背了民主精神或诸如此类的东西。他拒绝了。1924年，他公布了公园计划。他们说，路要通往哪里？我们想赚点钱。而他说，不，我拒绝。而在1925年，发生了那场亨普斯特德公投。他仍然拒绝向能够左右这一结果的人透露内幕消息。
NASA County GOP boss, G Wilbur Doughty, but his dreams are falling apart. So in 1925, that's gonna change. He's not gonna stand by that anymore. And Caro says, look, there's no record of a deal on paper. I cannot prove that there was an agreement by the standards of Robert Caro, which means it has to be written down on paper or he has to be told it by someone who either was there or talked to witness. But he goes, here's what happens. Moses says, oh, I'm going to work on this parkway with a commission led by a crony of G. Wilbur Doughty, who Moses has previously called this crony the creature of the machine. That's where the title comes from.
拿骚县共和党老板G·威尔伯·多蒂，但他的梦想正在破灭。所以在1925年，这一切将发生改变。他不会再坚持这一点了。卡罗说，看，纸面上没有任何交易记录。我无法根据罗伯特·摩西的标准证明存在一项协议，这意味着它必须写在纸上，或者必须由某个在场或与目击者交谈过的人告诉他。但他说，事情是这样的。摩西说，哦，我要和一个委员会合作这条公园大道，该委员会由G·威尔伯·多蒂的一个亲信领导，摩西以前曾称这个亲信为机器的造物。这就是书名的由来。
He was so disgusted by this guy being a creature of the machine. But not long after that, there's a politically connected lawyer who starts a corporation whose only business as a corporation is purely to buy 265 acres of seemingly worthless land, lands that nobody has any use for, which happen to be needed for the right of way for the Meadowbrook Causeway, which is part of the Parkway that's being built. Contracts to build the causeways, maybe by coincidence, they go to a contractor that's owned by Doughty's brother-in-law. And then Doughty throws his supportin-law, and then Doughty throws his support behind Moses Parkway plan and he tells Moses,
他对这家伙作为一个机器的造物感到如此厌恶。但没过多久，一个有政治背景的律师创办了一家公司，这家公司唯一的业务纯粹是购买265英亩看似毫无价值的土地，这些土地没有任何人有用途碰巧是建设美多布鲁克堤道所需的通行权土地，该堤道是正在建设中的公园大道的一部分。建造堤道的合同，也许是巧合，交给了多蒂的姐夫拥有的承包商。然后多蒂将他的支持投给了摩西的公园大道计划，并告诉摩西，
rewrite the referendum, resubmit it. Let's see what happens. And the referendum that lost by a three-to-one margin in 1925 suddenly wins by a three-to-one margin in 1926, giving the Long Island Park Commission, essentially, control of Jones Beach. Now, can you prove a crud pro quo? Carow says you can't, but I mean, it's basically, it seems unlikely that there was not one there. He's doing the thing he needs to do. He's getting his hands dirty in order to make his dream a reality. And it's the only way he can do it, it seems. There's some election year wrangling in Albany that we don't need to get into it.
重写公投，重新提交。让我们看看会发生什么。而那个在1925年以三比一的差距落败的公投，在1926年突然以三比一的压倒性优势获胜，从而实际上让拿骚县公园委员会获得了对琼斯海滩的控制权。现在，你能证明这是一场权钱交易吗？卡罗说你不能证明，但我的意思是，基本上，似乎不太可能那里没有发生过这种交易。他在做他需要做的事。为了让自己的梦想变成现实，他把双手弄脏了。而且这似乎是唯一的办法。奥尔巴尼有一些选举年的争吵，我们不需要深入了解。
As much as I love getting into the details of this book, we don't need to. But as a result of it, Al Smith and the Republicans in legislature, they agree that in exchange for the Northern State Parkway not being built until Moses has a route agreed to by the Long Island Barons and has built enough of the Southern State Parkway to reach Jones Beach. There's a lot of names, a lot of details. They'll give him all the money for the parks in 1926 so that Moses can begin building his projects. Basically, the agreement is he can't start this other road until he finishes the first road. He can't start the northern state until he's a certain way along the southern state and they end the Taylor state fight. Moses gets that land. Macy has realized that his allies in the legislature have betrayed him, which is a
尽管我很喜欢深入了解这本书的细节，但我们没必要这么做。但其结果是，阿尔·史密斯和立法机关的共和党人达成协议，作为交换，在摩西敲定一条获得长岛男爵们同意的路线，并且修建了足够到达琼斯海滩的南州公园大道之前，北州公园大道将不会修建。这里有很多名字、很多细节。他们将在1926年为公园提供所有资金，以便摩西能够开始建设他的项目。基本上，协议是他在完成第一条道路之前不能开始修建这另一条道路。在南州公园大道修到一定程度之前，他不能开始修建北州公园大道，他们结束了泰勒州的争端。摩西得到了那块土地。梅西已经意识到他在立法机关的盟友背叛了他，这正是
lesson he will, he will take with him for the rest of his life, as we'll see. And the Republicans say it's going to take him so long to build the Southern state parkway, the Northern state parkway. We don't even have to think about it. This parkway that's going to go through the land of our political patrons, the Barons, we don't have to worry about that. It took 14 years to build the Bronx river parkway, which is the same length. This is way in the future.
他余生都将铭记的教训，正如我们将看到的。而共和党人则表示，他需要那么长的时间来修建南州公园大道、北州公园大道。我们甚至都不用考虑这一点。这条将穿过我们的政治金主——男爵们的土地的公园大道，我们不用担心。建造布朗克斯河公园大道花了14年时间，而它的长度是一样的。这还在遥远的未来。
We don't have to deal with this. It's going to take Moses so long just to get the Bronx River Parkway, which is the same length. This is way in the future. We don't have to deal with this. It's going to take Moses so long just to get the rights to the lands he needs for the Southern State Parkway. They don't know that Moses has been out scheming him and playing with the local Long Island bosses. So suddenly the Nassau County Board of Supervisors gives him miles of land as a gift and combined with the lands that New York City already owns, Moses suddenly has all the right of way land he needs
我们不需要处理这个。摩西光是拿到南州公园大道所需的土地权就要花那么长时间。他们不知道摩西一直在智胜他们并与长岛当地的老大们周旋。所以拿骚县监事会突然送给他几英里长的土地作为礼物，再加上纽约市已经拥有的土地，摩西突然拥有了他所需的所有通行权土地
for the Southern State Parkway. And the legislature's like, well, what? I have to assume that they're eating soup at the time and they just spit soup all over themselves when they get the news. And the Republicans are like, oh yeah, but we're gonna give him all this money. But the appropriations until it's available,
用来修建南州公园大道。而立法机关就像是，嗯，什么？我必须假设他们当时正在喝汤，当他们听到这个消息时，他们直接把汤喷了自己一身。而共和党人则像是，哦，是的，但我们要把所有的钱都给他。但拨款直到它可用之前，
until that bond is passed, we're gonna keep them small. So he can't do any actual work. And then they look outside their windows, I guess. There's engineers and surveyors already out there working because it says in Moses law that the Department of Public Works can use its money and its workers to work on parks projects. And there's kind of classic, I always imagine that this is the way it would work in a movie is they're investigating and there are parks workers working on park stuff and they're like, what's this all about? And they're like, oh yeah, we're from the tree nursery. This is the tree nursery program of the conservation department. It's fine. There could be trees here someday. Well, you're developing this beach for a parkway. Oh no, no, no.
直到那笔债券通过之前，我们要保持资金数额很小。这样他就无法开展任何实际工作。然后他们望向窗外，我猜。有工程师和测量员已经在外面工作了，因为摩西法律规定公共工程部可以使用其资金和工人来开展公园项目。这里有一种经典的桥段，我总是想象这会以电影的方式运作，他们在调查，而公园工人在做公园的事情，然后他们说，这到底是怎么回事？他们说，哦，是的，我们来自树木苗圃。这是环保部的树木苗圃计划。没关系。这里有一天会长出树来的。好吧，你正在为公园大道开发这个海滩。哦，不，不，不。
This is oyster culturing. We're doing oyster culturing with this money. There could be oysters here someday. It's all this money that's earmarked for other stuff is going to park and road building. And Caro personifies the Republicans in the form of Ways and Means Committee Chairman Eberly Hutchinson and Finance Committee Chairman Charles J. Hewitt. And Hewitt and Hutchinson are just gonna be continually stymied by how fast Moses working
这是牡蛎养殖。我们正用这笔钱进行牡蛎养殖。这里有一天会长出牡蛎来的。所有这些指定用于其他用途的资金都被挪用到公园和道路建设中。卡罗将共和党人具象化为筹款委员会主席埃伯利·哈钦森和财政委员会主席查尔斯·J·休伊特。而休伊特和哈钦森将不断被摩西的工作速度
and how Moses out-thought them in this. And they go to the governor and they protest. And the governor's like, well, let's talk about it. Come over to my hotel room. And he just gets them drunk and they most of thought them out thought them in this and they go to the governor and they protest and the governor's like well let's talk about it come over to my hotel room and he just gets them drunk and they kind of listen to music all night and he puts them to bed and the next morning makes them breakfast really early and they're all hung over it's such a again personalities and politics you know it's how are we gonna deal with this problem and just send them over to me and well I'll just drink with them all night and
以及摩西在这方面智胜他们的方式所阻挠。他们去找州长抗议。州长说，好吧，我们来谈谈吧。到我的酒店房间来。他直接把他们灌醉，他们大多数人都被摩西智胜了，他们去找州长抗议，州长说，好吧，我们来谈谈吧。到我的酒店房间来。他直接把他们灌醉，他们整晚听着音乐，他让他们上床睡觉，第二天一大早给他们做早饭，他们都宿醉了。这真是一个又一次的性格与政治的结合，你知道的，我们要如何处理这个问题？直接把他们打发到我这儿来，我整晚跟他们喝酒，
I'll get them hung over and they'll be they won't be able to argue anymore it does seem like the Al Smith treatment, right? Like if the Lyndon Johnson treatment was that he like screamed in your face until you just wanted to kill yourself. Like Al Smith is just like, roll in like a barrel of bourbon. We'll just, we'll sort this out. I'll tell you about the Fulton Fish Market
我会让他们宿醉，他们就再也无法争论了。这确实很像阿尔·史密斯的处理方式，对吧？如果林登·约翰逊的处理方式是他冲着你的脸大吼大叫，直到你只想去死。阿尔·史密斯就像是，推进来一桶波旁威士忌。我们会解决这个问题的。我要跟你讲讲富尔顿鱼市场的故事
until you just, you're just like fine Al, whatever, he can have the money. Put a record on the gramophone, put Sidewalks of New York on, that's my song, we'll listen to that, that'll be great, come on, sing with me, boys, east side, west side. But there's sort of a swage by this chummy, old school, very slow working politics of Al Smith,
直到你觉得好吧，阿尔，随便吧，他可以拿走这笔钱。在留声机上放张唱片，放一首《纽约的人行道》，那是我的歌，我们会听那个，那会很棒，来吧，跟我一起唱，孩子们，东区，西区。但这一切都被阿尔·史密斯这种亲切的、老派的、进展极其缓慢的政治手腕所缓和，
but coming up right, drafting up behind him, is this person who will, while like go to sleep at night, will have built an entire foundation on your land for something like, and then, and then he's gonna go, what, what? Were you gonna tear it up? What? You know, like, you know, it's like, it's crazy.
但紧随其后、正在起草计划的是这样一个人，他会在你晚上睡觉的时候，在你的土地上为诸如此类的东西打好整个地基，然后，然后他会说，什么，什么？你们要把它拆了吗？什么？你知道的，就像，你知道，这太疯狂了。
Like the two of them really work as this incredible team because Al Smith kind of lulls a lot of these old school politicians into thinking that this road will take 14 years and our Moses knows it's going to take six months. You know, it's a real, it's like slow cop, fast cop the way they deal with things. So now it's we're in may 1926. They're still stalling that Taylor state trial at the same time that they are
他们俩作为这个不可思议的团队合作得非常好，因为阿尔·史密斯在某种程度上让许多老派政客放松警惕，让他们以为这条路需要14年才能建成，而我们的摩西知道这只需要六个月。你知道，这真的是一种慢动作警察、快动作警察的处理事情方式。现在已经是1926年5月了。他们仍在拖延泰勒州的审判，与此同时他们
literally in court stalling a decision about whether they own this land or not. Moses sending out crews to start turning buildings that are already on the land into park facilities. And by mid May, the Deer Range State Park, as it's called, is open. And when the trial finally begins in June, the judge is like, we're going to find against you. Like he finds that Moses and the, and the other park commissioners, he hits them each with $22,000 fines. And this is one of my favorite details in the whole book is that Moses' mother reads this in the newspaper and says, oh, he never earned a dollar in his life and now we'll have
实际上在法庭上拖延关于他们是否拥有这块土地的决定。摩西派出施工队开始把土地上现有的建筑物改造成公园设施。到5月中旬，所谓的鹿岭州立公园开放了。当审判终于在6月开始时，法官的态度是，我们要对你们做出不利判决。他裁定摩西和其他公园专员败诉，并对每人处以22,000美元的罚款。这是整本书中我最喜欢的细节之一，摩西的母亲在报纸上读到这个消息后说，哦，他一生中从未赚过一美元，现在我们得
to pay this. And I just love that that Carol knows that she said that. Talk to the right person who delivered that newspaper to her and knows it. Moses appeals to a new trial. Al Smith testifies in his favor and has lunch with the judge. And the judge ultimately decides in this retrial, the law was broken, but the land belongs to the Long Island park commission now. Like they've already done it. They've already built on it. He's not going to tell them to tear down the park buildings. And he advises the jury to fix damages owed to Kingsland Macy at six cents.
为此付钱了。我简直太喜欢卡罗连她说过这话都知道这一点了。去跟那个把报纸送到她手上并且知道此事的人谈过了。摩西上诉要求重审。阿尔·史密斯出庭为他作证，并与法官共进午餐。法官最终在这次重审中裁定，法律确实被打破了，但这块土地现在属于长岛公园委员会。就像他们已经完成了建设一样。他们已经在上面建成了。他不会命令他们拆除公园建筑。他建议陪审团将赔偿金定为六美分。
So insult to injury, by the way, the law was broken but I'm rude as hell anyway and you don't get any money. That's awful. It's so mean. It really seems like, I mean I'm sure Moses loved it, and that's the twist ending of the movie The Sixth Sense is that Moses should have lost the trial but he didn't. You did that one on blank check, right? We did, we did, long ago, yes. Yeah, and I believe it was about a land battle in the Long Island courts. The whole time you're like,
所以这真是雪上加霜，顺便说一句，法律被打破了，但我无论如何还是粗鲁得要命，而且你们拿不到一分钱。这太糟糕了。太刻薄了。这真的看起来，我的确确确信摩西很喜欢这样，这就是电影《灵异第六感》的结局反转，即摩西本该输掉这场审判，但他没有输。你在《空白支票》节目里讲过这个，对吧？我们讲过，很久以前，是的。是的，我相信那是关于长岛法庭的一场土地争夺战。你全程都在想，
this Willis doesn't own this land. And the judge at the end is like, he doesn't, but he gets to keep it. He doesn't, what's the matter with you? Let the people have a beach, six cents, get out of here, bang, bang, bang. And all the people in the audience, they go, oh, that's what that title meant.
威利斯根本不拥有这块土地。而最后的法官就像是，他确实不拥有，但他可以留着。他没有，你脑子有什么毛病？让老百姓有个海滩吧，六美分，滚出去，砰，砰，砰。台下的所有观众都说，哦，原来那个标题是这个意思。
Makes sense. This is the adage of possession is nine tenths of the law. This is what this sort of refers to, this type of thing. It's like, if you're there and you're squatting on it and you're doing the thing, judges are, you know, you think that judges are kind of conservative in the way of like, you know, like resting someone's land away from them,
这就是所谓的“占有乃九分之法律”。这正是这类事情所指的。这就好像，如果你人在那里，你强占了它，你在那里干活，法官们，你知道的，你以为法官在某种程度上是保守的，就像，你知道的，把别人的土地强行夺走，
stopping that as a conservative point of view. But in a way, they're kind of mostly conservative in the sense of like, well, if it's going to cause so much trouble, like already these parks are here, we can't just undo all this stuff. They're really low to just cause something to stop or be dug up or do something different. They really want to keep what is the most ultimate common sense piece in this situation.
从保守的角度来看是阻止这种行为。但在某种程度上，他们在某种程度上是保守的，因为，如果这会引起这么大的麻烦，既然这些公园已经在这里了，我们不能就这样撤销所有这些事情。他们非常不愿意仅仅引起事情停工、被挖开或者做一些不同的事情。他们真的只想在这种情况保留最具有终极常识的部分。
And at this point, people are already going to this park. So it just makes no sense. Yeah. There's a great passage here where, where Carol says, basically that he goes, by the time the higher courts came to rule on the question of whether the Taylor estate was a park, it was a park. What was the judge to do? Tell the state to tear up the roads and tear down the buildings to destroy what hundreds of thousands of dollars of the public's money had been spent to build? Tell the people who had visited the Taylor estate that they could visit it no more? In theory, of course, judges should not be influenced by such considerations, but judges are human, and their susceptibility to such considerations was undoubtedly increased by Moses's willingness
而此时此刻，人们已经开始去这个公园了。所以这根本毫无意义。是的。这里有一段精彩的段落，卡罗在其中基本上说，当上级法院对泰勒庄园是否是一个公园的问题做出裁决时，它已经是一个公园了。法官能怎么办？叫国家拆除道路和建筑物，去摧毁花费了数十万美元公众资金建造的东西？告诉那些曾经参观过泰勒庄园的人他们再也不能参观了？从理论上讲，法官当然不应该受到这种考虑的影响，但法官也是人，他们容易受到这种考虑的影响，这无疑是因为摩西愿意
to attack publicly those of them who ruled against him. And so it's like they're people, you know? And like Roman, like you're saying, a judge is not going to be like, okay, well, the law says no one can use this park ever again. So I guess no parks. And at the same time, Tara talks about a real imbalance between a lawsuit between a private individual and a government agency because the government agency has so much money, they can just keep stalling and keep appealing.
公开攻击那些对做出对他们不利裁决的法官。所以这就像他们是人，你知道吗？就像罗曼，你刚才说的，法官不会说，好吧，法律规定任何人以后都不能再使用这个公园了。所以我想那就没有公园吧。与此同时，卡罗谈到了个人与政府机构之间诉讼的真正不平衡，因为政府机构有如此多的资金，他们可以不断拖延、不断上诉。
Whereas an individual will run out of money. And that's what happens with Kingsland Macy eventually. He can no longer afford to keep this lawsuit going. The park has already been built. But ironically, he becomes so inspired by this fight that he decides to go into politics and he becomes the most ruthless machine boss that Suffolk County, Long Island
而个人则会把钱花光。克ingsland Macy最终就是这样。他再也无法承担继续这场诉讼的费用了。公园已经建好了。但具有讽刺意味的是，他被这场斗争深深鼓舞，决定涉足政坛，并成为了萨福克郡（长岛）有史以来
has ever seen. And they call him the little king of Suffolk County. He rules with an iron fist. He goes, sends himself to Congress. He and Moses start working together. And when Macy dies in 1962, Caro says, the only person outside of Macy's family that he wants to see before he dies is Robert Moses. And it feels like, I don't know that there are any books about Debbie Kingsland Macy,
最冷酷无情的机器大佬。他们称他为萨福克郡的小国王。他用铁腕统治。他把自己送进了国会。他和摩西开始合作。当梅西在1962年去世时，卡罗说，梅西在死前想要见的人中，除了他的家人之外，唯一的一个就是罗伯特·摩西。这感觉就像，我不确定有没有关于黛比·金斯兰·梅西的书，
but it feels like there's a whole book in this guy who lost this battle to Robert Moses. And instead of taking the lesson, we've got to do more to regulate this government. He takes it like, well, if you can't beat them, join them. I guess I'll be a corrupt political boss too. And becomes so good at it.
但感觉这个与罗伯特·摩西进行这场战斗并最终落败的家伙身上有一整本书的故事。他没有吸取“我们必须采取更多措施来监管这个政府”的教训，而是觉得，既然打不过他们，就加入他们。我想我也要成为一个腐败的政治大佬。而且他干得如此出色。
That he just takes over this one area and rules it like a king. That's a real comic book narrative right there. That's a real like Batman shows up in Gotham and then creates the Joker time and stuff. Yes, right, anyone who does battle with him is just like, well, I guess there's only one way to succeed. It is crazy that he asked for Robert Moses
以至于他直接接管了这一地区并像国王一样统治它。这简直是一个真正的漫画叙事。这简直就像蝙蝠侠出现在哥谭市然后制造了小丑的故事。是的，没错，任何与他战斗的人都只会觉得，好吧，看来只有一条成功之路。真疯狂，他竟然在临终前
on his deathbed though. Is there more on that later in the book? I do not remember. No. I would love to know. It's the last time you hear about Macy. It's a big book, David. We can't talk about every person
要求见罗伯特·摩西。书的后面还有关于这方面的内容吗？我不记得了。没有。我很想知道。这是你最后一次听到关于梅西的消息。大卫，这是一本大书。我们不可能谈论罗伯特·摩西一路上接触过的每一个人，你知道吗？我不知道。这本书确实有那种氛围。是的，我们可以。它有那种潜力，你知道吗？那倒也是。那倒也是。有太多的书页需要填满了。
Robert Moses touched along the way, you know? I don't know. The book kind of has the vibe of it. Yes, we can. It has the potential, you know? That's true. That's true. There's a lot of pages to fill.
你可能觉得梅西还会出现。我觉得一旦他们提到一个角色死亡，你通常就再也听不到他们的消息了。通常卡罗会说，我现在说这个是因为你要跟他道别了。卡罗实际上，你说得对，他在像这样一本庞大的书中保持信息精简方面表现得极为出色。
You might think that Macy shows up. I feel like once they mention when a character dies, you usually don't hear about them again. Usually, Caro's like, I'm saying that now because you say goodbye to him. Karo is actually, you're right, he's outstanding at keeping information streamlined in a colossal book like this.
你不会在翻过400页后看到一个姓氏然后想：这到底是谁？这真的是这货吗？根本不是这样的。是的，因为他在梅西实际上又多活了30、40年的这个时刻，为梅西的故事画上了句号。他就是这样，你可以把梅西放在一边，就这样。在写这种传记时，他并不死板地拘泥于时间顺序，
You're not going 400 pages later and seeing a last name and being like, who the hell is this? Is this guy, it's not like that at all. Yeah, because he closes the book on Macy at this moment when he in fact lives another 30, 40 years. And he's just like, you can put Macy aside and that's it. He's not slavishly devoted to chronology when it comes to doing this type of biography,
这是一个引人入胜的选择。我的意思是，我实际上觉得有时这会稍微吸引我，但大多数时候我都很喜欢它，你知道吗，因为比起那种无情的时间流逝，他其实更关注思想和戏剧性。对。是的，他组织这本书的方式主要是通过
which is a fascinating choice. I mean, I find it actually kind of, sometimes it'll draw me a little bit, but mostly I love it, you know, because he's really much more about the ideas and the drama than being like this relentless march of time. Right. Yeah, he's organizing the book mainly through
摩西作为一个人的发展，从理想主义者到怪物的转变，以及途中的任何事情。如果现在谈论这件事合情合理，他就会谈论它。我们以后会在本书中遇到一个整章。那只是摩西与纽约历任市长之间的关系，几乎就像卡罗在说：我们要暂时跳出
Moses's development as a person, from idealist to monster, and anything along the way. If it makes sense to talk about this thing now, he'll talk about it. There's a whole chapter we'll get to much later when we're talking. That's just most his relationship with different mayors of New York, where it's almost as if Carol was like, we're going to step out of the timeline of the
书中的时间线，以便我可以谈论这些事情，然后我们要跳回事件的洪流中。但他把书组织得非常好。有时确实会让人感到困惑，但有太多的事情需要记在脑子里了。而且令我惊叹的是，卡罗竟然能够在这么长的一段内容中把它记在脑子里并以这种方式组织起来。这确实让我赞叹不已。是的。
book for a moment so I can talk about this stuff, and then we're going to step back into the stream of events. Uh, but he's, he organized it really well. It is confusing sometimes, but just a lot of stuff to keep in your head. And it's astounding to me that Carol was able to keep it in his head and organize it in this way over such a long thing. It amazes me to no end actually. Yeah.
卡罗在这个时候，他列举了摩西从中吸取的一些教训。第一，得到他想要的东西的最简单方法是动用他所拥有的每一处权力。他不能因为自己的理想而束缚自己。几个政客从公共工程中捞到好处有什么区别？如果他们捞了，工程就完成了。如果不捞，就完不成。不打碎鸡蛋就做不成煎蛋卷，这后来成了摩西的大口号之一。此外，在公众眼中，目的可能无法为主张正义的手段辩护，但如果目的足够讨人喜欢，手段就无所谓了。它们并不重要。它们
Caro, at this point, he enumerates some lessons that Moses has learned from this. Number one, the simplest way to get what he wants done is to use every source of power he has. He can't hold himself back because of his ideals. What difference does it make if a few politicians profit off of a public work? If they do, the work gets done. If they don't, it doesn't. You can't make an omelet without breaking eggs, which becomes one of Moses's big slogans. Also, in the eyes of the public, the ends may not justify the means, but if the ends are loved enough, the means don't matter. They're unimportant. They don't
不需要被辩护，因为根本没人会在乎。人们热爱公园。他们才不在乎公园是怎么建起来的呢。另一个教训，人们热爱公园。如果你是在为公园而战，你就是个英雄。你做什么都无所谓。他就像，哦，这太棒了。是的。他后来因为忘记了这一点而遭到毁灭，
have to be justified because no one cares. People love parks. They don't care how parks get built. Another lesson, people love parks. If you're fighting for parks, you're a hero. Doesn't matter what you do. He's like, Oh, this is great. Yeah. He gets undone later by forgetting that. And instead being like, do people love highways in the middle of Manhattan?
取而代之的是想：人们真的喜欢曼哈顿市中心的公路吗？人们说，不。而他就像，你们确定吗？我真的很想建一条。让我在这里建一条吧。我们有这个愚蠢的公园，但这里可以建一个巨大的三叶草形立交桥。这是一个非常好的观点。就像，让我在这里建一条吧。我们有这个愚蠢的公园，但这里可以建一个巨大的三叶草形立交桥。不，不。这是一个非常好的观点。确实如此，因为是的，他失去了触及
People like, no. And he's like, are you sure? I really want to make one. Like, let me put one right here. We have this dumb park, but there could be a big clover leaf exchange. That's a really good point. Like, let me put one right here. We have this dumb park, but there could be a big cloverleaf exchange. No, no. That's a really good point. That really is, because yeah, he loses touch
那股他可以利用的秘密善意源泉的触觉，当他试图做所有这些冷酷无情的事情时。这太关键了。对，这就好比当他转向汽车那些破事时，（抱歉爆粗口了，我不确定）但如果我被允许这样做的话。你可以。不，不，这是一个面向所有观众的
of this secret sort of well of goodwill he can tap into when he's trying to do all these ruthless things. It's so crucial. Right, that's like when he pivots to the car shit, you know, sorry for swearing, I'm not sure. But if I'm allowed to do that. You can. No, no, this is an all audiences
家庭权力掮客播客，因为孩子们真的很想听这个。权力掮客当然被评为G级（大众级）。不，但是就像，关于摩西的另一件事是，当你环顾这座城市并看到他建造的公园时，你会想，你知道，这些经久不衰，这些经久不衰——就像，是的，也许它们有一些问题，但它们，以及他所有的公路，像臭鼬一样糟糕，因为它们是公园大道，是
family power broker podcast, because the kids really want to hear about it. Power broker of course is rated G. No, but like, and the other thing about Moses is when you look around the city and you see the parks that he made, you're like, you know, these endure these endure like yes maybe they had some problem but like they and all of his roads like stink because they're parkways that are
为你知道的以每小时40英里速度行驶的汽车建造的，你本该在经过时看看树木，而现在你却在杰基（派克大道）上陷入疯狂的交通大堵塞，你会想，是谁建了这条臭气熏天的公路？就像是罗伯特·摩西，是的，就像你（会觉得）道路根本不是长久之计。不管怎样，我很抱歉。我的公路长篇大论结束了。但我认为这真的很聪明。我的意思是，这不仅仅是所有的时光流逝
made for you know cars that go 40 miles an hour and like you're supposed to look at trees while you go by and now you're like on the Jackie in like an insane traffic jam you're like who built this stinking road like it's Robert Moses yeah like he you know roads are just not the way to go. Anyway, I'm sorry. That's my road rant over. But I think that's really smart. I mean, it's not just all the like time moving on
以及人们对他的行事方式变得更加精明。我的意思是，如果他没有把这个作为他的电力电池来源——公园的善意，他真的会跌落谷底，并被越来越多的人，也许不是《纽约时报》，但越来越多的人视为恶棍。这真的，真的很耐人寻味。除了就像这个时刻，他正在学习所有这些他必须放弃他的道德以及政治运作理想的教训之外，他还在学习关于这意味着什么的关键事物
and people getting savvier to his ways. I mean, like if he doesn't have this as this battery source of power, the goodwill of parks, like he really falls down and becomes like more and more people, maybe not the New York Times, but more and more people, you know, consider him a villain. And it's really, really intriguing. And in addition to sort of like this moment where he's learning like all these lessons that he has to let go of his morals and his ideals of how politics works, he's learning really key things about like what it means
而且人们越来越看清他的为人。我的意思是，如果他没有了这种权力电池、没有了公众对公园的善意，他就会真的垮掉，越来越多的人——也许不是《纽约时报》，但越来越多的人——你知道的，开始把他视作一个反派。这真的非常、非常耐人寻味。除了经历这样一个时刻，他正在吸取所有这些教训：他必须抛弃自己的道德感，抛弃关于政治运作方式的理想主义，他还在学一些真正关键的东西，关于这意味着什么
to be like a developer and constructor of things. Like if you drive down stakes and you pour concrete, it is really hard for people to stop you. And that's a really important lesson he uses like constantly. And then the other thing is that is really important to lie about how much everything costs. Yes. Because he knows that none of this stuff will work
就好像一个事情的开发者和建造者。比如，如果你打下桩子并浇筑混凝土，人们很难阻止你。这是他经常使用的一个非常重要的经验。另一个非常重要的事情是，要隐瞒所有东西的成本。是的。因为他知道这些东西根本行不通
even for like the, whatever, that $225,000 allotment that he got, barely got him a limousine and stuff. Like he just, but he just begins to work on stuff and knows that if he spends a lot of money, but not all the money needed and does a part of a thing that, you know, people might be mad at him for like underestimating the costs, but then he can just say, yeah, but you know, you're the one who gave me this money and if you're so smart, you should have known better that it's not going to cost this
哪怕是像他得到的那个22.5万美元的拨款，也只勉强够买辆豪华轿车之类的。他只是，他只是开始着手做事，并且知道如果他花了大量的钱，但并不是所需的全部资金，并且做了一部分事情，你知道的，人们可能会因为他低估了成本而生气，但他可以说，是的，但是你知道的，这钱是你给我的，如果你这么聪明，你就应该知道这花不了这么多
much. I mean, like he's really devious when it comes to this stuff. Um, I also liked that, that like his, his tactic in this is to not like build. You know, a couple of things or like spread the money out and start a lots of things. Like he likes to get really far along with one thing. So then they just cannot help, but you know, just like, okay, I guess we gotta put this building up or we have to do this thing because, um, it's already. You know, it's already so far along that it's really hard to say no. And people are really subject to a sunk cost fallacy when it comes to this stuff.
钱。我的意思是，在处理这种事情时，他真的很狡猾。嗯，我还喜欢他的这种策略，就是不建。你知道，几处地方，或者把资金分散开来，同时启动很多项目。相反，他喜欢把一个项目推进得很远。这样一来，他们就别无选择，只能说，好吧，我想我们得把这栋建筑建起来，或者我们必须做这件事，因为，嗯，它已经。你知道，它已经推进到这个地步，你很难拒绝。而且人们在这种事情上真的很受沉没成本谬误的影响。
He's got kind of a two pincer strategy. You're right. He's going to use this again and again and again, which is I'm going to spend enough money to make sure that there's visible work done. And are you going to tell people you wasted that money instead of finishing it? And then I'm going to finish it so that people see it and see how great it is. And they will want me to do more of it. The voters will want me to do more of it.
他有一种双管齐下的策略。你是对的。他将一遍又一遍地使用这一招，那就是我要花足够的钱来确保有看得见的工作成果。难道你要告诉人们你浪费了这些钱却没有把它建完吗？然后我要把它建完，这样人们就能看到它，看到它是多么棒。他们会希望我做更多这样的事。选民们会希望我做更多这样的事。
Once I finished this, these buildings on Jones beach, they'll let me do whatever I want, cause they'll see how amazing they are, you know, once I finished this park, but also as we'll see in this section, I'm going to use all the money you gave me to build this building, to lay the foundation for this building. And then I'm going to say, are you really going to just leave a naked foundation on this beach and tell people that that's what you did? No, you're going to give me the rest of the money. And the ultimate lesson, he broke the law.
一旦我建成了这个，琼斯海滩上的这些建筑，他们就会让我随心所欲，因为他们会看到它们是多么令人惊叹，你知道的，一旦我建成了这个公园，但正如我们在这个部分所看到的，我将用你给我的所有钱来建造这座建筑，为这座建筑打下地基。然后我会说，难道你真的打算在这个海滩上留下一个光秃秃的地基，然后告诉别人这就是你们做的事吗？不，你会把剩下的钱给我。最终的教训是，他违法了。
He got everything he wanted. He was fined six cents for it. So it's one of those things where it's like, you got what you wanted, but was it worth it? And he's like, yeah, it was worth it. It was worth six cents to do that. And he's insulated from the law because he has contracts and money to dispense. He has access to lawyers who can delay it. Carus says on page 220, if there was one law for the poor who have neither money nor influence and another law for the rich who have both, there is still a third law
他得到了他想要的一切。为此他被罚款六美分。所以这就是那种“你得到了你想要的，但这一切真的值得吗？”的情况，而他的反应是：是的，这很值得。这样做罚款六美分完全值得。而且他免受法律制裁，因为他手里有合同和资金可以支配。他有能够拖延时间的律师。卡罗在第220页写道，如果说对于既无金钱又无权势的穷人有一套法律，而对于两者兼具的富人有另一套法律的话，那么对于拥有更多权力的
for the public official with real power who has more of both. And he's learned that he has the power to defy the law and the only way that he can make that he has the power to defy the law. And the only way that he can make his dreams a reality is to defy the law. So he has $1 million available to him immediately from this $15 million for the entire Parks and Parksway system. He uses it to buy up so much land so he can start developing them. By the end of 1926, some of them are open for public use so he can show people, look what we're doing. And on August 29th 1926 my wedding anniversary But many years later
公职人员来说，还有第三套法律。而且他已经了解到，他有权对抗法律，而他能够让梦想成为现实的唯一途径，就是对抗法律。因此，在用于整个公园和公园大道系统的1500万美元中，他立即拿出了100万美元。他用这些钱买下了大量的土地，以便开始开发。到1926年底，其中一些公园已经向公众开放，这样他就可以向人们展示，看我们在做什么。1926年8月29日，那是我的结婚纪念日，但那是很多年以后了
He digs the first bit of soil of his first road construction the section of the southern state parkway That's gonna loop around the Hempstead Lake State Park reservoir. He's been planning roads since 1914 in his mind and I think the reason David that I think he goes to roads eventually rather than parks as his big Thing is what he really loves is he likes drawing lines on maps in his mind. And I think the reason, David, that I think he goes to roads eventually rather than parks, as his big thing is, what he really loves is he likes drawing lines on maps. He likes taking a pencil and drawing a line on a map. And you could do that with roads even more than with parks. It's just what Caro said on this podcast, right?
他为他的第一条道路建设——南州公园大道（Southern State Parkway）绕过亨普斯特德湖州立公园（Hempstead Lake State Park）水库的那段路——掘下了第一铲土。自1914年以来，他一直在脑海中规划道路。大卫，我认为他最终选择道路而不是公园作为他宏伟事业的核心的原因是，他真正热爱的是在脑海中的地图上画线。大卫，我认为他最终选择道路而不是公园作为他宏伟事业的核心的原因是，他真正热爱的是在地图上画线。他喜欢拿着铅笔在地图上画一条线。相比于公园，你在道路上更能做到这一点。这不正是卡罗在这个播客里所说的吗？
That he drew all these lines on a map, basically when he was a teenager, and then he built them all when he was an adult with very little change. He did exactly what he always wanted to do. Right. Like 12 years later what he always wanted to do. Right. Like 12 years later, he's finally building these roads and Hutchinson and Hewitt, they're so mad Moses is finding more money than they intended and doing more
基本上就是他在十几岁的时候在地图上画了所有这些线条，然后在他成年后把它们全都建成了，几乎没有什么改变。他完全做了他一直想做的事。没错。就像12年后他一直想做的那样。没错。就像12年后，他终于修建了这些道路，而哈钦森和休伊气坏了，摩西找到的资金比他们预期的要多，做的事情也比
worth than they intended. And he starts planning Jones beach. They say, Oh, you're making a bathing beach. Okay. You'll have a few, you know, kind of cheap dressing areas so that the boys can't watch the girls getting changed. You'll have like a boardwalk or something with some hot dog stands. And most is like, no, I don't want that. I'm going to get a bunch of star architects together. I want enormous bath houses big enough for 10,000 lockers.
他们预期的要多。他开始规划琼斯海滩。他们说：“哦，你在建一个海水浴场。好吧。你会有一些，你知道的，那种简陋的更衣室，免得男孩偷看女孩换衣服。你会有某种带热狗摊的木栈道之类的东西。”摩西却说：“不，我不要那样。我要把一帮明星建筑师凑在一起。我要巨大的浴室，大到足以容纳1万个储物柜。”
I want swimming pools big enough for hundreds of people. There's going to be terraces with restaurants. There's going to be diaper changing stations. It's all going to look fanciful and whimsical. I want it to look like a fairy tale. I want two parking lots big enough to hold 10,000 cars each. I want bandstands. I want outdoor sporting areas.
“我要足够几百人使用的游泳池。要有带餐厅的露台。要有婴儿换尿布台。这一切都要看起来奇幻而古怪。我要它看起来像童话故事。我要两个足够停放各1万辆汽车的停车场。我要乐队演奏台。我要户外运动区。”
And the architects are with him standing on an empty, totally nothing sandbar. There's nothing there. And he's like, I want this entire recreation complex. You're going to make it. And they start bringing him designs and they're very utilitarian. They're the kind of stuff you would expect for a government, you know, bathing station and Moses like, no, I want, I want one, one of these buildings to look like a castle.
建筑师们和他一起站在一个空旷、完全什么都没有的沙洲上。那里什么也没有。而他说：“我要整个这个娱乐综合体。你们得把它建起来。”然后他们开始给他带去设计图，而这些设计图非常实用主义。它们正是你对政府那种，你知道的，海水浴场所期望的东西，而摩西却说：“不，我要，我要其中一栋建筑看起来像个城堡。”
I want another to look like a Moorish temple. I want this to look like a campanile from Venice, this water tower. And they, he's demanding, I want the most, I want these beautiful building materials. I want it faced in the most expensive stone I can get. And, uh, their, his architects are like, it's going to cost a million dollars to build this. And Hutchinson Hewitt says,
“我要另一栋看起来像个摩尔神庙。我要这座水塔看起来像威尼斯的钟楼。”而且他，他在要求，我要最多，我要这些漂亮的建筑材料。我要它用我能弄到的最昂贵的石头贴面。呃，他们的，他的建筑师们说：“这要花一百万美元才能建好。”哈钦森和休伊说：
well, we'll only give you $150,000, assuming that he's gonna scale down his plans. No, he just used all that money to lay the foundations. And they're like, what? That's all you did? Smith, fire this man. And Smith says, no, I'm not gonna do it. And Moses just sees the situation so clearly.
“嗯，我们只能给你15万美元，”他们以为他会缩减计划。不，他把所有的钱都用来打地基了。他们说：“什么？这就是你干的全部？史密斯，把这人开除！”而史密斯说：“不，我才不干。”摩西把局势看得很透彻。
Like we've said, are Hutchinson Hewitt gonna go back to their voters and say, this guy lied to us and we wasted $,000 dollars on two cement foundations on a random sandbar in the middle of nowhere in Long Island that you can't even get to because there's no roads to get there or you can even give me some money you can give us more money and I'm going to finish this yeah and they they're like well we'll get revenge on you we'll only give you some of the money you want and he's like I'm going to take money from the other departments it's fine like I'm I have so much more the other departments, it's fine.
正如我们所说的那样，哈钦森和休伊难道要回到他们的选民面前说：“这家伙对我们撒谎了，我们在荒郊野岭、连路都通不到、根本去不了的朗德岛随机沙洲上的两个水泥地基上浪费了多少多少美元，而你们甚至可以给我一些钱，你们可以给我们更多的钱，然后我会把它建完。”是的，他们，他们就像是“好吧，我们要向你报复，我们只给你你想要的资金的一部分，”而他说：“我要从其他部门拿钱，没关系的，就像我——我有更多的其他部门的资金，这没问题。
Like I have so much more control over this. And that's how the chapter ends with Hutchinson and Hewitt fuming on Jones Beach at these foundations, just going, oh, Moses, he got us again. That's the end of chapter 12. This commitment to having this is again, where I get kind of like on Moses' side a little bit,
就像我对这个项目的控制力要大得多。”这就是这一章的结尾，哈钦森和休伊气急败坏地站在琼斯海滩的这些地基上，嘴里念叨着：“哦，摩西，他又把我们给耍了。”第12章就这样结束了。这种对拥有这些东西的执着，又是让我有点倾向于摩西这一边的地方，
where I'm just like, yeah, get that Ohio limestone. What are you gonna, you can't build, you can get it. You know, like it's, you know, everyone who like does any sort of like remodeling or construction knows that like a building is, a building costs what a building costs, but like 90% of what the building cost is in the end is that a quarter inch of surface, you know what I mean?
就是我觉得，对，去弄那种俄亥俄州的石灰石吧。你打算怎么办，你建不出来，你能弄到它。你知道的，任何进行过某种装修或建筑的人都知道，一栋建筑就是，建筑花费多少就是多少，但建筑成本的90%，最终都花在那四分之一英寸的表面上，你知道我的意思吗？
Like is it bamboo, is it stone, is it marble? You know, it's that little bit. And he's picking the most expensive materials like in the United States to do this stuff. And he has this real eye for this stuff. And people talk about this, that he has a real designer's eye. Like he'll go like, yeah, but those bricks will really bounce off the sand and sea.
比如它是竹子、石头还是大理石？你知道，就是那么一点点。他正在全美范围内挑选最昂贵的材料来做这些事情。他对这种事有着敏锐的眼光。人们谈论过这一点，说他真正具备设计师的眼光。比如他会说：“对，但这些砖块在沙子和大海的衬托下会格外好看。”
You know, like it'll really, the colors will really sparkle. And I totally appreciate that. Like, I think that's amazing. Yeah, he has a real aesthetic sense. He wants these things to look beautiful. And there's also, there's such an undeniable fun in seeing him out smart and out with these guys. There's a real Bugs Bunny kind of coyote element to Robert Moses outwitting
你知道，这会让颜色真正闪闪发光。我完全赞赏这一点。我觉得这太棒了。是的，他有着真正的审美感。他想让这些东西看起来很美。而且，看着他智胜、智取这些家伙，有一种不可否认的乐趣。罗伯特·摩西智胜这些人，有一种兔八哥和威利狼式的元素，
these, these guys who are trying to keep things, trying to basically do their job of not overspending on a, on a public beach. Those bath houses are still incredible. They're, you know, a lot of them are being spruced up to this day or whatever. Like they are impressive and enduring. Like they, he was right on a lot of those calls, which again is weird when he seems to abandon aesthetics,
这些家伙试图维持现状，试图基本上做好他们分内的事——不在一个公共海滩上过度花钱。那些浴室现在依然令人难以置信。它们，你知道的，直到今天其中许多还在被翻新或怎样。它们令人印象深刻且经久不衰。就像，他在很多这类决策上都是对的，这再次让人觉得奇怪，因为他后来似乎放弃了审美，
like, you know, as he goes on. On his roles. Well, like any artist, his style changes over time and somebody It's easy. It's his earlier more popular stuff. It's easier to understand his later more, you know, you know brutal or pollution era yeah Someday maybe we'll be kind of high-minded enough to understand what he was getting at with those words Oh, yeah, yeah, but it's so true that the enduring quality of just how nice Jones Beach is.
就像，你知道的，随着他继续他的项目。嗯，就像任何艺术家一样，他的风格随时间而改变，而且有些事情。这很简单。这是他早期更受欢迎的作品。人们更容易理解他后来的那些，你知道的，更加残酷或污染时期的作品。是的，也许有一天我们会变得足够崇高，能够理解他那些作品到底想表达什么。哦，是的，是的，但琼斯海滩的这种经久不衰的品质是如此真实，
Like you could take the most ardent anti-sprawl, anti-car, anti-Moses person, but they'll go to you, yeah, Jones Beach is pretty nice. You know, like it really is, it really works in his favor. This vision, in a way, it's interesting that this is his crown jewel, and it's done so early in this process.
你可以带上最坚定的反对城市扩张、反对汽车、反对摩西的人，但他们也会对你说：“好吧，琼斯海滩确实挺不错的。”你知道的，这确实对他的事业很有利。从某种意义上说，这种愿景很有趣，这是他的皇冠明珠，而且在整个进程的这么早期就完成了。
But you could say, because it's so beautiful, because it's so accomplished, it gives him a blank check for his later work. Hey. Hey. I mean, he definitely wrote himself blank checks, right? It's true, yeah. It's not the traditional blank check of the government being whatever you want.
但你可以说，正因为它如此美丽，正因为它如此完美，这为他以后的工作开出了一张空白支票。嘿。嘿。我的意思是，他绝对给自己开过空白支票，对吧？确实，是的。这与政府随你心愿的那种传统空白支票不同。
The government's just kinda like, how are you paying for this? And he's like, don't worry about it. I got nickels coming from so many bridges, you don't even need to write me a check. Yeah. But in blank check parlance, this is the guarantor. Like Don't Speech, it's success.
政府只会有点像：“你这是怎么付钱的？”而他则说：“别担心。我有从那么多桥梁收来的零钱，你们甚至都不需要给我开支票。”是的。但在空白支票的行话里，这就是担保人。就像琼斯海滩，它的成功。
Is the guarantor for like- All of his work with Al Smith is the guarantor for later, like now you can't get rid of me. Because I'm one, one because I've created popular things and two because I have like planted roots in every agency and you cannot get rid of me. Like, you know, even if you try, I'm already over there. So it doesn't matter if you've gotten me out of here or whatever.
是这样一种担保人——他与阿尔·史密斯的所有合作都是后来的担保人，就像现在你无法摆脱我一样。因为第一，我创造了受欢迎的事物；第二，我在每个机构都扎下了根，你无法摆脱我。就像，你知道的，即使你试图这样做，我也已经在那里了。所以你把我赶出去什么的都无济于事。
It's like Voldemort. You know what? Yes. It's like, I hate to do. I know everyone compares everything to Harry Potter, but when you were talking with Carol, I was like, yes, it's like Horcruxes. He's like, you can't destroy me because I have a job in that agency. So even if you obliterate this one, I live eternally. It's ridiculous. Yes. We've got to take a break when we come back. Chapter 13. Let's move to the next chapter, Chapter 13. It's called driving. And this is a chapter title that
这就好比伏地魔。你知道吗？是的。我讨厌这么做。我知道每个人都把所有东西拿来跟《哈利·波特》作比较，但当你在和卡罗谈论时，我就觉得：对，这就像魂器。他就像是：“你摧毁不了我，因为我在那个机构里有一份工作。所以即使你彻底消灭了这个，我也能永垂不朽。”这太荒谬了。是的。我们得休息一下，回来后是第13章。让我们进入下一章，第13章。它叫做“开车”。这是卡罗会再次使用的一个章节标题，
Carol's going to use again. And I love it as a title because it's got two or three big meanings. Moses is driving himself and his men to work as hard and fast as possible in this, so people can do driving in their cars later. And it reminds you of that irony that Moses himself almost never drives a car, never really learns how to drive. There's a scene in here where he's practicing in case he wants to learn someday, and I think he just decided he doesn't want to. But Moses' success in the bathhouse battle, the Battle of the Bathhouses, shows him how much he needs Al Smith's support. Al Smith is the one who is, he is the guarantor right now that can back him up against the legislature, but he's not gonna have Al Smith
我非常喜欢这个标题，因为它有两三个重大的含义。摩西在这一章中驱使自己和他的手下尽可能努力、尽可能快地工作，以便人们以后可以在汽车里开车。这让你想起了这样一个讽刺之处：摩西本人几乎从不自己开车，也从来没有真正学会开车。这里有一个场景，他在练习开车以防哪天想学，而我想他只是决定自己不想学。但是摩西在浴室之战（Battle of the Bathhouses）中的成功，向他展示了他多么需要阿尔·史密斯的支持。阿尔·史密斯就是那个，他现在是能够支持他对抗立法机关的担保人，但他不会拥有阿尔·史密斯太久了。
for long. Al Smith is planning to run for president in 1928. And so Moses is like, I've got to get as much done as possible on these projects so people can see how great they are. And then people will provide pressure on the government to get my other projects completed. And so Moses' staff in a lot of this chapter is about how hard he pushes them. They're working from 9 a.m. to midnight on many days. If someone isn't giving Moses what he wants, he yells at them or even worse, shuts them out of his presence, just cold shoulders them completely.
阿尔·史密斯正计划竞选1928年的总统。因此，摩西心想：“我必须在这些项目上尽可能多地完成工作，这样人们就能看到它们有多棒。然后人们就会向政府施加压力，促使我的其他项目完成。”因此，在这一章的大部分内容中，摩西的员工都在讲述他如何严厉地鞭策他们。他们经常从早上9点一直工作到午夜。如果有人没有给摩西想要的东西，他就会对他们大喊大叫，甚至更糟，把他们晾在一边，彻底对他们冷脸相向。
And at the same time, Moses is still overseeing a lot of non-Parks projects for Al Smith because he's still Al Smith's go-to guy for getting things done. And so Carol talks about the schedule where Moses, he gets on the 6 a.m. train to Albany, which is a four hour ride on Monday mornings. He goes to Al Smith. train to Albany, which is a four-hour ride on Monday mornings. He goes to Al Smith. He says, can you give me a state-owned car and a chauffeur to take me back
与此同时，摩西仍在为阿尔·史密斯监督许多非公园项目，因为他仍然是阿尔·史密斯用来把事情办妥的首选人物。因此，卡罗谈到了这样的时间表：摩西在周一早上乘坐开往奥尔巴尼的早晨6点的火车，这是一段四个小时的车程。他去找阿尔·史密斯。坐火车去奥尔巴尼，在星期一早晨是一趟四个小时的车程。他去找阿尔·史密斯。他说：“你能给我一辆州属汽车和一个司机送我回去吗？
so that I'm because I know I'm going to miss the midnight train back home. And if you give me a car back, then I can start work tomorrow morning on Tuesday on park stuff. And he has spent at least three days a week in New York City for the State Council of Parks. He's shuttling between regional parks to check in on them. His park employees at the Long Island office in the old Belmont mansion, they say he never seems tired. He's working late into the night. He keeps them there until late in the night. The only person who can get him to leave the office is his wife, Mary. So sometimes the employees will sneak out and call her privately so that she will come to the office and tell him to come home. But then when he goes home, he does more work there. There's always a manila envelope full of new instructions for his employees
因为我知道我会赶不上半夜回家的火车。如果你派车送我回去，我明天早上周二就能开始处理公园的事情了。”他每周至少有三天时间待在纽约市处理州立公园委员会（State Council of Parks）的事务。他在各个区域公园之间穿梭以进行视察。他在老贝尔蒙特宅邸的长岛办公室的公园员工说，他似乎从来不觉得累。他工作到深夜。他把他们留在办公室直到深夜。唯一能让他离开办公室的人是他的妻子玛丽。所以有时员工会偷偷溜出去私下打电话给她，好让她来到办公室并命令他回家。但当他回家后，他会在家里继续工作。第二天早上，
the next morning in his house. And his family is always around the office and the people at the office talk about how they're working hard. Their boss is kind of a tyrant, but there's a sense of excitement. And there's a sense of a fun, informal atmosphere, especially for the 1920s. They don't have to wear their suit jackets while they're working and things like that. Their boss dresses like a slob and is wearing, always wearing an old beaten up
他的房子里总是有一个装满给员工的新指令的马尼拉信封。他的家人总是在办公室周围转悠，办公室里的人也谈论着他们是如何努力工作的。他们的老板有点像个暴君，但有一种兴奋感。这里有一种有趣、非正式的氛围，尤其是对于20世纪20年代来说。他们在工作时不必穿着西装外套诸如此类。他们的老板穿得像个邋遢鬼，总是戴着一顶破旧的
hat. It is the excitement of a startup essentially that they are, they're working in, in this parks department. And this is the 1920s. Things are super basic. Moses is like, uh, I want the areas around my parkways to zone to certain ways. They can't be turned into houses and the towns, long Island are like, we don't have any zoning laws.
帽子。这基本上就是初创公司的兴奋感，他们在这个公园部门里工作。这是20世纪20年代。一切都超级基础。摩西的想法是：嗯，我希望我的公园大道周围的区域以某种方式进行区划。它们不能变成房屋，而长岛的城镇则说：我们没有任何区划法律。
We don't have those. So Moses workers have to draft laws and then work with local town councils to get them put in place. There's so much work that has to be done, even beyond the designing of things. And the designing of things has to be incredibly effortful because Moses wants his work to be as elegant and beautiful as possible. If you're designing a guardrail, if you're designing a light pole, if you're designing the sign that points to the bathroom, he's saying, how do we make this pleasant to look at? How do we make this something that people will enjoy looking at and remember?
我们没有那些东西。所以摩西的工人们必须起草法律，然后与当地城镇委员会合作将其付诸实施。有如此多的工作必须完成，甚至超出了事物的设计。而事物的设计必须付出难以置信的努力，因为摩西希望他的工作尽可能优雅和美丽。如果你在设计护栏、设计路灯杆、设计指向洗手间的标志，他都会说：我们如何让这看起来令人赏心悦目？我们如何让这成为人们乐于观看并铭记的事物？
And his workers are very inspired by that, as I imagine anyone would be by someone who's pushing them to do their best, not just to work hard because we've got to make money for the company, but to do the best work that they can do as designers. Yeah, yeah. This is the part where I feel like the cult of personality makes the most sense to me when it comes to Robert Moses. Like sometimes when he's like shouting at people,
他的工人们深受启发，我想任何人看到一个推动他们做到最好的人都会如此，不仅是为了给公司赚钱而努力工作，而是作为设计者做出他们能做出的最好工作。是的，是的。这就是我觉得个人崇拜对罗伯特·摩西来说最有道理的部分。比如有时当他对着人们大喊大叫时，
I'm always like, I would just walk away from this fucking idiot, you know what I mean? But like this vibe, this is very like, put out the school paper, you know, public radio, everyone's get paid like $15,000 a year. And you know, like, but we're still going to put out something amazing. We're going to work all the time. Like this, this really feels that I can get into the spirit of this moment.
我总是在想：我才懒得理这个该死的笨蛋呢，你知道我的意思吗？但这种氛围，这非常像是，办学校校报，你知道的，公共广播，每个人每年只拿1.5万美元的薪水。你知道的，但我们还是要搞出一些了不起的东西。我们要一直工作。就像这个，这真的让人能融入此刻的精神中。
There's a number of times in the book, this is one of them. And earlier when most is starting to work for Al Smith, that really resonate for me with my years at the Daily Show with Jon Stewart. We didn't get yelled at at the Daily Show with Jon Stewart, but there was a very hectic pace. We had to work really hard. We were putting out TV shows four nights a week that had a lot of substance in them. But you felt like this exact feeling of I'm being pushed to do my best and I'm doing something
书中有好几次——这是其中一次，还有之前摩西开始为阿尔·史密斯工作的时候——这些都让我想起了我在乔恩·斯图尔特《每日秀》（The Daily Show with Jon Stewart）度过的那些岁月。我们在乔恩·斯图尔特的《每日秀》没有挨骂，但那里的节奏非常紧凑。我们必须非常努力地工作。我们一周有四个晚上在制作包含大量实质内容的电视节目。但你会感受到一种确切的感觉：我被推着去做最好的自己，我在做一件
that feels important and I want to do it as well as possible and I want to make it as funny as possible while also saying something. And there's something very exciting about that. And especially when you're young and a lot of the people working for him are relatively young men. There's an excitement to doing that, especially when you have the energy to do it. Later on, as we'll see coming up soon, people with families also have to work this hard and it is not as easy. But I see why some of these guys who are working for him here go on to work for him for decades and will defend him
感觉很重要的事，我想尽可能好地完成它，我想在表达一些观点的同时尽可能让它变得有趣。这其中有一种非常令人兴奋的东西。特别是当你年轻的时候，为他工作的许多人都是相对年轻的男性。做这件事有一种兴奋感，尤其是当你还有精力去做的时候。后来，正如我们很快将看到的，有家庭的人也必须这么努力地工作，这就没那么容易了。但我明白为什么在这里为他工作的这些家伙后来为他工作了几十年，并会在卡罗面前为他辩护
to Cairo throughout So they got to do work on Jones Beach. It's the winter. We're gonna wait till the winter is over to survey this beach, right? No, we're not gonna do that. You have to go out. We have to get it done. Go out there Well, sometimes the water freezes and we can't get off the beach So bring rations with you so you can live there at one point point, the bay freezes for 10 days and most surveyors have just trapped there and they just eat nothing but pancakes because that's all they brought with them is pancake fix and they can never eat pancakes again because they spent 10 days eating pancakes. The beach level, it's too low to keep the ocean from rising above the road at times. So they're going to have to fill this beach with 40 million
贯穿始终……所以他们得去琼斯海滩干活。现在是冬天。我们要等到冬天过去再去测量这个海滩，对吧？不，我们才不那样做。你必须出去。我们得把活儿干完。去那儿吧。嗯，有时水面结冰了，我们离不开海滩，那就带上口粮，这样你就能在那儿生活了。有一次，海湾结冰了10天，大多数测量员就被困在那里，他们除了吃煎饼什么都不吃，因为他们带的全部东西就是做煎饼的原料，他们再也不想吃煎饼了，因为他们花了10天时间吃煎饼。海滩的高度太低了，无法阻止海水有时涨到道路上方。所以他们得用从海湾底部挖出的4000万
cubic yards of sand fill taken from the bottom of the bay. It has to be dredged up and spread over 17 miles. It's the winter. The crew is living on the ships in the winter of 1927 to 1928, working all day to get it done. The bay bottom sand, it's too fine to stay down when it gets windy. It blows in your face. Now we've got to plant millions of clumps of beach grass by hand to hold it down. We've got to do in the winter. So you've got guys by hand kneeling in the sand, digging holes to plant beach grass as wind is buffeting them and it's freezing. They're just doing it because Moses knows We got to do in the winter. So you've got guys by hand kneeling in the sand, digging holes to plant beach grass as wind is buffeting them and it's freezing. They're just doing it because Moses knows
立方码的沙子填满这个海滩。这些沙子必须被疏浚并铺在17英里的长度上。现在是冬天。在1927年到1928年的冬天，施工人员住在船上，整天工作以完成任务。海湾底部的沙子太细了，起风时根本呆不住。它会吹到你的脸上。现在我们得亲手种植数百万丛海滩草来把它固定住。我们必须在冬天做这件事。所以你会看到工人们跪在沙子里用手挖洞来种植海滩草，当时狂风呼啸，天寒地冻。他们这么做只是因为摩西知道我们必须在冬天做这件事。所以你会看到工人们跪在沙子里用手挖洞来种植海滩草，当时狂风呼啸，天寒地冻。他们这么做只是因为摩西知道
they have to get it done enough before Smith gets out of office. The contractor was building the causeway. He's like, look, I'm out of money. I can't meet my payroll. So if we don't get another $20,000, we're not gonna do it. Moses can't get the government to pay it to him. So as he always has done, he turns to his mom
他们必须在史密斯离任前把足够多的工作赶完。建造堤道的承包商说：“听着，我没钱了。我发不出工资了。所以如果我们拿不到另外2万美元，我们就干不下去了。”摩西无法让政府把这笔钱付给他。于是，正如他一贯的做法那样，他向他的母亲求助，
and borrows that money from his mother, which again, it is bonkers to him. So as he always has done, he turns to his mom and borrows that money from his mother, which again, it is bonkers to me. The idea where it's like, well, this is a government project, but we gotta get it done. So mom, can you give me $20,000 so I can pay these guys to build a highway? It's so funny. He's ignoring legal injunctions to stop working.
向他母亲借了这笔钱，这在他看来又是一件疯狂的事。所以，正如他一贯的做法那样，他向他的母亲求助，向他母亲借了这笔钱，这在我看来又是一件疯狂的事。这种想法就像是：嗯，这是一个政府项目，但我们必须把它完成。所以，妈妈，你能给我2万美元，好让我付钱给这些家伙去修高速公路吗？这太搞笑了。他无视旨在停止工作的法律禁令。
Like he's still working and he is building Jones Beach. And he's getting closer and closer to the point where the landscape stops being his and starts belonging to Babylon Township. He needs that land before he can build the roads that are gonna reach his beach and reach other places that make that land valuable. And he doesn't want someone to see
就像他还在继续工作，在建造琼斯海滩。而且他越来越接近这样一个临界点：这片风景不再属于他，而是开始属于巴比伦镇（Babylon Township）。他需要这片土地，然后才能修建通往他的海滩以及使这片土地变得有价值的其他地方的道路。他不希望有人看到
that the road is going there, buy it up and build crappy, gaudy beach stuff. He wants it for himself because he needs to someday be able to build his bridge that goes from there to Fire Island. He has so many plans he needs this land for. He tries threatening the Babylon town board. It doesn't work. He's unpopular there. He's living there at the time. So when his wife goes to the stores to get to buy things, she's getting dirty looks from the people in town. One day he's practicing driving in case he ever does it. He's never going to.
道路要通往那里，然后把地买下来，建起那些俗气的、艳俗的海滩建筑。他要把地留给自己，因为他总有一天需要能够建造从那里通往火岛（Fire Island）的桥梁。他有那么多的计划，需要这片土地来实现。他试图威胁巴比伦镇董事会。这没用。他在那里并不受欢迎。他当时就住在那里。所以当他的妻子去商店买东西时，镇上的人都会对她翻白眼。有一天他在练习开车以防哪天真要开——虽然他永远不会开。
He meets an old man and the old man is like, hey, my father was a judge in the county. And he and another judge, they had to resolve a case about who owns the bay bottom, this sacred bay bottom that Babylon Township has been leasing out to fishermen. It's there. It's the thing they've been protecting for generations. Hey, why don't you go talk to this other old man who dealt with the case? He has something interesting to tell you and this other even older man tells Moses That when they were looking at this who knows how many years back They discovered that there was there were two laws that were gonna be passed in the mid 19th century Giving half the Bay bottom to Nassau County and half to Suffolk County the Nassau County half passed the Suffolk County half
他遇到了一位老人，老人的父亲曾是该县的一名法官。他和另一名法官不得不解决一起关于谁拥有海湾底部的案件，这个神圣的海湾底部一直是巴比伦镇租给渔民的地方。它就在那里。这是他们几代人一直在保护的东西。嘿，你为什么不去跟那个处理过这个案件的另一位老人谈谈呢？他有些有趣的事情要告诉你。而另一个更老的老人告诉摩西，
They never got around to it They never passed it. So that Bay bottom that Babylon treats as sacred and they lease out and they don't want anyone ever to impinge on it, they don't own it. They don't actually own it. No, it belongs to New York State. They forgot that they don't own it.
当他们在不知多少年前研究这件事时，他们发现19世纪中期原本要通过两条法律，把海湾底部的一半给拿骚县（Nassau County），一半给萨福克县（Suffolk County）。拿骚县的那一半通过了，而萨福克县的那一半，他们从来没有顾得上处理。他们从未通过它。所以，被巴比伦镇视为神圣并出租、不希望任何人侵犯的海湾底部，其实根本不属于他们。他们实际上并不拥有它。不，它属于纽约州。他们忘了这根本不属于他们。
And Moses uses that information and he calls it blackjacking, that he blackjacks the town council, but it's blackmail. I don't know why you would say blackjack instead of blackmail, because I guess it sounds cooler. It's like he hit the town council over but it's blackmail. I don't know why you would say blackjack instead of blackmail. Cause I guess it sounds cooler. It's like he hit the town council over the head with this information. He says, if you don't give me the Jones beach land in exchange for the city, finally giving you this Bay bottom.
摩西利用了这个信息，他称之为“二十一点勒索（blackjacking）”——他用这个信息给镇议会施加了压力，但这就是敲诈。我不知道你为什么要把敲诈勒索（blackmail）说成是“二十一点勒索（blackjack）”，因为我猜这听起来更酷。这就像他用这个信息狠狠地敲了镇议会的脑袋……但这就是敲诈。我不知道你为什么要把敲诈勒索说成是“二十一点勒索”。因为我猜这听起来更酷。这就像他用这个信息狠狠地敲了镇议会的脑袋。他说：“如果你不把琼斯海滩的土地交出来，用来换取城市最终把这个海湾底部交给你，
I'll reveal to your citizens that you have spent 70 years leasing it out to fishermen when you don't even own it because you never bothered to finish the job of getting legal control over it. And they go, okay, okay. well, we'll hold a referendum. How about that? We'll hold a referendum about whether you'll get this land. And Moses says, that's fine. And you know what?
我就向你们的市民揭露，你们居然花了70年时间把根本不属于你们的海湾底部租给渔民，因为你们从来懒得去获得对它的法律控制权。”而他们回答：“好吧，好吧。嗯，我们要举行一次全民公投。这样行吗？我们将就你是否能得到这块土地举行一次全民公投。”而摩西说：“那很好。而且你知道吗？
This referendum voting shouldn't just be open to taxpayers here. It should be open to anyone who lives in town, including the employees of my projects that are living here temporarily. And you know what? We're going to hold it on the day of primary, but the primary hours voting is going to be open till nine o'clock. The referendum hours, the voting is going to end at six. And so they're bringing in by car state employees from out of town to vote. There's no clear voter registration rules. They can't tell people not to vote.
这次全民公投的投票不应该只对这里的纳税人开放。它应该对镇上的任何居民开放，包括临时居住在这里的我的项目的员工。而且你知道吗？我们要在初选日当天举行公投，但初选的投票时间将一直开放到九点。公投的投票时间将在六点结束。”于是他们用车把外地的州政府员工接来投票。根本没有清晰的选民登记规则。他们无法阻止人们投票。
People show up to vote after six and find that they cannot vote in the referendum on the primary. Even with all that, the referendum ends, Moses wins by seven votes. And so with all of that, and he barely gets it, but now he finally has that land. And I just love, I love that it feels again, like a movie where it's like, if only I had some special information I could use to get this land and an old man says, well, you might, you might look back here. Where'd this old man come from? Look, these were the days when there was,
人们在六点后赶来投票，却发现他们无法在初选的公投中投票。即便如此，公投结束了，摩西以七票的优势获胜。因此，凭借这一切，他勉强赢得了土地，但现在他终于得到了那块土地。我就是喜欢，我喜欢这种感觉再次像是一部电影：要是我能有一些特殊信息来换取这块土地就好了，然后一位老人说：嗯，你或许可以，你或许可以去查查这个。这老头打哪儿冒出来的？看，在那个年代，
if you want information, you had to find an old man. So he could tell you, they didn't have the internet. There weren't a lot of encyclopedias. You had to get an old man to give you some information. Yeah, yeah. And this is another instance of Robert Moses kind of using the sort of like, the inept practices of his opponents against them.
如果你想要信息，你必须去找一个老人。这样他才能告诉你，那时没有互联网。也没有多少百科全书。你得找个老头来给你提供一些信息。是的，是的。这也是罗伯特·摩西利用对手的无能做法来对付他们的又一个例子。
Yes. It's like, I'm going to embarrass you with how bad you are at this. If you don't just give me what I want. And it works a lot. I mean, Bel Moskowitz kind of taught him this stuff. We talked about in the last episode with the dancing halls, when she cleaned those up, where she said,
是的。这就好比，如果你不乖乖把我要的给我，我就会因为你在这方面有多糟糕而让你难堪。这招屡试不爽。我的意思是，贝尔·莫斯科维茨（Bel Moskowitz）某种程度上教给了他这些东西。我们在上一集里谈到舞厅时提到了她是如何整顿那些地方的，当时她说：
I could reveal that you are running these places of predation, or we can just, we can register them and no one has to know about it. And he, he's using those lessons he learned from Bell that instead of a frontal attack often you can get around the back and make an agreement with your enemies that they won't like, but you'll get what you want. And he's not in it. Look, he's like a reality show contestant. He's not here to make friends. He's here to win. You know, he's, he's, he's all about parks. He's not here to make friends. He's here to win, you know, he's, he's, he's all about parks.
我可以揭露你们在经营这些充满掠夺性的地方，或者我们可以把它们注册登记，这样就没人知道了。而他，他正在运用他从贝尔那里学到的经验：与其进行正面进攻，不如常常从背后迂回，与你的敌人达成他们可能不喜欢但能让你如愿以偿的协议。他不属于这里。听着，他就像个真人秀选手。他来这里不是为了交朋友的。他是来赢的。你知道的，他，他，他一门心思扑在公园上。他来这里不是为了交朋友的。他是来赢的，你知道的，他，他，他一门心思扑在公园上。
He's not here to make friends with the Babylon town council, but he's running out of time Smith's governorship is almost up. There's a law that says you cannot run for president and governor at the same time in New York state and Smith wants to be president so badly. And so Moses is working fast in less than three years. He's got all the land he needs for the Southern state parkway. He has 21 miles of it in various stages of work. In that time, he's also expanded Long Island's state park space. It's gone from
他来这里可不是为了跟巴比伦镇议会交朋友的，但他时间不多了。史密斯的州长任期快要结束了。有一条法律规定，在纽约州，你不能同时竞选总统和州长，而史密斯太想当总统了。因此摩西正在快马加鞭地工作。在不到三年的时间里，他拿到了修建南州公园大道所需的所有土地。他在不同施工阶段拥有了21英里的路段。在这段时间里，他还扩大了长岛的州立公园面积。它已经从
200 acres to 9,700 acres across 14 parks. He's acquired that land for about a million dollars, even though the land value at the time was more than 15 times that. Through picking up land the government already owns, making deals with people, trading things, he started building facilities in those parks. Bathhouses, baseball fields, picnic areas, playgrounds, diving boards, hiking paths, roads. Jones Beach in 1926 is nothing but sand. Now it's got these two enormous, these beautiful bathhouses. And here's another passage that I'd love to read to you, just about the immediate effect of this, after this hurry, this frenzy of work. During the summer of 1928, park-seeking families heading out of New York City
200英亩增加到分布在14个公园中的9700英亩。他以大约100万美元的价格收购了这片土地，尽管当时的土地价值是这个数字的15倍以上。通过接手政府已经拥有的土地、与人们做交易、进行置换，他开始在这些公园里建造设施。浴室、棒球场、野餐区、游乐场、跳水板、远足小径、道路。1926年的琼斯海滩除了沙子什么都没有。现在它有了这两座巨大的、美丽的浴室。这里还有另一段我很想读给你们听的文字，关于在经历了一阵狂热的工作之后，这一切产生的即时效果。在1928年的夏天，寻求公园的出游家庭涌出纽约市，
began to feel Long Island open up to them. Week by week, words spread. At the beginning of the summer, the bathhouse at Valley Stream State Park contained a thousand lockers. For a few weekends, these were sufficient. Then they were not. Another thousand lockers were added. Then another thousand. And even so, by the end of the summer, thousands of would-be bathers were being turned away every weekend. by the end of the summer, thousands of would-be bathers were being turned away every weekend. By the end of the summer, attendance at Long Island State
开始感受到长岛向他们敞开了怀抱。一周接一周，消息传开了。夏天刚开始时，山谷溪流州立公园（Valley Stream State Park）的浴室里有一千个储物柜。头几个周末，这些还够用。然后就不够了。又增加了一千个储物柜。接着又是一千个。即便如此，到了夏天结束时，每个周末仍有成千上万想去洗澡的人被拒之门外。到了夏天结束时，每个周末仍有成千上万想去洗澡的人被拒之门外。到夏天结束时，长岛州立
parks had passed half a million. So there was this need. People do love these parks. They're already using them. And there's also a foreshadowing here of what's going to happen when Moses builds roads. Later on, he's going to build expressways and bridges to cut down on traffic only for more and more cars
公园的访客量已经超过了五十万。所以确实有这种需求。人们真的很喜欢这些公园。他们已经在使用了。而且这里也预示了后来当摩西修建道路时会发生的事情。后来，他将修建高速公路和桥梁来减少交通拥堵，结果却引来更多、更多的汽车
to fill up these roads. And he's seeing that happen with people. But here there's something kind of joyous about it because it's like, yeah, people are using the parks. This is amazing. This is great. He's already making this dream happen in reality. And the press loves him. They give Moses all the credit. He's becoming a popular hero in New York. And Robert Caro has an interesting comparison here where he's like,
涌入这些道路。他看到这种情况正在人们身上发生。但在这里，某种程度上有一种喜悦感，因为感觉就像是：太棒了，人们正在使用这些公园。这太神奇了。这太棒了。他已经把这个梦想变成了现实。而且媒体很喜欢他。他们把所有的功劳都记在摩西头上。他正在成为纽约家喻户晓的英雄。而罗伯特·卡罗在这里做了一个有趣的对比：
Moses was getting far more New York headlines than Einstein's new theory of relativity. Einstein had a new version of the theory of relativity that was coming out the same time. And yeah, it's an interesting way to measure relative popularity. Totally. Because it's not like there's newsies on the street corner going, extra, extra, read all about it. Time slows down as you approach the speed of light. Extra, extra, read all about it. Time slows down as you approach the speed of light. But it's a, I guess it shows you how big a name Moses is. Even the most famous scientist in the world, you know,
摩西获得的纽约头条新闻远远多于爱因斯坦的新相对论。爱因斯坦的新版相对论几乎是同时问世的。是的，这是一种衡量相对受欢迎程度的有趣方式。完全如此。因为街角可没有什么报童在大喊：“号外，号外，快看新闻！当你接近光速时，时间会变慢。号外，号外，快看新闻！当你接近光速时，时间会变慢。”但这，我猜这也向你展示了摩西的名气有多大。连世界上最著名的科学家，你知道的，
is getting less press. One funny thing is they keep giving him middle initials in the press, even though he doesn't have ones. They're making up middle initials for his name. He's like Robert A. Moses or Robert T. Moses. And the legend is being built. Here's this public servant. He doesn't care about making money.
获得的媒体关注都更少。一个有趣的事是，媒体不断给他的名字加上中间名首字母，尽管他根本没有中间名。他们在为他的名字捏造中间名首字母。他成了“罗伯特·A·摩西（Robert A. Moses）”或者“罗伯特·T·摩西（Robert T. Moses）”。传奇正在被构建。这就是这位公务员。他根本不在乎赚钱。
He makes very little money, but he wants to build parks. And now his Long Island dream is pretty much safe. But he's actually accomplished even more than it seems, because while he's been building all this Long Island stuff, he's been buying up land and preserving parks upstate in New York also. There's all this land around Lake George, and almost none of it is owned by the state, and it's been opened up to development and logging. And he persuades some of the rich old men there to give him 11,000 acres of land for the bargain basement price of $75,000.
他赚的钱非常少，但他一心只想建造公园。现在他的长岛之梦可以说是稳操胜券了。但他实际上取得的成就比表面上看起来还要多，因为在建设所有这些长岛项目的同时，他还在纽约州北部收购土地并保护公园。乔治湖（Lake George）周围有大片土地，其中几乎没有一块属于州政府，并且已经向开发和伐木开放。他游说那里的一些富有的老头把11000英亩的土地以75000美元的白菜价交给他。
And he's preserving Revolutionary War battlefields at Fort Stanton and at Saratoga, over 10,000 acres of Whiteface Mountain. And he's absorbed 70 parks that were kind of already there but not run on a professional basis for another 125,000 acres. He's buying up land in the Adirondacks and the Catskills, or at least obtaining it, and he's building facilities in these places. But since the people upstate don't care about Long Island parks, they don't use those. And the people in New York City, they don't care about the upstate parks. Nobody but Moses really seems to have a total understanding of just how much land he's now made into public parks and how much land is now under his personal control.
他在斯汤顿堡和萨拉托加保护独立战争战场，还保护了白脸山超过1万英亩的土地。他还接管了70个原本就存在、但并未按专业标准运营的公园，面积达12.5万英亩。他在阿迪朗达克山脉和卡茨杀尔山脉买地，或者至少是获取土地，并且他在这些地方建造设施。但由于上州的人不关心长岛的公园，他们不去那些地方。而纽约市的人也不关心上州的公园。除了莫西，似乎没有人对莫西现在建成了多少公共公园、以及多少土地现在处于他的个人控制之下有一个全面的了解。
Yeah. And they don't really understand how much all of the success has changed him. Yes. And Carol ends this chapter talking about how amazing it is. The most remarkable thing maybe is that these parks and parkways, they're so close to the plans that he first presented in the early 1920s. He has, in this short amount of time, he has made his dream, either reality or about to become a reality purely through the power of.
是的。而且他们并不真正了解所有的成功是如何改变他的。是的。卡罗在本章的结尾谈到了这是多么令人惊叹。最值得注意的事情也许是，这些公园和景观大道，与他在20世纪20年代初首次提出的规划如此接近。在这么短的时间内，他完全凭借着……的力量，将自己的梦想变成了现实，或者即将变成现实。
Political sliminess and pushing people really hard and lying to people and just doing them to oblivion, not showing up to his own depositions, things like that. Yeah, that's there's, we, we skipped over that, but there's a part during the lawsuit that Macy has against him where he's not showing up to his own depositions, you know, things like that, yeah. We skipped over that, but there's a part during the lawsuit that Macy has against him where he's not showing up because he's too busy. And then also his lawyer just stays away for one day. He says, I'm too busy, I can't show up at court. And then when the court reconvenes, he's like,
政治上的卑劣手段、对人们的强力施压、对人们撒谎以及彻底把他们搞垮，不出庭应诉自己的取证，诸如此类的事情。是的，那是……我们，我们跳过了那部分，但在梅西对他的诉讼期间，有一个部分是他没有出庭作证，你知道，诸如此类的事情，是的。我们跳过了那部分，但在梅西对他的诉讼期间，有一部分是他没有出庭，因为他太忙了。然后他的律师也有一天缺席。他说，我太忙了，我不能出庭。然后当法院复会时，他说：
well, certainly we can't, I wasn't even here yet last time. We can't do anything now. And... What kind of a court is this, having the trial without me even present? I wasn't even here. This is outrageous. All right, moving on, the next chapter is chapter 14, changing.
好吧，当然我们不能，上次我甚至都还没来呢。我们现在什么也做不了。而且……这算什么法庭，在我甚至都不在场的情况下进行审判？我当时甚至都不在这里。这太离谱了。好了，继续，下一章是第14章，改变。
Elliot, what is Carrow referring to when he says changing here? Well, everyone knows that ch-ch-ch-ch-change is time may change you, but you can't change time. In this case, power can also change you, but you can't change time. And in this case, power can also change you, but you can't change power, I guess. Robert Moses is, before our very eyes, through Caro's eyes, is changing as a result of suddenly having power. All the negative traits he had before have become enlarged and kind of enhanced because people can't say no to him. So the arrogance, the impatience, the condescension, his refusal to compromise. Those were all there in his character. Again, he was Bela Coen's son.
埃利奥特，卡罗在这里说“改变”时指的是什么？嗯，大家都知道，时——时——时——时间可能会改变你，但你无法改变时间。在这种情况下，权力也可以改变你，但你无法改变时间。而且在这种情况下，权力也可以改变你，但我想你无法改变权力。在我们的眼皮底下，通过卡罗的眼睛，罗伯特·摩西正在因为突然拥有了权力而发生改变。他以前所有的负面特质都被放大并某种程度上增强了，因为人们无法对他说不。所以傲慢、不耐烦、居高临下的态度、他拒绝妥协。这些都存在于他的性格中。再说一次，他是贝拉·科恩的儿子。
He has her qualities, but now he also has the power that means he doesn't have to hide those qualities. He doesn't have to temper them. And his earlier idealism is giving away to the easier way to do things, the more effective way to do things. He no longer has as much of a positive path set before him to follow. He has power now, and he's determined to do things his own way, no matter what. And so he starts lashing out at people who disagree with them. If you're on the phone with him and you disagree with him, he'll just hang up on you. He doesn't care who you are. He ignores the press.
他有着她的特质，但现在他也有了权力，这意味着他不必隐藏这些特质。他不必缓和它们。他早期的理想主义正在让位于更轻松的做事方式、更有效率的做事方式。他面前不再有那么多积极的道路可供遵循。他现在有了权力，无论如何他都决心按自己的方式做事。因此，他开始抨击那些不同意他观点的人。如果你在电话里跟他意见不合，他会直接挂断你的电话。他才不在乎你是谁。他无视媒体。
He insults legislators to their faces. There's one particular, there's a particular passage here that I'd love Roman, if you and I could, could talk about when a particular legislator named Jeremiah F. Toomey, the Senate Finance Committee chairman, he represents Brooklyn, he stops by to talk to Moses about a bill that Moses has that might provide some patronage. And it was reported to Caro as happening this way. Roman, would you prefer to be Mr. Moses or Mr. Toomey? I don't know.
当面侮辱立法者。有一个特别的，这里有一个特别的段落，罗曼，如果你和我能，能聊聊的话，我会很高兴，当一个名叫杰里米·F·图米（Jeremiah F. Toomey）的特定立法者，参议院财政委员会主席，他代表布鲁克林，他顺道拜访摩西，谈论一件摩西提出的可能会带来一些政务任免权的法案。据向卡罗汇报，事情是这样的。罗曼，你更愿意当莫西先生还是图米先生？我不知道。
I don't know. Let me do Bob Moses. Let me do Bob Moses. Okay, you'll take the plum part. That's Mr. Toomy? I don't know. I don't know. Let me, let me, let me, let me do Bob Moses. Let me do Bob Moses. Okay. You'll take the plum part. That's fine. You're the, you're the boss. That's okay.
我不知道。让我来演鲍勃·摩西。让我来演鲍勃·摩西。好吧，你挑个讨巧的角色。那是图米先生？我不知道。我不知道。让我，让我，让我，让我来演鲍勃·摩西。让我来演鲍勃·摩西。好吧。你挑个讨巧的角色。好吧。你是，你是老板。没关系。
A very Moses move to do that. So, uh, this is how apparently Toomy told the story. Toomy says, Bob, it looks like there'll be a lot of jobs out there. And I was wondering if we could get a couple. Well, what did you have in mind, Jerry? Jerry mentions one job and Moses says very softly, very politely. Do you have anything else in mind Jerry? Jerry completely taken in, thinking that for once this fellow is going to be reasonable,
这很有摩西的风格。所以，呃，显然图米是这样讲述这个故事的。图米说：“鲍勃，看起来外面会有很多工作机会。我想知道我们能不能弄到几个。”“嗯，杰里，你有什么想法吗？”杰里提到了一份工作，摩西非常轻声、非常礼貌地说道：“杰里，你还有别的想法吗？”杰里完全被蒙在鼓里，以为这个家伙破例要讲道理了，
mentions a couple of other jobs and Moses says, Do you have anything else in your mind Jerry? Jerry says, Well, that's about all. And Moses says, Jerry, you can take that bill and stick it up your ass. Perfectly done. So that's the way he talks to the legislators that he's working with. He's just, he's like, yeah, yeah, sure.
又提到了另外几份工作，摩西说：“杰里，你脑子里还有别的想法吗？”杰里说：“嗯，差不多就这些了。”摩西说：“杰里，你可以把那份法案拿去塞进你的屁股里。”做得太完美了。这就是他与合作的立法者说话的方式。他只是，他就像是，好啊，好啊，当然。
Yeah, okay, yeah, of course. Anything else you want? Well, get the hell out of my office. Like it's, I love that not just that he yelled at him, but that he led him along, that took him down the garden path, you know, to get there. I think that he projects such invincibility. It's, you guys are asking Kara about this.
行，可以，好，当然。你还想要别的吗？那就给我滚出我的办公室。就像是，我喜欢的不只是他朝他吼叫，而是他牵着他的鼻子走，把他引入歧途（顺便带上了林荫小道），你知道，才到达那一步。我认为他表现出了一种不可战胜的姿态。这是，你们在向卡罗询问这件事。
Like, why didn't people just fire him or accept his resignations eventually? Like, it's his psychic armor is only like growing more powerful. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And that's how Moses is dealing with his ostensible opponents. These are like the Republicans in the legislature,
比如，为什么人们最终不直接解雇他或接受他的辞职？就像是，他的心理铠甲只是变得越来越强大。是的，是的，是的。这就是摩西对待他表面上的对手的方式。这些人就像是立法机构中的共和党人，
but he's also dealing with his ostensible allies that way. One of the ways he was able to get his bill passed that gave him all this power was because he had the support of the people who would become the members of the state parks council, these older men, their pillars of their community is all over the state and they run little parks and they don't like how fast he's moving. They see that this land, when we change it, we can never go back. We can never undo these changes.
但他也是这样对待他的表观盟友的。他能够通过赋予他所有这些权力的法案的方法之一，是因为他得到了那些将成为州公园委员会成员的人的支持，这些老年人，他们是全州各地社区的中流砥柱，他们管理着小公园，而且他们不喜欢他行动的速度。他们看到这片土地，一旦我们改变它，我们就永远无法回头。我们永远无法撤销这些改变。
So let's take our time with it. They don't like his methods for taking land. They don't want to lose control of their own individual parks. And he had promised them this state parks council, this is an advisory council. This is not a supervisory council. And they soon learn that's not the case anymore. Now that he doesn't need their support, he starts refusing their budget requests. He's rude to them. And they, they, they everybody, finally read the law that they helped him pass and they go, oh, that's not what they wanted.
所以让我们慢慢来。他们不喜欢他征用土地的方法。他们不想失去对自己各个独立公园的控制权。而他曾向他们承诺过这个州公园委员会，这是一个咨询委员会。这不是一个监督委员会。他们很快就发现情况不再如此了。既然他不再需要他们的支持，他便开始拒绝他们的预算申请。他对他们很粗鲁。而且他们，他们，他们所有人，终于读了他们曾帮他通过的法律，然后他们说，哦，那不是他们想要的。
And they cannot stop him from putting his own projects through, he controls enough votes on the council. They can't stop him from being elected as chairman of the council. And some of this is genuine philosophical differences about how land should be used, whether it should be conservation or recreation, but other is just about power. And there's one story in particular that Carroll tells that we'll go over quickly,
他们无法阻止他推进自己的项目，他在委员会中控制了足够的票数。他们无法阻止他被选举为委员会主席。其中一些是关于土地应该如何使用、应该是保护还是娱乐的真正哲学分歧，但另一些则纯粹关乎权力。卡罗讲述了一个特别的故事，我们会快速过一遍，
where the treatment of two members of the Niagara State Park Commission, the elderly Judge Clearwater and the also elderly Ansley Wilcox. Judge Clearwater is a former political power in New York State, and he was semi-retired, but he went to lobby in Moses' behalf during the Ataylor State fight. Ansley Wilcox, Carol presents him as almost single-handedly responsible for making Niagara State Park a thing, that when he was a young man, he surveyed it on his own and then lobbied to get it made a park and has care taken it for years. And they also want to develop the park. They're not disagreeing with Moses about developing the park in some way. Wilcox is dying of cancer. He wants to see this park finished and used before he dies. So they agree with Moses' plans on the
其中讲述了对尼亚加拉州公园委员会（Niagara State Park Commission）两名成员的处理，年迈的克利尔沃特法官（Judge Clearwater）和同样年迈的安斯利·威尔科克斯（Ansley Wilcox）。克利尔沃特法官是纽约州前政治权贵，他半退休了，但在泰勒州之争期间，他曾为摩西出面游说。安斯利·威尔科克斯，卡罗将他描绘成几乎凭借一己之力让尼亚加拉州公园成为现实的人，当他年轻时，他独自对它进行了测绘，然后游说将其建成公园，并多年来一直对其进行照料。他们也想开发这个公园。他们并不反对摩西以某种方式开发公园。威尔科克斯因癌症病危。他希望在死前看到这个公园完工并投入使用。所以他们同意摩西的计划，
most part, but they want to control it. This is their park. They've been running it for a long time now. They don't agree with all of Moses' individual decisions, and they don't really care about this larger parkway system that Moses sees as a piece of. They're not part of that. They just like this Niagara park. They've arranged for the Niagara Power Company to buy a little bit of land that the park needs for its roads and to donate that land to the park. And Moses uses this, you know, benevolent thing that they've done in order to start rumors that Wilcox and Clearwater, who at this point also Carol relays it on, are very sick old men. Like they're both sick. They can't even go to all the meetings. Moses
在很大程度上，但他们想要控制它。这是他们的公园。他们经营了很长时间了。他们不同意摩西的所有个人决定，他们其实并不在乎摩西视为其中一部分的那个更宏大的公园大道系统。他们不属于那一部分。他们只喜欢这个尼亚加拉公园。他们安排了尼亚加拉电力公司购买了一小块公园修路所需的土地，并将这块土地捐赠给公园。而摩西利用他们所做的这一慈善举动，开始散布谣言，称威尔科克斯和克利尔沃特（此时卡罗也转述了这一点）是病得很重的老人。就像他们两个都生病了一样。他们甚至不能去参加所有的会议。摩西
uses that to create, start rumors that they are colluding with the power company for profit. And there's a bunch of machinations. There's an investigative hearing where during the hearing, they refuse to admit that there are charges they're investigating. And then they release, then a report gets written that says there's no problem here and the report doesn't get released.
利用这一点来制造、散布谣言，称他们为了利润与电力公司勾结。还有一堆阴谋诡计。有一场调查听证会，在听证会上，他们拒绝承认存在他们正在调查的指控。然后他们发布了，接着一份报告被撰写出来，称这里没有问题，并且该报告没有被公开发布。
But Wilcox keeps saying, can you send me the report so I can clear my name? And Moses sends around a letter that's meant as a reply to Wilcox without sending Wilcox's letter where it's like, I don't know why you sent this insulting letter to us. I don't know why you had to take this abusive tone. And Wilcox is in such bad health that it takes him five days to dictate
但威尔科克斯一直说，你能把报告发给我，好让我澄清我的名声吗？而摩西四处散发了一封旨在回复威尔科克斯的信，却没有发送威尔科克斯的信，信里写道：“我不知道你为什么要给我们寄这封侮辱性的信。我不知道你为什么要采取这种谩骂的语气。”而威尔科克斯的健康状况如此糟糕，以至于他花了五天时间口述
this 10-page letter laying out the facts of what happened, accusing Moses of abusing his power. And at the end of the letter, he says, you know, few will read this letter and fewer still will understand it. and Cairo says, he was right. And on page 254 he goes, the old man was right. His letter lay unread in an unopened folder in a dusty Albany warehouse for 42 years. And although in the 43rd year the folder was opened, parentheses, by the author, and the letter was read, and although it provided the first detailed account of the changes
这封长达10页的信，列出了发生的事情的事实，指责摩西滥用权力。信的末尾，他说：“你知道，没几个人会读这封信，更少的人会理解它。”卡罗说：“他是对的。”在第254页，他说：“老人是对的。他的信在奥尔巴尼一个满是灰尘的仓库里，躺在一个未打开的文件夹里，未被阅读地度过了42年。”尽管在第43年，这个文件夹被打开了（括号内注：由作者本人），信也被阅读了，尽管它提供了第一份关于权力饥渴在罗伯特·摩西身上引起的变化的详细记述，但它无法写出摩西对安斯利·威尔科克斯犯下的所有不义行为中最糟糕的一桩，他说摩西移除了公园里所有提及威尔科克斯名字的牌匾，换成了提及摩西名字的牌匾，在那里修建的公园大道就是罗伯特·摩西公园大道。有朝一日将在那里建造的大坝，这座巨大的发电大坝，将是罗伯特·摩西大坝。他从他创建的公园里抹去了威尔科克斯的记忆。这就像是，什么，拜托，有，你为什么这么做？
wrought in Robert Moses by his hunger for power, it could not write the worst of all the injustices, Moses perpetrated by Ansley Wilcox, and he says that Moses has removed all the plaques from the park that mention Wilcox's name and replaced them with plaques that mention Moses's name, and the parkway that gets built there is the Robert Moses Parkway. The dam that will someday be built there, this huge power dam, will be the Robert Moses Dam. He has erased Wilcox's memory from the park he created. And it's like, what, come on, there's, why are you doing that?
你为什么要这样对待这个老头？是的，我的意思是，他表现出了一种真正存在于此的残酷，让人难以释怀。是的，罗伯特·卡罗在他的书中有这样一种习惯，喜欢把代表过去做事方式、并且其离去象征着旧方式消亡和主角做事方式崛起的老年人进行英雄化和圣洁化。他曾因
What are you doing that to this old man for? Yeah, I mean, he presents, there's a kind of cruelty to it that is really present here, that it's hard to get over. Yes, and Robert Carroll has a habit in his books of kind of lionizing and sanctifying old men who represent a previous way of doing things and whose passing symbolizes the passing of the old way and the rise of the main character's way of doing things. He's been criticized for the
处理科克·史蒂文森（Coke Stevenson）的方式而受到批评，科克在《权力的手段》（Means of Ascent）一书中曾与林登·约翰逊竞选参议员。但在这里，很难看出这两个家伙的负面影响是什么，这只显示出摩西对他们的对待是多么的不必要地残酷，他们对他的计划构成了多么小的威胁，而他却不得不这样做。而且卡罗，我喜欢卡罗带有一点点印第安纳·琼斯式的英雄动作，他说：“我就是那个在仓库里满是灰尘的文件夹里找到那封信的人。”太棒了。
way he handled Coke Stevenson, who was running against Lyndon Johnson for the Senate in the book Means of Ascent. But here it's kind of hard to see what the what the negative side is of these two guys and it just shows how unnecessarily cruel Moses's treatment of them is, how what little threat they were to his plans and how he had to do this. And Carrow, I love that Carrow gets in that little bit of like Indiana Jones hero action by being like, I'm the one who found that that letter in that dusty folder in the in the warehouse. It's so good.
我喜欢他透露自己的一点创作过程，而这流露了出来。而且真的没有其他方式来谈论它了。你知道，他在林登·约翰逊的书里也这样做过，就像是，他拿到了那个篡改了所有选票的家伙的笔记本，你知道，当他赢得第一个参议院席位时，你知道，里面有同样的东西。
I like when he reveals a little bit of his process and it comes through. And there's no other way to really talk about it. You know, like he does this in the Lyndon Johnson books too, which was like, he gets the notebook of the guy who fixed all the ballots, you know, when he won his first Senate seat, you know, it has the same thing.
而且我确实，你知道，它有同样的东西，而且我确实，我，你知道，这个，真正让人倒胃口的是这里面卡夫卡式的审判性质，他们被指控了什么，但随后他们说他们并没有真正被指控，所以他们无法真正反击。然后他们陷入了这种奇怪而模糊的指控中，说他们以这种奇怪的方式与某人勾结。对于这个公务员，或者，你知道，无论如何，这个致力于一项使命的人，这是一个相当崇高的使命。
And I do, you know, it's it has the same thing and I do, I, you know, the, it's the, what really turns your stomach is the Kafkaesque trial quality to this, that they get accused of something, but then they're saying they're not really accused so they can't really fight it. And then they get stuck in this just weird vague accusations that they're colluding with someone in this weird way. And for this public servant or or, you know, whatever, this guy committed to a mission, which is a pretty noble mission.
而一个有使命的人能够完全、彻底地去破坏一个一生大部分时间都在诚实做事的人，这实在是太恶劣了。是的。这也强调了摩西认为重要的事情，那就是把你的名字留在某个地方，对吧？就像是，你知道，这就像是，我要从他那里把那拿走。那将是某种终极惩罚。
And it's just sort of gross how someone with a mission can just totally just like undermine someone who has, you know, been acting in good faith most of his life. Yes. It also, it emphasizes what Moses thinks matters, which is having your name on a place, right? Like, you know, it's like, I'll take that away from him. That'll be the sort of ultimate punishment.
令人惊叹的是，竟然花了这么多人来弄清楚尼亚加拉瀑布应该有一个公园。我刚刚意识到这家伙就像是，你知道，我们应该在这里建个公园。这些瀑布非常漂亮。很好，我们可以有个地方站着看它们。是的。这表明他们把这些事情视为理所当然的程度有多高。
Amazing that it took this many people to figure out there should be a park where Niagara Falls is. I'm just realizing this guy is like, you know, we should put a park here. These waterfalls are very pretty. Lovely, we could have a place to stand to look at them. Yeah. It's a, it shows you how much they took for granted.
这些东西将永远存在，永远留在这里。我认为直到尼亚加拉瀑布成为一个旅游景点并且变得有点恶心时，才有所改变。我不知道你去没去过尼亚加拉瀑布，但它——有点恶心。我的意思是，瀑布很不错。除了瀑布之外，但它，它，它，它有点恶心。我的意思是，除了瀑布，它有点，我的意思是，也许不一样。当我还是个孩子的时候，我记得就像是，有尼亚加拉瀑布，还有雷普利礼堂（Ripley's auditorium）。
These things will always be around and always be here. And I think it isn't until Niagara Falls becomes a tourist spot and gets really kind of gross. I don't know if you've been to Niagara Falls, but it's- It's a little gross. I mean, the falls are nice. Aside from Falls, but it's, it's, it's, it's a little gross. I mean, aside from the falls, it's kind of, I mean, maybe it's different. When I was a kid, I remember it was like, there's Niagara Falls and there's Ripley's auditorium.
就像他们有杂耍动物的那种地方。是的。是的。是的。但有趣的是他们会说，嗯，等一下，等一下。你知道，这是一块好地。也许这里应该有个公园。嗯，但每个创意都必须由某人发起。公园委员会的其他老头们就像是，史密斯州长，解雇摩西。而立法者们就像是，解雇摩西。而史密斯拒绝了。首先，公园是很好的拉票工具。其次，史密斯全心看重忠诚。他对忠诚于我，我忠诚于他。第三，没有人比罗伯特·摩西为阿尔·史密斯工作更卖力了。阿尔·史密斯能看到
Like where they have like the sideshow animals. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. But it is funny that they're like, well, wait a minute, wait a minute. You know, this is nice land. Maybe it should be a park here. Um, but every idea has got to start with someone. And the other old men of the parks Commission, they're like, Governor Smith, fire Moses. And the legislators are like, fire Moses. And Smith refuses. First, parks are good vote getters. Second, Smith is all about loyalty. He's loyal to me, I'm loyal to him. And third, nobody works harder for Al Smith than Robert Moses. And Al Smith can see the work
摩西正在做的工作。他能看到那些公园。这是上一集，我谈到了我的口号，显著改善人们的生活，简称为“显改生”。这就是行动中的“显改生”。摩西全神贯注于“显改生”。史密斯认可这种“显改生”。并且可能史密斯并没有意识到摩西一些最糟糕的手腕，
that Moses is doing. He can see those parks. And this is last episode, I talked about my slogan, noticeably improve people's lives, nipple. This is nipple in action. Moses is all about nipple. And Smith recognizes that nipple. And it's possible that Smith is not aware of some of Moses' worst methods,
但他知道摩西是个斗士。他喜欢他是个斗士。不管摩西如何对待其他人，他对阿尔·史密斯总是表现出尊重。他叫他州长，而且他从不称呼其他人为州长。他合作的其他任何州长都不叫。他直呼他们所有人的名字。但正如卡罗所说，对于罗伯特·摩西来说，永远只有一个州长。再说一次，这就是个性。
but he knows Moses is a fighter. He likes that he's a fighter. And no matter how Moses treats everyone else, he always shows respect to Al Smith. He calls him governor, and he refers to nobody else ever as governor. No other governor he works with. He calls them all by his first name. But as Carol says, for Robert Moses, there would always be only one governor. And again, this is personalities.
阿尔·史密斯就是喜欢罗伯特·摩西。他们经常混在一起。他喜欢跟他一起唱歌。就像在任何行业、企业或组织中，当尼喜欢某个人并且觉得“我就是喜欢和这个人待在一起”时，你能对一个人网开一面到什么程度，以及当人们喜欢和你待在一起时你能逃脱惩罚到什么程度，这实在是很难高估的。我这辈子一起唱过歌的老板屈指可数。
Al Smith just likes Robert Moses. They hang out together. He likes singing with him. Like it's hard to overstate in any industry, business or organization, how much you can let someone get away with when you like them and you're like, but I like being around that person and how much you can get away with when people like to be around you. There are so few bosses I have sung with in my life.
我必须得说，你知道，这也是一种亲密感。喜欢和你待在一起。我这辈子一起唱过歌的老板屈指可数。我必须得说，你知道，这也是一种亲密感。我们一起唱歌。呃……呃……呃……现在我们要讲到书中极其诡异的一个章节，也就是罗伯特·摩西与拳击的短暂接触。
I must say, you know, that there's an intimacy too. like to be around you. There are so few bosses I have sung with in my life. I must say, you know, that there's an intimacy too. We sing together. Uh... Uh... Uh... And now we're getting to the most strange section of the book, which is Robert Moses' dalliance with boxing.
我们会在……我们会在中场休息后处理那个。所以我们接下来要讲的章节，也是今天我们要讲的最后一章是第15章，花椰菜馆长，这是一个委婉地说极其晦涩的名字，但当我们讲到那里时我们会解释它。如果你是个拳击迷，如果你是甜蜜科学（拳击的别称）的粉丝，你就不会这么想了。这是一个，但是，到了1928年，好吧。
We're gonna... We're gonna handle that after the break. So the next chapter we're covering and the last chapter we're covering today is chapter 15, The Curator of Cauliflower, which is a cryptic name to say the least, but we will explain it as we get there. Not if you're a boxing fan, not if you're a fan of the sweet science, you know. It's a, but the, by 1928, okay.
摩西1919年州政府重组计划中的一切基本上都已成为法律。州长仍然没有四年任期，这最终在1932年实现了，但他彻底重塑了州政府。他一直是争取其通过的重要力量。最终纽约州州长拥有了真正的行政权力，而史密斯一直在利用这一点来推动劳工改革、福利改革。他使该州更加
Everything in Moses's 1919 state government reorganization plan has basically become law. The governor still doesn't have a four year term, that happens in 1932 eventually, but he has drastically reshaped the government of the state. He's been a big part of fighting to get it passed. And finally the governor of New York has real executive power and Smith has been using that to push through labor reforms, welfare reforms. He's made the state more
积极响应选民的需求。他减了税。他为纽约人民做了很多优秀的工作。是的，他把我们过去大约150个部门精简成了8个部门。这真的很了不起。当人们谈论时，你知道，也许那些并没有真正在思考罗伯特·摩西建造的东西的人，但如果我们把其中一些东西放在一边，所有关于“显改生”的事情，你都可以——如果你能把目光从“显改生”上移开一会儿。是的。
responsive to needs of voters. He's cut taxes. He's done a lot of good work for the people of New York. Yeah and he streamlined what we used to be like 150 departments into eight departments. It's really something. And when people talk about, you know, maybe people who are not really thinking about the things that Robert Moses built, but if we were to sort of put some of that stuff aside, all the nipple things, you could- If you can take your eyes off the nipples for a moment. Yeah.
你可以认为，这一州政府改革的时刻——这在全美各地都有所呼应——也许是罗伯特·摩西一生中最具意义的重大举措之一。是的。他在实体世界中所做的同类工作。他在机构组织的世界里也做了，对于大多数人来说，这听起来可能没那么激动人心，但对我来说确实如此，仅仅是政府的运转、政府的机制现在也按照他认为应该完成的方式塑造了。正如他的公园和道路一样，我们至今仍在使用这种
You could argue that this moment of state governance reform that, which is, which is, you know, like repeated all across the nation is maybe one of the biggest significant acts of Robert Moses life. Yes. The same type of work he's doing in the physical world. He has done in the world of institutional organization, which doesn't sound as exciting maybe to most people, but it does to me, just that the functioning of government, the mechanics of government has now been also molded in the way he thinks it should be done. And just as with his parks and roads, we're still living with that
影响，你知道，或好或坏以不同的方式。我的意思是，大部分这是件好事。我的意思是，这真的是那种我不知道这里面到底有没有真正的坏处的事情之一。坏处是现在阿尔·史密斯这样的人更难进入那个职位了，因为就像我们上次和贾马尔讨论的那样，你需要某种政府的技术知识，也许你在竞选公职之前并不具备，而且国会里有大量不懂装懂的笨蛋，
effect, you know, for better or ill in different ways. I mean, mostly this is for good. I mean, this is really one of those ones where I don't know if there's a real downside to any of this stuff. The downside is now it's harder for an Al Smith to get into that place because like we were talking about with Jamal last time, you need kind of technical knowledge of government that maybe you didn't have before you can get elected to office, uh, and there's, there's plenty of clowns in Congress who don't have,
不具备他们所做事情的知识。但现在要想把事情做好，不再是与地方基层群众接触并做出这些决策的问题了。你需要了解系统。但在大多数情况下，它运作得好得多。我的意思是，在美国，为了办成事情而需要向某人行贿的日子，在很大程度上已经不复存在了。你知道，为了得到一份工作，你不再需要向你的党魁支付一定数量的钱或回扣你的一部分薪水。这些事情作为这次重组的巨大结果，不再是一个问题了，这使得很难说这有什么不好的一面。
don't have the knowledge of what they're doing. But to get things done now, it's no longer a matter of being in touch with people at the local level and to make those decisions. You need to know the systems. But in most ways, it works much better. I mean, the days of you need to pay someone off to get something done in the United States are, for the most part, not around anymore. You know, the idea that to get and to get a job, you no longer need to pay your reward boss a certain amount or kick back part of your salary. Those things as a big as a big result of this organization are not an issue anymore, which is it is hard to say that there's a bad side to that.
是的，但是所有这些随之而来的东西——更好的劳资关系、更好的福利改革——所有这些随之而来的东西，都是在政府在这一层面的专业化相当不错的时候发生的，你知道吗？对的。对的。这很好。而这样的时刻正是这种状态的黄金时刻。
Yeah, but there's a bit all this stuff that comes with this sort of like better labor relations, better welfare reforms, all this sort of like better labor relations, better welfare reforms, all this sort of stuff happens when the professionalization of the government at this sort of level was quite good, you know? Right. Right. This is good. And it's this kind of moment is the kind of the golden moment of this.
有足够的专业化来消除马虎和街头那种基层的腐败。但仍然带有一点点政务任免权、一点点专项拨款、一点点政治交易的理念，这样你就能吞下一颗你未必完全同意的药丸，如果它能，你知道，主要能让你的生活更好或者让你们选区的人的生活更好。你知道，主要能让你的生活更好或者让你们选区的人的生活更好。我认为这种推拉就像是政府可能在它，
Like there's enough professionalization to knock out the sloppiness and the sort of basic level corruption on the street. But there's still kind of that idea of a little bit of patronage, a little bit of earmarks, a little bit of horse trading so that you can sort of swallow a pill of something that you don't necessarily agree with if it's going to just, you know, mostly like make your life better or maybe the people in your district better. know, mostly like make your life better or maybe the people in your district better. I think that push and pull is like when government is probably acting at it, at
在它……呃，最有力的时候，你知道，就是把所有这些东西都占一点。是的。当有一个被几乎是政治民间文化所调和的系统，并且有被现实实用主义所调和的意识形态时。就像是，是的，那才是甜蜜点。阿尔·史密斯正坐在那个甜蜜点上。而重组带来的变化之一是，国务卿现在是一个任命职位，而不是选举职位。阿尔·史密斯要任命谁来担任这个职务？
its, um, uh, most powerful, you know, is to have a little bit of all this stuff. Yeah. When, when there's, there's a system that's tempered by a kind of almost folk culture of politics and there's ideologies that are tempered by realistic practicalities. Like that's, yeah, that's that sweet spot. Al Smith is sitting right in that sweet spot. And one of the changes that reorganization is that Secretary of State is now in an appointed position, not an elected position. Who is Al Smith going to appoint into that job?
别无选择。只能是那个为他战斗最努力、付出最多的人，罗伯特·摩西。而他现在监督的州务部门，处理所有不属于其他部门的事情。如果你要提交公司注册文件，你得向州务部门提交。如果你在汇总选举结果，那是州务部门。如果你是一名拍卖师，你需要一个执照，
There's no other option. It's got to be the guy who fights the hardest for him and does the most, Robert Moses. And the Department of State that he now oversees, it handles everything that kind of doesn't fit into other departments. If you're filing incorporation papers, you gotta file with the Department of State. If you're compiling the results of an election, it's the Department of State. If you're an auctioneer and you need a license
或者你是一名私家侦探，你需要一个执照，那是州务部门。而且，对于本章及其标题而言非常重要，但同时也有些随机，因为国务卿显然是纽约州最随机的职位。国务卿还控制着纽约的运动委员会（Athletic Commission），该委员会负责监督该州的拳击运动，这意味着国务卿控制着大量的政务任免权。有所有那些想要私家侦探执照的人，他们将不得不，你知道，他们获得这些
or you're a private detective and you need a license, it's the Department of State. And also, very importantly for this chapter and the title thereof, but also kind of random because Secretary of State is apparently the most random job in New York State. The Secretary of State also had control over New York's Athletic Commission which oversaw boxing in the state and this means the Secretary of State controls a lot of patronage. There's all those people who want private detective licenses and they're gonna have to you know they get those
工作来获得执照，而史密斯希望这个人能够协调全州所有的建设，同时也协调全州的内阁。所以这是一个权力极大的职位。而奥尔巴尼并不希望罗伯特·摩西拥有这种权力。他们恨他，但史密斯太受欢迎了。报纸急于将这描述为大老板与公园狂人之间的较量，以至于他们无法真正投票反对摩西的任命。现在，这带来的巨大影响，即刻的直接后果，摩西终于有了一份能维持不错生计的工作。他终于年薪1万2千美元了，他的母亲说：“终于，终于，他要开始谋生了。”这就像是他母亲几十年的所有努力
jobs to license them and Smith wants this to be the person who coordinates all of the state's construction and also coordinates the state's cabinet. So it's a hugely powerful position. And Albany does not want Robert Moses to have that power. They hate him, but Smith is too popular. The newspapers are too eager to present this as the fat cats versus the Parks man for them to actually vote against Moses' appointment. And now the big repercussion of this, the big immediate consequence, Moses finally has a job that pays a decent living. He's finally making $12,000 a year and his mom is like, at last, at last, he's going to start earning a living. Like this is all of his mother's work for decades
终于迎来了这个时刻，她根本不在乎他是否有权力。他终于可以养活自己和妻子了，这，这，在报纸上读到关于你儿子在全州各地建造这些建筑的报道，一定感觉很奇妙。然后他说：“妈妈，你能帮我付房租吗？”而她就像是：“好吧，我想我会这么做的。”而摩西在媒体面前表现得像个斗士。他将成为一位发起十字军东征的国务卿。他亲自去剥夺那些无良企业经营者和侦探的执照，但他做得过头了。他试图监管拳击比赛中涉及的腐败门票销售。他真的不了解拳击行业。
has finally led to this moment that she doesn't care that he's powerful. He can finally support himself and his wife, which is, which is, it must be amazing to be reading the newspapers about your son who is building these structures all over the state. And then he's like, mom, can you help me pay the rent? And she's like, yeah, I guess I'll do that. And Moses presents himself to the press. He's going to be the crusading secretary. He goes personally to strip the licenses from unscrupulous business operators and detectives, but he goes too far. He tries to regulate the corrupt ticket sales involved in boxing matches. He really doesn't understand the boxing industry.
他曾一度表示，如果拳击比赛的裁判无法做出决定，他将亲自介入并做出决定，这绝对是一件疯狂的事情。而且，国务卿，你——它将上交给国务卿。就像我们会打电话给国务卿看看谁赢了。你们俩谁更喜欢海滩？好吧，你赢了。而他作为“花椰菜馆长”的统治，
At one point he says that if the judges at a boxing match can't decide, he will step in and make the decision, which is a bonkers thing to do. And, uh, secretary of state, you- It'll go on to the secretary of state. It'll like we call it the secretary of state and see who wins. Which of you men enjoy the beach more? All right, you're the winner. And his reign as the curator of cauliflowers,
正如媒体所称的那样，很快就结束了。它是，它是异乎寻常地短暂。我希望当我们说，当我们说他要涉足拳击界时，我知道每个人都以为他要走进拳击台，但并没有，这就是它的全部极限，它的，它的，它的，它的，它的，它的，它的，它的，它的，它的，普通老百姓可以买到票。结果发现售票处应付不了所有买票的人。所以这些拳击比赛只有三分之一满，因为人们还在外面试图挤进去。然后他意识到，我想这是生平第一次，也许也是这本书中唯一的一次，他实在是
as the press calls him, is quickly over. It's, it's promersively brief. I wish that when we said, when we said he was getting into boxing, I know everyone thought that he was gonna get in the ring, but no, that's the extent of it it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, average Joe can buy tickets. And it turns out that the ticket box office can't handle all the people buying tickets. And so like these boxing matches are like one third full because people are standing outside still trying to get in. And then he realizes for the first time, I think, and maybe the only time in this book that he's just in over his
力不从心，他就像是：我不想处理这个。而且他可能只是不够在乎。就像是：你知道吗？他做了一番权衡。他觉得：人们关心公园。那是权力的源泉。人们并不太在乎拳击行业是否卑劣。我想他们多少接受了这一点。
head and he just like, I don't want to deal with this. And he probably just doesn't care enough. Like he's like, you know what? He does the calculus. He's like, people care about parks. That's a source of power. People don't really care that much about whether the boxing industry is slimy or not. I think they kind of accept.
而且在某种程度上，你不得不认为他会想：如果我继续推动这个，他们可能会揍我。我正在和那些以痛殴其他男人为生的人打交道。所以对于我们较年轻的听众，我的意思是80岁以下的听众，“花椰菜”在拳击界是什么意思？所以我应该对此做点研究。自从我读到它以来，我的假设一直是他们在谈论“花椰菜耳朵”。就像拳击手一样，他们的耳朵会变得畸形。这只是20世纪的时代标志，他们会说，嗯，
And at a certain point, you have to think he's like, they could punch me if I keep pushing this. I'm dealing with people who punch other men for a living. And so for our younger listeners, and I mean listeners under the age of 80, what does cauliflower mean when it comes to boxing? So I should have done research on this. My assumption always since I read it is that they're talking about cauliflower ears. Like boxers, they get their ears would become deformed. And it's just the, it's a sign of the times in the 20s that they would they're like, hmm
你们的耳朵因为作为工作的一部分在脸部挨打而变得畸形了。让我们给它起个可爱的名字，叫它“花椰菜耳”。这差不多就是它的样子。它就像一小朵花椰菜。是的，确实如此。他们从来没有说过“花椰菜馆长应该阻止人们因为拳击而毁掉耳朵”。我们只是给它起了一个基于此的绰号，你知道，他们只是多少理解了这一点。所以这就是为什么它不是真正的字面上的花椰菜。他不是在经营蔬菜博物馆并管理花椰菜部门。
Your ears are becoming malformed from being hit in the face as part of your job. Let's give it a cute name Let's call it a cauliflower ear. That's kind of what it looks like It's like a little cauliflower Yeah, it does At no point are they like the curator of cauliflowers should stop people from having their ears ruined from boxing We'll just give them a nickname that's based on it, you know, they just kind of understood it So that's why it was not actual literal cauliflowers. He was not running a museum of vegetables and curating the cauliflower department.
但这就是，又是一个这样的时刻，罗伯特·卡罗是在70年代写这本书的。他并不觉得有必要去定义它，对吧？我不认为他刻意去做了。不，这是那种，再次觉得，这对于50年后的我们来说就像是一个不合逻辑的结论。但这在1974年是一个完全合乎逻辑的结论。所以这个当花椰菜馆长的统治，很快就结束了，但他作为国务卿还在做一堆其他事情。
But that's, that's one of those times, again, Robert Carow's writing this in the 70s. He doesn't feel the need, I think, to define it, does he? I don't think he goes out of his way. No, it's one of those ones where it's like, again, it's like, it feels like a non sequitur to us 50 years later. It is a complete sequitur in 1974. So this reign of, of being the curator of Cauliflower's is, is, is sort of quickly over, but he's still doing a bunch of other stuff as secretary of state.
是的。他负责加快新监狱和精神病院的建设。呃，有时他要做公园建设工作，州长会字面意义上派州警把他抓来，强行带到最近的电话旁，好让州长能指派他做更多的事情。而且他此时基本上是在为阿尔·史密斯共同管理政府。他没有时间过个人生活。
Yes. He is in charge of making the construction of new prisons and mental hospitals goes faster. Uh, the, and at times he's going to do park building work and the governor will literally send state troopers to get him and force him to go to the nearest telephone so that the governor can make him do more things. And he is essentially co-running the government at this point for Al Smith. And he has no time for personal life.
正是在这个时候，卡罗说，摩西除了晚上游泳外不进行任何体育运动。他没有业余爱好。他没有社交活动。他不能出去买自己的衣服。他的妻子不得不代劳。他不能去理发店。理发师必须来他的公寓给他理发。而且他一直都在加长轿车的后座上工作一点。现在他简直是把汽车后座变成了一个办公室。
It's at this point, Carol says, Moses, he doesn't do sports except for swimming at night. He has no hobbies. He has no socializing. He can't go out to buy his own clothes. His wife has to do that. He can't go to the barber. The barbers have to come to his apartment to cut his hair. And he's always done a little bit of work in the back of his limousine. Now he is literally turning the back of his car into an office.
它有额外的座位。他的秘书黑兹尔·塔彭（Hazel Tappen）和他同乘一辆车，在车里做速记。他在车里开会，还有另一辆有专职司机的车一直跟着他的车，以便当他吩咐完秘书该做什么时，她可以下车，坐上那辆车，带着那些新的命令立刻被开车送回办公室。两辆车都配备了三名司机，实行八小时轮班制。所以他们拥有24小时的驾驶覆盖。他一直在工作，也一直在路上。
It has extra seats. He has his secretary, Hazel Tappen, riding with him, taking dictation in the car. He holds meetings in the car and there's another chauffeured car that's always following his car so that when he's done telling the secretary what to do, she can get out, get in that car and be driven immediately back to the office with those new orders. And both cars are staffed with three drivers each working in eight hour shifts. So they have 24 hour driving coverage. He is always working and he's always on the move.
他把办公室的电话换成了一条直通秘书的单线。电话上没有按钮。他无法用它呼出。它只能呼入，而且只有在秘书允许某人通过时才行。如果你不是史密斯州长，如果你打电话，你就要一直等到他准备好接听。他不会为了接电话而打断手头的事情。史密斯之后的每一位州长和纽约市的每一位市长都得等待。摩西不会放下任何事情，纽约市必须等待。
He replaces his office phone with a single line that just goes to his secretary. The phone has no buttons on it. He cannot call out from it. It can only come in and only when a secretary lets someone through. And if you are not governor Smith, if you call, you're going to wait until he's ready for you. He will not just interrupt things to pick up the phone. Every governor after Smith and every mayor of New York has to wait. Moses will not drop anything New York has to wait.
摩西不会放下任何事情。他们必须等摩西来接听他们的电话。他在办公桌上安装了一个蜂鸣器系统，连接到他每一位行政人员的办公室，这样他就可以立刻分别呼叫他们。只要他一按按钮，他们就知道必须放下手头正在做的一切，立刻马上去他的办公室。
Moses will not drop anything. They have to wait for Moses to take their call. He installs this buzzer system in his desk that connects to each of his executive's offices so he can call them individually right away. And as soon as he pushes the button, they know they have to drop whatever they're doing and go right to his office right away.
就像是，这太……这是20世纪20年代的事，但感觉就像是1950年代老板办公室的讽刺版，你知道吗，那里就像有这样一条特殊的专线。我的意思是，通常只有戈登局长才有那种特殊的电话，对吧？就像那是总统通往俄罗斯的热线，也是戈登局长通往蝙蝠侠的热线。他拒绝使用办公桌。他只有一个桌子，因为他不想让工作被塞进抽屉里然后被遗忘。
Like he is, it is such a, it's the 20s, but it feels like it is the parody of like a 1950s boss office, you know, where it's just like this special phone line. I mean, only Commissioner Gordon really has a special phone like that usually, right? Like it's the president's hotline to Russia and it's Commissioner Gordon's hotline to Batman. He refuses to have a desk. He just has a table because he doesn't want work shoved into drawers and forgotten about.
就像他，这真的是，这是20世纪20年代，但感觉就像是1950年代办公室老板的滑稽模仿，你知道吧，那里就只有这样一条专线电话。我的意思是，通常只有戈登局长才会有那种特别的电话，对吧？就像那是总统通往俄罗斯的热线，也是戈登局长通往蝙蝠侠的热线。他拒绝使用办公桌。他只有一个桌子，因为他不想让工作被塞进抽屉里然后被人遗忘。
He wants that table cleared off of work at the end of every day. And he's just constantly working and just reading this part stresses me out so badly. I don't know if you had the same feeling. Except he has his daily swimming routine, which David, I know you have the same thing. I do. Well, I swim laps in a gym pool. I don't like what I feel like what he does is he like drives to the beach and just runs into it every morning. Like the crack of dawn, I have to assume. Like it's kind of amazing. It says he changes in his car, right?
他希望每天结束时那张桌子上一尘不染、没有公文。他一直在工作，读到这里让我感到压力巨大。我不知道你有没有这种感觉。除了他每天的游泳习惯——大卫，我知道你也有这个习惯。我有。好吧，我在健身房泳池里游来游去。我觉得他的做法是，每天清晨开车去海滩，然后直接冲进海里。我想象那大概是在破晓时分。感觉这简直太酷了。书上说他在车里换衣服，对吧？
And then he just like jumps out of his car. Yeah. I remember that. So tell me as a sort of an equally powerful man, you know, dedicated to swimming every day, what do you think if you could put us in the mind of Robert Moses, what is the swimming doing for him? Well, if you are unable to listen to podcasts,
然后他就从车里跳了出来。对。我记得。所以，作为一个同样拥有强大力量、并且每天坚持游泳的人，你能否带我们走进罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）的内心，猜猜游泳对他来说有什么作用？好吧，如果你无法收听播客，
I currently listen to podcasts while I swim. I don't think Robert Moses had that technology available to him. So you do, like you zone out, my joke is that you think of death, but like in a fun way, right? You just sort of start meditating on the universe as you're kind of just like back and forth, back and forth, counting the laps. I find swimming to be incredibly pleasant, but I don't swim in the ocean, which is very cold and has powerful waves and currents, uh, every morning. Maybe I should,
我现在是一边游泳一边听播客的。我觉得罗伯特·摩西当时可没有这种科技可用。所以你会放空，我的笑话是，你会去想死亡，但却是一种很有趣的方式，对吧？当你一边来来回回、来来回回地游，一边数着圈数时，你就会开始对宇宙进行某种冥想。我觉得游泳极其美妙，但我可不会每天早晨去大西洋里游泳——那海水冰冷刺骨，还有汹涌的巨浪和暗流。也许我应该去，
maybe I should do that. Yeah. And he swims at night too. It talks about how sometimes on the way home, he'll tell the driver to take him to Jones beach so he can run into the water and just swim out into the darkness. He's, he loves swimming. He's more fish than man at times. Now he's like Namor. Right. Aren't there stories where people are like, is he dead? And then he finally like returns like he's gone in the ocean for so long that they're like, should we call the god of Coast Guard? Like, where is Robert? These are the parts that are like mythic and the swimming is not enough to stop the strain. He's starting for the first time to really show the strain of all this work.
也许我真该这么做。对。而且他晚上也游。书中提到，有时候在回家的路上，他会叫司机载他去琼斯海滩（Jones Beach），这样他就可以冲进水中，一直游向黑暗的深处。他是如此热爱游泳。有时他看起来更像是一条鱼而不是人。现在他就像纳摩（Namor）一样。对吧？是不是有些传言说人们会问：他死了吗？然后他终于像这样游了回来——他在海里消失了那么久，以至于大家都在想：我们要不要报警叫海岸警卫队？罗伯特去哪儿了？这些部分读起来就像神话一样，而游泳并不足以缓解这种精神压力。他第一次开始真正显露出所有这些工作给他带来的巨大压力。
And there's a section here just about his temper that's starting up here. It says, the fuse always short that ignited his temper had been chopped down to a nub. The broad smile with which he greeted underlings could disappear in an instant if the reports displeased him. The hard mask that replaced it would turn pale, almost white, as his rage mounted. And then a wave of deep red, almost purple, would seep up out of his collar and over his face. The palm of his big right hand would begin to smack down on the table as he talked. And his secretaries, listening outside the closed door to his office, trying to smile at each other, would hear his voice begin to rise.
这里有一段专门描写他的暴脾气的文字，从这里开始。书中写道：“点燃他怒火的引信总是被烧得只剩短短一截。当手下向他汇报工作时，他脸上原本挂着的灿烂笑容会瞬间消失。如果汇报内容让他不满意，取而代之的将是一副冷酷的面具，他的脸色会变得苍白，几乎呈白色，随着怒气上升，紧接着，一股深红色、几近紫色的怒潮会从他的衣领泛起，蔓延至整张脸。他那只大右手的手掌会在说话时开始重重地拍打桌面。而他的秘书们则在办公室紧闭的门外偷听，试图互相苦笑着，听着他的声音开始高亢起来。”
Lunging out of his chair, he would stride around the room, bellowing, his eyes wild, and sometimes as he walked, he pounded his clenched fist into the walls so hard the skin was ripped from his knuckles. Oblivious to the pain, he would sit back down at his desk and grab the next batch of papers with bleeding hands." And it's like, this is written, the stuff with the colors and everything, I'm like, I bet Robert Caro saw some of this while he was interviewing him.
“他从椅子上猛地弹起，在房间里大步流星地走来走去，放声咆哮，双眼圆睁。有时在走动时，他会把紧握的拳头猛砸向墙壁，以至于关节上的皮肤都被撕裂了。对疼痛浑然不觉的他会重新坐回办公桌前，带着流血的双手抓过下一批文件。”这段文字的描写，包括那些颜色变化的细节等等，让我觉得，罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）在采访他时肯定亲眼目睹过其中的一些情景。
I bet he saw him get mad and saw this, because it's so specific and so detailed, but it really makes me, it's like, if you're in a room with that guy, it's frightening. I'm sure you'll do whatever he says, to get out of that room. And the people who work under him, they talk about like, because of this intercom system,
我敢说他一定见过他发火的样子，也见过这种面部变化，因为这实在是太具体、太细致了。但这真的让我觉得，如果你和那种人在同一个房间里，那绝对是令人毛骨悚然的。我敢肯定，为了能离开那个房间，他让你做什么你都会照做。而那些在他手下工作的人，他们谈论到，因为这个对讲系统，
they eat at their desks and they'll put anything away to go deal with him. It's not that he's calling on them all the time. He just has so complete control over them that they can't do anything else because they're waiting for him to call on them. You know, like there's no leaving, there's no that. There's like, if someone's having a barbecue,
他们甚至在办公桌上吃饭，只要听到传唤，他们会放下手头的一切去处理他的事情。并不是说他无时无刻不在召唤他们。而是他对他们有着绝对的掌控，以至于他们什么也做不了，只能时刻等待着他的召唤。你知道的，根本没有离开的可能，也没有别的选择。比如，如果有人正在办烧烤派对，
it's like, when can you be there? I'll be there in 45 minutes and he's there in 40. You know, like that is just, they're always on call. And I can't imagine the stress of that. It's incredibly stressful. And some of the Moses men, as they're called, they start being called Moses men and they call him RM. They start to crack under the strain.
就会变成：“你什么时候能到？”“我45分钟后到。”结果他40分钟就到了。你知道的，他们就是处于随时待命的状态。我简直无法想象那种压力有多大。那压力太惊人了。其中一些被称为“摩西门徒”（Moses men）的手下——人们开始这样称呼他们，而他们则称呼摩西为“RM”——开始在巨大的压力下崩溃。
Caro talks about more than one becomes an alcoholic, some that have nervous breakdowns, some that have marital problems. There's at least one suicide, although Caro does not mention that person by name. In the notes in the back, he says that he's kept that man's identity private out of sensitivity to the man's mother, which is also a very kind of old-fashioned way to do something in a book. But for all the people who are inspired by Moses and are being pushed to their best work and being molded by him and to men they want to be, there are workers for him who are cracking under this strain because it is, like you're saying, so overwhelming.
卡罗提到，不止一个人成了酗酒者，有人精神崩溃，还有人婚姻出现问题。至少有一人自杀身亡，不过卡罗没有提及那个人的名字。在后记的注释中，他说出于对死者母亲的体谅，他将那个人的身份保密了，这也是一种在书中处理此类事情的非常老派的方式。但是，对于所有那些受到摩西启发、被逼出最佳工作状态、被他塑造并朝着自己理想中的男性方向成长的人来说，他的手下中也确实有人在这样的高压下崩溃了，因为正如你所说，这实在是太令人难以承受了。
And exactly, not because they are on call all the time. So even when they're not being talked to by him, they know that at any moment he might need them and they're going to be expected to drop everything and go right towards them. But at the same time, there are some perks to working in the Moses man. Yes. Yes. Yes. Cause you have all this land and you have all these people who can build things. And so he's just starts building houses for them. Yeah. He'll use parks department resources to build houses for them on park land. The parks come, the department pays for the utilities for the houses. If he feels like someone is not making enough money, but the civil service regulations mean he can't give them a raise, he'll put their wives on the payroll so that they have a little bit of extra cash.
没错，不仅因为他们随时待命。所以即使摩西没有跟他们说话，他们也知道他随时可能需要他们，并且他们会被要求放下一切立刻赶过去。但与此同时，当“摩西门徒”也有一些福利。没错，没错，没错。因为你拥有所有这些土地，还有所有这些可以搞建设的人。所以他就会开始为他们建房子。对。他会利用公园部门的资源在公园土地上为他们建房子。公园部门甚至为这些房子支付水电费。如果他觉得某个员工的工资不够高，但公务员法规又限制他不能直接给对方加薪，他就会把员工的妻子也列入工资名单，好让他们能多拿一点额外现金。
It's a real carrot and stick thing. He's really taking care of them in some ways and brutalizing them in others. And he also really trusts his people. Like he, he, when he finds people that he can delegate to, he will let them do the job and that's why he's able to get so much done so quickly because there's whole parts of his like empire building that he can't possibly be present for every moment of it, but they handle it for him. Yes.
这完全是胡萝卜加大棒的手段。他在某些方面确实很照顾他们，而在另一些方面则像暴君一样折磨他们。而且他也确实非常信任自己的人。比如，当他找到可以授权的人时，他就会放手让他们去干工作，这就是为什么他能以如此快的速度取得如此巨大的成就，因为他的“帝国建设”中有整块整块的业务是他不可能每时每刻都亲临现场的，但手下会为他处理得井井有条。没错。
He has a real eye for talent and he's good at picking people and saying, you can do this. Now you do it. And then leaving it up to them. I mean, it's how like Henry Stern, who ran the parks department for years was one of like his sort of little protege's and he ran things that way too. And like you would hear that about Bloomberg when I, who I covered as the mayor for a long
他确实有一双慧眼，很擅长挑选手说：“这事你能行。现在交给你了。”然后就完全放手不管。我的意思是，比如亨利·斯特恩（Henry Stern）——他管理公园部门多年，曾是摩西的哼哈二将和门生之一——他也是用这种方式来管理事务的。你会听到关于布隆伯格（Bloomberg）的传闻，我曾作为记者长期报道过他的市长生涯，
time of like, if he delegated to you, you got to do whatever you want. You know, like he would, he would sort of invest incredible and which, which could be good or bad, obviously, depending on how you felt about the power being delegated, which is probably true here too. But I think it's classic municipal stuff, right? Yeah, you can't pull every lever yourself. Yes. And at this point, Moses has become the second most powerful person in the government and there's newspaper articles about it. He can do whatever he wants basically, and Smith has his back. And Robert Caro takes a moment to quote two speeches that Moses gave in 1927 to associations
如果你获得了他的授权，你就可以随心所欲地做任何你想做的事。你知道的，他会给予你极大的信任，这当然可能带来好坏参半的结果，取决于你如何看待这种权力的下放，这种情况在这里大概也是如此。不过我认为这很符合经典的市政运作套路，对吧？是的，你不可能凡事都亲力亲为。没错。而此时，摩西已经成为了政府中第二权势滔天的人物，报纸上到处都是关于他的报道。他基本上可以为所欲为，而且史密斯（Smith）是他的坚强后盾。罗伯特·卡罗花了一些篇幅引用了摩西在1927年对长岛房地产经纪人协会发表的两场演讲，
of Long Island real estate brokers, where he seems to very kind of blatantly lay out his, his feelings about things. And he says, the future of Long Island is as a recreational community for New Yorkers. You can't go any farther East around here because you hit the ocean. You can only go West to the city. So that's, that's where you have to look to for your future That's gonna require a lot of zoning and development your local government's they're not equipped to handle it So we're gonna do it for you. And if you're opposed to what we're gonna do
在演讲中，他似乎非常直言不讳地阐述了自己对一些事情的看法。他说：“长岛的未来是成为纽约人的休闲社区。你们在这里不能再往东走了，因为前面就是大洋。你们只能向西去往城市。所以，这就是你们未来必须寄予厚望的地方。”“这需要大量的分区规划和开发，你们的地方政府根本没有能力处理这件事。所以我们要代劳。如果你反对我们的所作所为，
we're gonna defeat you because your opposition is stupid because This all the things we're doing mean a lot of money going into your places And if you don't like it, the money will go somewhere else. It doesn't have to go to Long Island. And so if you're opposing me, you're opposing money coming to you. And if some people get hurt along the way, he can't make an omelet without breaking eggs and he says, he's like, people who don't like the things we're doing, they can always go West.
我们就会击败你，因为你们的反对是愚蠢的，因为我们正在做的所有这些事情意味着大把的钞票会流入你们的地区。如果你不喜欢，钱就会流向别的地方。它不一定非得去长岛。所以，如果你在反对我，你就是在反对流向你们的财富。如果在这个过程中有人受到了伤害，不做煎蛋饼就打不破鸡蛋。”他还说，那些不喜欢他们所做事情的人，随时可以去西部。
They can move to the Rockies if they want to, which is such a, such a mean, but also funny way to look at things. Like you don't like this new park, this new parkway in Long Island, go to the Rocky Mountains. No one's developing that area. And in this second speech, he talks about how sometimes to do the right thing, you have to do other things that might technically overstep the law. And he's becoming more and more comfortable with that and not only comfortable with doing
如果他们想的话，可以搬到落基山脉去。这种看问题的方式既刻薄又搞笑。就像如果你不喜欢这个新公园、不喜欢长岛这条新公园大道，那就去落基山脉吧。根本没有人去开发那个地区。在第二场演讲中，他谈到有时为了做正确的事，你不得不去做一些在技术上可能越过法律边界的事。他对此变得越来越习以为常，不仅对这样做感到心安理得，
it, but comfortable with pushing back aggressively against anyone who tries to stop him. And Carol quotes Frances Perkins, who we remember has known Moses for years now. They were young reformers together. She's working in the state government and she says, she calls him and says, Moses, you're using non-union labor to build these bath houses on Long Island. By law, you're only supposed to use union labor. You're being naughty. I think she uses the word naughty in it. And, and she's acting as a public official. She's calling him on breaking the law as part of her job. And he instantly becomes abusive and is like, I'm going to build these bath houses and no one's going to stop me. These are for the people. And she says,
而且对于积极反击任何试图阻止他的人也习以为常。卡罗引用了弗朗西丝·珀金斯（Frances Perkins）的话——我们还记得她认识摩西已经很多年了。他们曾是一起奋斗的年轻改革派。当时她在州政府工作，她打电话给摩西说：“摩西，你在长岛建这些澡堂时使用的是非工会劳动力。按照法律，你只能使用工会劳动力。你太淘气了。”我想她在话里用了“淘气”这个词。她当时是以公职人员的身份行事，职责所在，她打电话指责他违法。而摩西立刻开始恶语相加，说道：“我就要建这些澡堂，没人能阻止我。这是为了老百姓。”而她则说：
we had known each other for years informally. And he's talking to me this way. And by the time he is eventually rebuked by a court for using non-union labor, again, as we said, it doesn't matter. The bathhouses are being used. You can tear them down. People are already in there changing, you know, that would, you just, people would see them changing if you tore those bathhouses down while they're still inside. And he's becoming more, he's becoming kind of like a bully.
“我们以前一直是老熟人，私下里无话不谈，而他现在却这样跟我说话。”等到他最终因为使用非工会劳动力而遭到法院谴责时，正如我们所说，这已经无关紧要了。澡堂已经投入使用了。你总不能把它拆了吧？人们已经在里面换衣服了，你知道的，如果你在他们还在里面的时候把澡堂拆了，大家就会看到他们换衣服的窘态。他变得越来越像一个恶霸了。
When he drives around Long Island, his car is speeding over the speed limit. He has motorcycle troopers around his car that push other cars off the road so that he can get where he's going and he's now using his power to make life easier for him because in his mind, it all counts towards this end goal of getting this stuff done. But there are times when one power meets a greater power.
当他开车在长岛行驶时，他的车总是严重超速。他的车周围有骑摩托车的交警开道，把其他车辆逼出路面，以便他能准时到达目的地。他现在利用自己的权力来让自己的生活更轻松，因为在他心中，这一切都是为了完成这些目标的最终目的。但有时候，一种权力会遇到更大的权力。
Oh yeah. When an unmovable force. You know, it's a positive right. Exactly. When an unstoppable force builder meets an unmovable force, you know, it's an impossible right. Exactly, when an unstoppable force builder meets an immovable land's baron. Yeah, and in this case, like, he does something that we don't see a lot, is that he compromises because of his,
哦，是的。当一个不可动摇的力量……你知道，这是一种正面的权利。没错。当一个不可阻挡的力量建设者遇到一个不可动摇的力量时，你知道，这简直不可能发生，对吧？没错，当一个势不可挡的力量建设者遇到一个不可动摇的土地大亨时。是的，在这种情况下，他做了一件我们不常见到的事——他妥协了，原因在于
probably his familial association with Otto Kahn. Yes, he's had to make deals with Long Island barons about the roots of his parkways. Usually it's like, hey, instead of running a road right next to my house, can you put it like on the edge of my estate? And he's like, that's fine. Can you make sure there's not an exit
他与奥托·卡恩（Otto Kahn）的家族姻亲关系。是的，他不得不就其公园大道的路线与长岛的大亨们达成协议。通常情况下，情况是这样的：“嘿，与其把公路修在我家房子旁边，你能不能把它修在我的庄园边缘？”而他的回答是：“可以啊。”“你能确保路上不要在我房产附近设置出口吗？”
on the road near my property? Yeah, we could do that. But there's one instance particularly, Otto Kahn, who is married to one of Moses's cousins. And Otto Kahn is one of these people who I know of as a rich person, but again, I don't know what they, what his money came from. What is it David? Is it zinc? Is it what? Let's find out how did Otto Kahn get his money. Let's see. He was known as the King of New York, pretty good title to get, I would say. It's that old classic banking. The man had banks. I think he did a lot of railroad stuff with his money, it seems. He was the ablest reorganizer of railroads.
“行，我们可以做到。”但有一个特殊的例子，那就是奥托·卡恩，他娶了摩西的一个表亲。奥托·卡恩是那种我知道他是个富豪、但我又不知道他的钱是从哪儿来的人。大卫，这是怎么回事？是锌矿吗？到底是什么？让我们查查奥托·卡恩的钱是怎么来的。我们来看看。他被称为“纽约之王”，我觉得这是一个相当不错的头衔。这就是老派的银行业。这个人拥有银行。我想他的财富中很大一部分似乎来自铁路业务。他是铁路重组方面最能干的人。
What does that mean? I guess, oh, I guess he would like, he would take over failing railroads and he would, he was the Mitt Romney of his day, right? Totally, totally. Except he would probably just be like, crush these workers! I mean, I don't mean to impugn him. I don't know if he said to crush workers. Probably.
这是什么意思？我想，哦，我想他会接管那些陷入困境的铁路，他就是那个时代的米特·罗姆尼（Mitt Romney），对吧？完全是，完全是。只不过他可能会说：“把这些工人都给我压榨干净！”我的意思是，我无意诋毁他。我不知道他是否说过要压榨工人。很可能说过。
Assuming, yes. I assume he did. But he was also a patron of the Metropolitan Opera. So, you know, let's give him that. It's the same way that, is it David Koch, who's like, I'm evil, but I love the ballet, so I will keep the new ballet running. Yes.
假设如此，是的。我猜他是说过。但他也是大都会歌剧院（Metropolitan Opera）的赞助人，所以，你知道的，我们得承认这一点。这就好比大卫·科赫（David Koch）那样的人，他会说：“我很邪恶，但我热爱芭蕾舞，所以我愿意出资维持新芭蕾舞团的运转。”是的。
He does love the dang ballet, and as a devoted viewer of The Gilded Age, yes, now have learned that the Metropolitan Opera was basically a Netflix-style deficit spending scheme founded by new money, because they didn't like their box seats at the old opera the Academy Which was wonderful to learn I'm looking at this picture of Otto Kahn on on Wikipedia and he looks like a child with a fake mustache on he has
他是真的很爱该死的芭蕾舞。作为《镀金时代》（The Gilded Age）的忠实观众，是的，我最近了解到大都会歌剧院基本上是一个由暴发户建立的、奈飞（Netflix）风格的赤字开支项目，因为他们不喜欢旧歌剧院“学院”（The Academy）的包厢座位。了解这些真是太棒了。我正在看维基百科上奥托·卡恩的照片，他看起来就像一个粘着假胡子的孩子。他留着我见过最
Triangular mustache I have ever seen It's a real whisk broom of a mustache. It's like curling up on the sides, but he looks like he has a real richy rich kind of vibe. And then this big black mustache on his face. I always look at these guys and I think like, God, they had so much money, they controlled so much land. They didn't have like air conditioning though. How good was life for an auto con?
三角形状的胡子。那真是一撮扫帚般的胡子。两端向上翘起，但他整个人散发着一种超级暴发户的气质。脸上还留着这么大一撮黑胡子。我每次看到这些家伙都会想：天哪，他们有那么多钱，控制了那么多土地。不过他们当时可没有空调。奥托·卡恩的生活能有多舒适？
I totally agree. They didn't have air conditioning and they didn't have like- They didn't have like Tylenol. Exactly. No painkillers. And it's like when you read about rich people hundreds of years ago
我完全同意。他们没有空调，也没有像——他们甚至没有泰诺（Tylenol）。没错。没有止痛药。这就好像当你读到几百年前的富豪时，
and they're still complaining about bed bugs and it's like, yeah, I guess you knew you were gonna eat. That was the basic benefit of being rich. Right. To be clear, there were benefits. It was good. When somebody asked like Gore Vidal, like this sort of noted historian
他们仍然在抱怨臭虫咬人，这就好像是，好吧，我想你至少知道自己有饭吃。这就是有钱的基本好处。没错。澄清一下，好处还是有的，生活挺不错。当有人问戈尔·维达尔（Gore Vidal）——这位著名的历史学家和历史小说作家——如果让你选择生活在自己写过的哪一个历史时期，你会选哪个？他说：“现在。”
and writer of history books, what is the time that you've written about that you would want to live in? And he's like, now. I'll tell you one word. Count me out. Anesthetic, anesthetic is like, that's enough of a reason to live now
我只想对你说一个词：算我一个。麻醉剂，麻醉剂就是让你选择生活在现在、而不是历史上面任何其他时期的充分理由。他说：“这就是足以让我选择生活在现在、而不是历史上任何其他时期的理由。”是的。所以奥托·卡恩，你知道的，他最终拥有一个高尔夫球场，我猜是这样吧？他是个高尔夫球场大亨？是的，他在长岛拥有一个高尔夫球场，而北方州际公园大道（Northern State Parkway）正好要穿过它。
and not any other time in history. He's like, that's enough of a reason to live now and not any other time in history. Yeah. So Otto Kahn, you know, finally, he has this golf course, I guess, right? He's the golf course guy? Yes, he has a golf course in Long Island and the Northern State Parkway is gonna go through it.
他对摩西说：“如果你不穿过我的高尔夫球场，我给你1万美元资助土地测绘。”摩西回答：“没问题，我干。”这意味着要把路线往南稍微挪一点，而这会穿过另外两个富有权势的男人的庄园。他们说：“我们不同意。”
And he says to Moses, I'll give you $10,000 to fund surveys for the land if you don't cross my golf course. And Moses goes, sure, I'll do it. And that means shifting the route a little farther south, which goes through the estates of two other rich, powerful men. And they say, we don't want that.
而他说：“好吧。”于是他把路线继续向南挪，穿过了其他权贵们的庄园。我简直无法向你描述，当时长岛有多少土地是被富有而权势滔大的人占有的。他继续把路线往南延伸，结果侵占了一个名叫詹姆斯·罗斯（James Roth）的农民的土地。罗斯和他的妻子在1922年买下了这片土地，
And he goes, okay. And he shifts it further south through the estates of other powerful men. I cannot begin to tell you how much of Long Island was owned by rich, powerful men at this time. And he shifts it further south and outruns the land of a farmer named James Roth. And Roth and his wife, they had bought this land in 1922.
他们自己动手清理了树木和岩石。他们买下这块地甚至还没多久，转眼到了1927年，他们已经没日没夜地干了五年，农场刚刚开始有收益，他们本可以靠农场自给自足。这时，一名公园官员去告诉罗斯，公园大道将穿过他的土地。罗斯说：“你能不能把它往南移400英尺，这样它就会穿过我地里比较贫瘠的那部分？它依然会穿过我的土地，但不是我种地必须的那部分。”而得到的回答是：“不可能。这条路是根据工程学考量规划的。它就得从这里过。”我们前面说过，摩西
They cleared it of trees and rocks themselves themselves they haven't even owned it that long by now it's 1927 they've been working for five years non-stop the farm is just beginning to pay off they can support themselves on the farm when a parks official goes to tell Roth the parkway is going to go through your land and he says can you move it 400 feet south so that it'll go through the less fertile part of my fields? It'll still go through my fields, but not the part that I need to farm. And he's told that's impossible. This road has been laid out on the basis of engineering considerations. This is where it has to go. And we said Moses
为了富豪权贵可以把道路改道三英里，但为了一个农民，他连400英尺都不肯挪。道路建成了，把农场一分为二。现在，仅仅是为了播种和收割庄稼，他不得不花上50分钟进行单程往返、横穿马路，才能到达他田地的另一部分。农场再也无法盈利了。他们甚至无法把它卖掉，因为原本的一大块地，
will shift the road over three miles for the rich and the wealthy, but for a farmer he will not shift it 400 feet. The road is built. It cuts the farm in two. And now just to plant his fields and harvest his fields, he will not shift it 400 feet. The road is built, it cuts the farm in two. And now just to plant his fields and harvest his fields, he has to make a 50 minute both ways round trip across the road to get to the other part of his field. And the farm is no longer profitable. They can't even sell it because instead of one big field,
现在变成了两小块地。而他和遭遇同样命运的其他农民唯一的慰藉是，至少我们知道这条路不可能修在别的地方。这是他们唯一能修路的地方。卡罗再次插入自己的评论说：直到作者在40年后与他们以及其他农民交谈时，他们才意识到，这条路本可以穿过富人的庄园，而不是他们自己的田地。
it's now two small fields. And the only consolation that he and these other farmers that this happened to have are that at least we know the road couldn't have gone anywhere else. It was the only place they could have built this road. And Carro again inserts himself and says, not until the author talked to them and the other farmers 40 years later, did they think at any point that it could have gone through the rich estates instead of their own fields.
这再次证明了摩西的作风：他为了达成自己的项目愿意不惜一切代价。如果这意味着为了迎合富人而碾压农民，那他就会这么做。碾压，碾压，碾压。是的，这与我们曾经认识的那个老摩西背道而驰。这一部分读起来很纠结，因为他表面上依然在为一件好事而努力，对吧？
And it's just it's Moses again, he is willing to do whatever it takes to get his projects done. And if that means crushing farmers so that he can accommodate the wealthy, then he will do that. Crush, crush, crush. Yeah, and so against the old Moses that we used to know. And it's hard in this part because he's still doing this ostensibly
比如这依然是为了公园建设以及方便人们去公园，对吧？修路嘛，我的意思是。好吧，你总得去得了那里。虽然不完全是。你确实得去得了那里。但这就是他惯用的手段之一：
for like a good thing, right? Like it's still for the parks and getting to the parks, right? Road, I mean. Well, you gotta get. Less so. You do have to get there. But it is, one of these things that he uses
他把专业知识、工程学和科学当成大棒，来强行推行他想要的东西。因为他经常以此为借口，就像有人会问：“好吧，你为什么不能把路修在这边？你为什么不能这么做？”他就会摆出专家的架势说：“工程师们说了，这路只能修在这个地方。”
kind of expertise and engineering and science as this cudgel to get through what he wants because he'll often rest on this, just like somebody will say, well, why can't you build it over here? Why can't you do this? And he'll just like, engineers, man, like they told us this has to where it has to be,
而事实几乎从来都不是这样的，你知道的吗？但他确实对那些不敢反抗他的人使用这一招。这是一个极具说服力的论点，仿佛在说：“我想世界就是这样运转的吧。”但有钱人知道世界根本不是这样运转的。你知道的，如果你愿意，你可以花足够多的钱让路绕过某个地方。
which is almost never the case, you know? But he really does use that for people who won't stand against them. That's a really powerful argument of just like, I guess this is the way the world works. But rich people know that that's not the way the world works. You know, like that you can pay enough money to build around a thing if you want to.
但这些农民根本没有这种概念，他们也因此饱受苦难。这又是一个伏笔，书中到处都是伏笔，因为摩西的生活总是充满轮回。这为他后来在纽约市内部开展更大规模的项目埋下了伏笔，尤其是他后来为了修建跨布朗克斯高速公路（Cross Bronx Expressway），对布朗克斯的东特里蒙特（East Tremont）社区所做的一切。
But these farmers, they don't have a concept of this and they really suffer because of that. And it's a foreshadowing, again, there's so much foreshadowing because Moses' life lives in cycles. It's a foreshadowing of what's going to happen later on with his larger projects within New York City, and especially what he does to the East Tremont neighborhood of the Bronx much later
关于奥托·卡恩这段插曲，另一个值得注意的细节是，罗伯特·卡罗谈到自己采访罗伯特·摩西时，提到了“奥托·卡恩”这个名字，而罗伯特·摩西当时的反应是：“这次采访到此结束。”是的。因为他立刻就察觉到了。这就是他嗅出不对劲的时候，对吧？
to build the Cross Bronx Expressway. One thing that's also notable about this AutoCon moment is the moment where Robert Carrow talks about interviewing Robert Moses, and he mentions the name AutoCon, and Robert Moses is like, this interview is over. Yes. Because he knows immediately. That's when he sniffs it out, right?
当他心里想：“哦，等等。你不是只在歌颂我有多伟大吗？”是的，在卡罗坐在那里听了几个小时摩西滔滔不绝地讲述他那些伟大的项目、甚至讨论“那边是不是该修条路？对，应该修。没错，你说得对”之后，这就是卡罗提到的那个名字，而摩西却说：“我们的时间到了。音乐响了。你现在得离开了。”
When he's like, oh, wait a second. You're not just writing about how great I am? Yeah, after hours and hours of Carol sitting there while Moses regales him with tales of his amazing projects and shouldn't there be a road over there? There should be. Yeah, you're right. This is the name that Carol mentions and Moses says, our time is over. You got to like this. The music's playing. You're going to have to leave now.
这就很有意思了，因为相比于他做过的那么多极其恶劣的事情，他收受1万美元来稍微改道，在他所有的所作所为里其实只算是一个极其微小的过失。但我认为，这其中沾染了一种腐败的污点，而罗伯特·摩西对此有着强烈的过敏反应。你知道的，我认为这就是本质所在。就像他不会为此感到不安，他会说出这样的话：“哦，你知道的，当我准备把50万人从他们的社区移走时，暴民们确实很不高兴，但我们根本不理睬他们。”他在面对那种事情时毫无道德负担。
And it's interesting because it's kind of such a minor transgression on his part, like taking $10,000 to kind of move this compared to so many other things that he does that is so awful. But I think it has a kind of taint of corruption that Robert Moses is really allergic to. You know, I think that's the nature of it. Like he doesn't sort of, he'll say stuff like, oh, you know, like the rabble got upset when I was gonna move 500,000 of them, you know,
但这个小小的贿赂事件确实戳到了他的痛处，我想是这样的。我在想，这是不是——这是我在靠着椅背瞎琢磨，虽然我坐的是办公椅而不是扶手椅。我要是能坐张扶手椅就好了，比这把转椅舒服多了。我在想，这会不会是他回首往事时觉得：“这就是我真正开始堕落的起点。”
out of their neighborhood, but we just ignored them. And he has no compunction when it comes to that sort of thing. But this little payoff really sort of gets under his skin, I think. I wonder if there's, this is me armchair, psychological, even though I'm sitting in an office chair, not an armchair. I wish I was sitting in an armchair, it'd be more comfortable than this swivel chairman. I wonder if this is a moment that he looked back on as, this is the beginning of when I really changed for myself.
在此之前，我可以对自己说：“我在违法，但我这么做是为了阻止富人阻挠我为普通人建设设施。”而这件事情却是一个分水岭：不，我为了帮助富人而在伤害普通人——这是我以前从未真正做过的事。我在想，这对他来说是不是具有某种心理层面的重要意义，就像一种“原罪”，他无法像为其他行为开脱那样去解释它或为之合理化？也许吧。是的。我的意思是，我很喜欢这种解释。我的意思是，这正是读书会的意义所在——去琢磨你对这些深刻含义的理解，你知道的，我很喜欢这种解释。我的意思是，这就是读书会的意义所在，就是去弄清楚你对这些意义的看法，你知道的。
Before I could say, I am breaking the law, but I'm doing it to keep the rich from stopping me from building things for regular people. And this is the moment where it is, no, I'm hurting regular people to help the rich, something that I had not really done before. And I wonder if, I wonder then if it, if it had some kind of like psychological importance for him as, as a, you know, kind of like an original sin that he cannot, he can't explain it away or, or rationalize it the way he could his other stuff. Maybe. Yeah. I mean, I like that explanation for it. It's, I mean, this is what a book club is for. It's to sort of like figure out like what you think of these meanings, you know, I like that explanation for it. I mean, this is what a book club is for, is to sort of like figure out, like, what you think of these meanings, you know?
但我觉得这说得通，因为在经历了他做过的所有那些惊天动地的大事之后，这件事显得出奇地温和，而罗伯特·摩西居然会因为这件事而对罗伯特·卡罗说：“哦，我再也不想跟这个叫罗伯特·卡罗的家伙说话了，因为他提到了这笔交易”，这确实很不寻常。
But that makes sense to me because it strikes me as, you know, just like surprisingly mild for all the things that he has done, for this to be the thing that where Robert Moses really is like, oh, I don't want to talk to this Robert Carragher guy anymore because he brought up this one transaction is really something.
不，我的意思是，他肯定把这看作是他并非彻底失败、但又无法一手遮天的时刻，是的，也许这仍然让他感到恼火。还有一种可能是，他把这视为卡罗能够顺藤摸瓜的唯一一根松动的线头，他心里想：“哦，如果你连这个都知道，那你肯定也知道其他所有这些事。我们不能再谈下去了。”完全是这样，百分之百。如果你连奥托·卡恩的事都知道，这就好像，如果你——你一定找到了威尔科克斯（Wilcox）的信。
No, I mean, he just must think of it as like a time he didn't lose per se, but he, you know, he couldn't just run roughshod and yeah, maybe it still irked him. It's also possible that he saw that as the thread that the one loose thread that Carroll could pull that he's like, oh, if you know about that, you must know about all this other stuff. We cannot talk anymore. Totally. 100%. If you know about the auto-cut, it's like, if you, there's. You must've found the Wilcox letter.
没错。谁告诉你有人敢违抗我的？等一下。那可是绝密文件。罗伯特·摩西，他是个深藏不露的人。他手握权势，而且他拥有某种卡罗在这里没有深入探讨、但我却能读出其中潜台词的东西，那就是
Yeah. Who told you that someone ever defied me? Wait a second. That's supposed to be top secret. Robert Moses is, he's a sconce. He has power and he has something that Caro doesn't get into here, but which I was kind of reading the underlying subtext of it is
罗伯特·摩西差点就能获得更大权力的那个时刻。因为那是1928年6月，阿尔·史密斯（Al Smith）赢得了民主党总统候选人提名，摩西和他在贝尔莫斯（Belmont）一同庆祝这个好消息。摩西并没有参与竞选，因为阿尔·史密斯基本上对他说过：“当我竞选总统时，你就是代理州长。”没错。对于那些对他的生平故事不太熟悉的人来说，阿尔·史密斯之所以没能赢得总统大选，很大程度上是因为他本可能成为第一位天主教徒总统。当时仍然存在着这种强烈的反天主教偏见。你知道的，32年后，当约翰·F·肯尼迪（John F. Kennedy）竞选总统时，他依然不得不
this moment where Robert Moses almost gets access to even greater power because it's 1928 June Al Smith wins the Democratic nomination for president and Moses is there with him in Belmosk which they're celebrating the news Moses isn't involved with a campaign because Al Smith has basically said you are governor while I'm running for president. Right. And Al Smith, for people who are not familiar with his life story, does not win the presidency in a very large part because he would have been the first Catholic president. And there is still this intense anti-Catholic prejudice. You know, 32 years later, when John F. Kennedy is running for president, he still has to
面对这样一个事实：许多美国人并不信任天主教徒。而阿尔·史密斯在余生中都对因自己的出身而被剥夺总统宝座耿耿于怀。卡罗没有谈到这一点，但如果他真的当选总统，你不得不想象他可能会试着让摩西跟他一起去华盛顿。就像杰梅尔（Jamel）上一集所说的，你一上台就会把信任的人带在身边并给他们安排工作。我在想，摩西是否曾经设想过，如果那个最信任他、他也总是可以依赖的人最终成为了美利坚合众国的总统，他自己又会变成什么样？
deal with the fact that a lot of the Americans do not trust Catholics. And Al Smith for the rest of his life is kind of bitter about he was denied this thing because of who he was. And Carol doesn't talk about it, but if he was president, you have to imagine he might have tried to get Moses to come with him. That, you know, Jamel was saying last episode, you get into office and you bring the people that you trust with you and get them jobs. And I wonder if Moses ever wondered about what he might have been if the man who trusted him more than anything else and who he always relied on him, he could always rely on became the president of
特别是正如我们所看到的，他的一位死敌后来确实当上了总统，虽然这并没有彻底阻止他的脚步，但也确实让他感到相当烦恼。没错。这确实在某些事情上阻挠了他，对吧？有些事情。某些事情，微不足道的，是的，一些事情。我们会深入探讨这些细节。但摩西的心态是：还有那么多事情等着去做呢。我现在是代理州长，但还有那么多工作没完成。
the United States of America. Especially because as we'll see, one of his diehard enemies does become president later and it doesn't stop him that much, but it annoys him quite a bit. Right. It stops things for him, right? There are certain things. Certain things, small, yeah, some things. We'll get into those details. But Moses is like, there's still so much left to do. I'm the acting governor right now, but there's still so much left to do.
我必须在下一任州长上任之前建完南部州际公园大道，好让人们看到它是多么伟大。这样新州长就无法阻止我做更多的事了。我还得修完通往琼斯海滩的这条路，好让人们见识到它的宏伟。随着1928年的结束，他仍然以疯狂的节奏派遣着工人。他必须在这些道路上完成更多的工作。第15章在第282页就这样结束了：“那些与罗伯特·摩西亲近的人知道，他的这种紧迫感是有正当理由的，
I've got to finish the Southern State Parkway before the next governor comes in so that people can see how great it is. And the new governor won't be able to stop me from doing more. And I got to complete this road to Jones beach so people can see how great that is. And as 1928 ends, he's still sending out workers this furious pace. He's got to do more work on these roads. And the chapter ends thusly on page 282. Those close to Robert Moses knew that there was justification for his urgency, a
那种似乎已经渗透到他匆忙行事之中的绝望感，背后是有原因的。‘要不是阿尔·史密斯对我的信任，’摩西后来谈到阿尔·史密斯时说道，‘我什么也做不成。’他曾拥有阿尔·史密斯及其绝对的信任长达十年之久，但现在，他再也不会拥有阿尔·史密斯了。而接替摩西最伟大的朋友坐上州长宝座的那个人，正是摩西最死心塌地的死敌。”第15章完。咚、咚、咚。
reason for the desperation, which now seemed to underlie his haste. Without his loyalty to me, Moses was to say about Al Smith, I could have done nothing. He had had Al Smith and his loyalty for 10 years, but now he was to have Al Smith no more. And the man who was to follow Moses' greatest friend into the governor's chair was Moses' deadliest enemy. End of chapter 15. Dun, dun, dun.
所以纽约选出了骷髅王（Skeletor），对吧？是的，完全正确。在1928年。这就是，纽约真的走在了全国其他地区的前面，因为全国其他地区不肯选出一个天主教徒，而纽约却选出了一个来自埃特尼亚（Eternia）的邪恶骷髅术士，甚至都不是在美国出生的。
So New York elected Skeletor, correct? Yes, exactly. In 1928. That was the, New York was really ahead of the rest of the country because the rest of the country wouldn't elect a Catholic, and New York would elect an evil the rest of the country, because the rest of the country wouldn't elect a Catholic, and New York would elect an evil skeleton warlock from Atternia, not even born in the United States.
天哪。卡罗用这种“咚、咚、咚”的语气来形容一个在许多方面都温文尔雅、尽管显然权力极大的政客，真是太搞笑了。一个极权人物，因为在下一集的《权力掮客解密》（The power broker breakdown）节目中，
Oh, God. It's just so funny that, like, Caro is doing this like, bum, bum, bum, about like a, you know, a genteel politician in many ways, although a very powerful one, obviously. A very powerful one, because, so the next episode of the power broker breaking down power broker breakdown breakdown show, uh, we're going to find out who is Moses's deadliest enemy.
我们将揭晓摩西最大的死敌究竟是谁。我给你个提示。他的名字缩写是FDR。接下来还会发生什么？摩西将要“占领曼哈顿”（Take Manhattan），而且他产生的影响将比当年的布偶艺人（Muppets）占领曼哈顿还要持久得多。我们终于可以看到更多关于吉米·沃克（Jimmy Walker）的故事了——那个圆滑浮华的花花公子政客。他现在是市长了，在中央公园里拥有了自己的赌场。我们终于要深入探讨卡罗对摩西以及卸任州长后的阿尔·史密斯提出的真正种族主义指控了。他将在中央公园动物园获得
I'll give you a hint. His initials are FDR and then what else is going to happen? Moses is going to take Manhattan and he's going to have such a more lasting impact than the Muppets had when they took Manhattan. We're finally going to get to see more of Jimmy Walker, the, uh, the, you know, slimy dandy politician. He's mayor now and he's got his own casino in Central Park. We're finally going to get into the genuine accusations of racism that Carol has for Moses and Al Smith after his governorship. He's going to get his
属于他自己的钥匙，在我看来，那是一个如此美丽而感人的时刻。这虽然无法弥补摩西背负的种族主义指控，但摩西确实一直在照顾着这位前州长。这些以及更多精彩内容，尽在下期节目。罗曼（Roman），我们在下一集要涵盖哪些页码？我们将涵盖从第16章《鸡毛掸子》到第21章之间的第283页到第401页。这就是下一集的《99%无形》之《权力掮客》解密节目。大卫·西姆斯（David Sims），
own key to the Central Park Zoo in what is, I find to be such a beautiful and touching moment. It doesn't make up for the accusations of racism that Moses has, but Moses does to keep taking care of the governor. That's going to be all that and so much more. Roman, what pages are we covering in the next episode? We'll be covering pages 283 to 401 from chapter 16, the feather duster, to chapter 21 year. And that's the next episode of the 99% invisible breakdown of the power broker. David Sims, it was such
很高兴能邀请你来这里做客。这太美妙了，谢谢你让我时隔15年左右第一次重新翻开这本书。在接下来的系列节目中，我将迫不及待地与你一同阅读，并且我很荣幸能被视为——你知道的。按照这种说法，我被视为与罗伯特·卡罗平起平坐的人。是的，我想这绝对就是那么回事。是的，你必须这么说。你、杰梅尔、柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien），你们都在同一个——
a pleasure to have you here. It's been delightful and thank you for making me crack this book open for the first time in like 15 years. I'm going to be reading along with you eagerly for the rest of this series and I'm honored to be, you know, considered. The way this works is that I'm considered an equal of Robert Caro. Yeah, I think that's exactly how that works. Yeah, you gotta say that. You, Jamell, Conan, O'Brien, you're all on the same,
你们都在同一个水平线上。我们是同行。你们是同事。没错，没错。能请教你一个问题吗？既然你在这儿，你看了很多电影，你是一位影评人。过去曾有过无数次尝试，或者至少有人买下了这本书的改编版权，
you're all on the same level. We're peers. You're colleagues. That's right, that's right. Can I ask you, while we have you, you watch a lot of movies, you're a movie critic. There's been numerous attempts, or at least people have optioned the rights to this book
并试图以不同的方式讲述罗伯特·摩西的故事。你认为要把它拍成一部优秀的影视作品，需要具备什么条件？我的意思是，我不知道这是否可能。而且我也担心，它当然会被拍成那种冗长拖沓的、10集流媒体精品剧。
and have tried to tell the story of Robert Moses in different ways. What do you think it would take for this to be a good piece of filmed entertainment? I mean, I don't know that it's possible. And I also would fear that, of course, it would be turned into a sort of sludgy, 10-episode prestige streaming drama.
倒不是说这必然是件坏事，显然，被拍成那种冗长拖沓的10集流媒体精品剧。倒不是说这必然是件坏事，显然，考虑到这是一个宏大的故事架构，就像克林特·伊斯特伍德（Clint Eastwood）拍的埃德加·胡佛（J. Edgar Hoover）电影那样，对吧？埃德加·胡佛在某种程度上与美国的罗伯特·卡罗是一个非常类似的人物。罗伯特·摩西，罗伯特·摩西，不是罗伯特·卡罗。埃德加·胡佛和罗伯特·卡罗其实没什么共同点。我想澄清这一点。你知道那些调查人员，他们掌握着秘密情报。
Not that that would be necessarily bad, obviously, turned into a sort of sludgy 10 episode prestige streaming drama. Not that that would be necessarily bad, obviously, given that it's like a large sort of story to tell when you think of like the Clint Eastwood, J. Edgar Hoover movie, right? Like J. Edgar Hoover is sort of very similar figure to Robert Caro in American. Robert Moses, Robert Moses, not Robert Carrow. J. Edgar Hoover and Robert Carrow have very little in common. I want to be clear about that. You know the investigators, they find secret information.
就像，你知道的，我几年前读过《G战警》（G-Man）——那是一本关于胡佛的大部头传记。而且，这也是另一个人，在某个特定时刻，人们会问：“你怎么什么都知道、认识所有人，而且我怎么也甩不掉你？”以至于每一任后来的总统都不得不向他低头示好，而不是反过来。为什么事情会是这样的？而且，
Like, you know, I read G-Man, which was this big biography of Hoover a couple of years ago. And like, it's another, he's another guy where it's sort of at a certain point, people are like, how do you know everything and know everyone and I can't get rid of you. And every subsequent president has to kiss his hand versus the other way around. Like, why does it work this way? And, uh,
就像克林特·伊斯特伍德的电影那样，只是试着去讲述：“好吧，埃德加·胡佛曾经是个年轻人，后来变老了。”我们只是草草带过。我可能会尝试采用这样一种方式：让我们专注于晚年60年代的摩西，当他表现得像是在说：“我觉得公园里不该上演莎士比亚戏剧”的时候。你知道的，当他最终变成一个真正的卡通反派时，以及，你知道的——
like Clint Eastwood's movie just tries to do like, okay, well, uh, Jager Hoover was a young man and he aged into an old man. And we're just going to rush through it. I would probably try to do more of a, like, let's, uh, let's concentrate on Moses at the end in the sixties when he's like, I don't think there should be Shakespeare in the park. You know, when he's like, you know, finally turned into an actual cartoon villain and, and you know,
就像克林ต์·伊斯特伍德的电影试图做的那样，好吧，胡佛年轻时是个小伙子，后来老了。而我们只是打算匆忙带过。我可能会尝试多做一些这样的事，比如，让我们集中精力关注60年代末期的摩西，当时他大概在想，我认为公园里不该上演莎士比亚戏剧。你知道的，当他最终变成一个真正的卡通反派时，而且你知道的
parallel it with this time in his life, right? With, with the, with the accumulation of power in the twenties and you know, the ways in which he's maybe started out somewhat idealistically and figured out the best ways to get things done was not very idealistic. I don't know. That's probably the approach, but it's a really hard story to tell in less than 1300 pages, which is what Robert Caro, that's his name, I got it right, learned when he wrote this book.
把他人生中的这个时期作个平行对比，对吧？伴随着20年代权力的积累，你知道，他一开始可能有点理想主义，但后来发现完成事情的最佳方式其实并不那么理想主义。我不知道。这大概就是方法，但要在不到1300页的篇幅里讲清楚这个故事真的很难，罗伯特·卡罗——对，就是这个名字，我没记错——他在写这本书时就意识到了这一点。
It's so hard to get across the scope and those details while boiling it down. And this is something I only thought about until just now. So tell me if I'm off my rocker with this, the only movie I can think of that gets across this same kind of feeling is there's a section of the Russian movie, Andrey Rublev. It's a Tarkovsky movie from 1966, where this young guy is put in charge of making an enormous bell for his town's church. And to get it done, he is pushing the workers so hard and he becomes a tyrant. And they're like, this isn't how your dad who we were for used to do it. And he's like, this is how I do it now.
要在精简篇幅的同时展现宏大的视野和那些细节是如此困难。而且这是我刚才才想到的。所以如果我觉得离谱，请告诉我，我能想到的唯一一部能传达出这种同样感觉的电影，是俄罗斯电影《安德烈·鲁布廖夫》中的一个片段。那是塔科夫斯基1966年的一部电影，讲的是一个年轻人被委任为镇上的教堂制造一口巨大的钟。为了完成任务，他疯狂地催促工人们，结果自己变成了一个暴君。工人们说，我们曾经效力的你父亲可不是这么干的。而他说，现在我就是这么干的。
And he is in such tension hoping that the bell doesn't fail when it's finished, because that's the end of his life if this bell doesn't fail when it, when it's finished, because that's the end of his life, if this bell doesn't work. And it, I feel like that movie was the only time I've seen something that gets across the idea of someone who is so invested in a construction building project, that they're giving up everything and they're pushing people to their limits and it becomes their entire life and their whole being and all they're focused on is the end point and they don't care how they get there. I mean, there's other movies that do that,
他内心充满紧张，祈祷着大钟完工后不要失败，因为如果这口钟失败了，那就是他生命的终结。如果这口钟不能运作，那就是他生命的终结。我觉得那部电影是我见过的唯一一部能传达这种感觉的作品：一个人对一个建筑工程投入如此之深，以至于他放弃了一切，把人们逼到了极限，这成了他的全部生活和整个存在，他关心的只有终点，而不在乎他如何到达那里。我的意思是，还有其他电影也能做到这一点，
but I feel like it does it in a very concentrated way. And it's, you don't have to watch the rest of the movie. If you don't want to, you just skip ahead to that part. It's in chapters, but I feel like that, that gets it across. So maybe the last chapter for when I remember. Right. So maybe if we get, if we can bring Andre Tarkovsky back to life, he died in 1986, maybe bring him back. Maybe he can do it. I don't know. That would be great. I would love Tarkovsky back to life. He died in 1986. Maybe bring him back. Maybe he can do it. I don't know. That would be great.
但我感觉它以一种非常集中的方式做到了这一点。而且你不需要看电影的其余部分。如果你不想看，可以直接跳到那部分。它是分章节的，但我觉得，那确实传达了这种感觉。所以也许当我记住的时候就是最后一章。对吧。所以如果我们能让安德烈·塔科夫斯基起死回生——他在1986年去世了——也许把他带回来。也许他能做到。我不知道。那太棒了。我很想让塔科夫斯基复活。他在1986年去世了。也许把他带回来。也许他能做到。我不知道。那太棒了。
I would love Tarkovsky to be revived, told all about Robert Moses, who he might not know too much about, and then set to work. Yes, on recreating his life. Can I see my family? Can I see how they turned out? No, get to work on the movie.
我很想让塔科夫斯基复活，向他详细介绍罗伯特·摩西（他可能对摩西不太了解），然后让他开始工作。是的，重新创作他的一生。我能见见我的家人吗？我能看看他们过得怎么样吗？不，快去工作拍电影。
How's Russia doing? Don't worry about it, Andrei. We need you to read this book. Oh boy. Again, David, it was a pleasure. Can you tell people where they can find your work and find you? Yes, of course.
俄罗斯现在怎么样？别担心，安德烈。我们需要你读这本书。天哪。再次感谢，大卫，这真是太愉快了。你能告诉大家去哪里可以找到你的作品和找到你吗？好的，当然。
I'm a film critic at the Atlantic where you can read my reviews of films and such. And I host the podcast, Blank Check, with Griffin and David, with my cohost Griffin Newman, where we tackle directors filmographies movie by movie, directors who have gotten a Moses-esque blank check to make a crazy passion project at some point in their life. And Roman and Elliot have both been on
我是《大西洋月刊》的一名影评人，在那里你可以阅读我对电影等的评论。我还是播客《Blank Check with Griffin and David》的主持人，我的联合主持人是格里芬·纽曼，我们一部接一部地探讨导演的电影作品，这些导演在人生的某个阶段都获得了类似于摩西的“空白支票”，用来制作一个疯狂的挚爱项目。罗曼和埃利奥特都曾上过节目，
and both should return. I would love to, I love your show. It is my favorite good movie podcast. Good save. Good save, Roman. Of course. Of course. I saw you about to say favorite movie podcast and you caught yourself and you saw me glaring at you. But again, it was great to have you here.
而且都应该再来。我很乐意，我喜欢你的节目。这是我最喜欢的优秀电影播客。圆得好。圆得好，罗曼。当然。当然。我看到你刚要说最喜欢的电影播客，然后你及时刹住了车，你看到我在瞪你。不过再次感谢你能来到这里。
Thank you so much. Thank you guys, seriously. That's it for this episode. Again, next month we'll be covering chapters 16 through 20. That's the middle chunk of part four, the use of power. And remember to join our Discord server. You'll be able to connect with other Power Broker fans and keep the discussion going. The link is on our website or you can go to discord.gg slash 99PI. We did an AMA there a couple couple weeks ago and it was so fun.
非常感谢。谢谢你们，说真的。本期节目就到这里。同样，下个月我们将讨论第16到第20章。那是第四部分“权力的使用”的中间部分。记得加入我们的Discord服务器。你将能够与其他《权力掮客》的粉丝交流，并继续讨论。链接在我们的网站上，或者你可以访问 discord.gg 斜杠 99PI。我们在几周前在那里做过一次AMA（问答），非常有趣。
So keep an eye out for other events. And as always, you can check me out on my other podcast, The Flophouse, which I must assume is Roman's favorite bad movie podcast. It absolutely is my favorite bad movie podcast. The 99% invisible breakdown of The Power Broker is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by committee, music by Swan Real, mix by Dara Hirsch.
所以请留意其他活动。像往常一样，你可以在我的另一个播客《The Flophouse》上找到我，我必须假设这是罗曼最喜欢的烂片播客。这绝对是我最喜欢的烂片播客。《99%无形》对《权力掮客》的剖析由伊莎贝尔·安杰尔制作，委员会编辑，音乐由斯旺·里尔制作，混音由达拉·赫尔希完成。
99PI's executive producer is Cathy Tu, our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, the rest of the team includes Sarah Bake, Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lash Madon, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, as well as our Discord server, the aforementioned Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the normal social media sites, as well as our Discord server, the aforementioned Discord server, which is our favorite place to hang out right now. You can find a link to that and every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. That's too bad you picked the one fictional universe I don't know well enough to talk in.
99PI的执行制片人是凯茜·图，我们的资深编辑是德兰妮·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，团队的其他成员包括莎拉·贝克、克里斯·伯鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉什·马顿、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、凯利·普赖姆，以及我们的Discord服务器，也就是前面提到的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市Uptown。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站上找到我们，还有我们的Discord服务器，也就是前面提到的Discord服务器，这是我们现在最喜欢闲逛的地方。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到该链接以及 99PI 以往的每一期节目。真遗憾，你挑了一个我所知甚少、无法插话的虚构世界。
I mean, if we want to talk about it in terms of the Dune world, we could talk about it that way, you know. But anyway. Okay, you well, I mean, no, no, sorry, go on. So he's like the melange spice that you need for navigation, you know. Hahaha! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的意思是，如果我们想用《沙丘》世界来谈论它，我们也可以那样谈论，你知道的。但无论如何。好吧，你，我的意思是，不，不，抱歉，你继续。所以他就像你导航所需的美琅脂香料，你知道的。哈哈！本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。